Fred's missing and uh Jason's missing
missing I can't can't leave my guy
that's right me you were the only one
apparently it's all right we'll get it
done you were up all night were all
right so$ 12299 um was the bill dealing
with the fire educator for the community
college system um wanting to add that in
uh for people who can continue to stay
in group two after they've had 10 years
of fire service experience um testimony
about this bill was all negative I don't
think we had any um positive uh
testimony on it um it seemed to me that
uh there were a couple of reasons for
that uh negative testimony there were
oppositional testimony um the first was
uh the 10 years fire service experience
wasn't enough time after 10 to go into a
position like this and be able to stay
in group two which was primarily created
um because of the risk to life and limb
um the benefit was primarily for that
was just not enough time of investment
um to move over to this kind of position
and maintain group two status and I
understand that and the other is concern
about other people who would like to get
into group two who upon seeing this
might think well here's reason for us to
be able to get into group two as well um
so what I have proposed as the bill
stands um
I I there seems to be pretty much
unanimous consent among all of the
players anyway that uh the bill should
be it and I don't think that there's
been much support on the committee from
anybody I've talked to either however
I'm floating this idea in um this
0300 that if the fire educator for the
community college system had 20 years of
fire service experience in the field
then then they would be able to move
over into the position and keep their
group to benefits um my reasoning for
that and I've talked to a few people um
on the issue is it seems to me that the
fire educator in the community college
system should be somebody who has some
field experience yeah no question and
and you are asking those people with the
field experience to give up a tremendous
amount of their benefit that they've
earned hey there's a guy now we can take
a vote come sit now you're great
couldn't be happier to see
you
um you're asking them to take a huge hit
to their benefit to come over to this
educator um position and uh so I can
understand why they would be reticent to
do so um at 20 years they've they've
completed most of their retirement um
obligation um as far as service is cons
concerned and we do have some other
positions that they can move into um
such as a a fire chief who are no longer
traditionally dealing directly oh yeah
um
Amendment thank you see
right talking highlighted highlighted
yeah the B the bolded part um such as a
fire chief who um although is still an
integral part of you know the
firefighting system is no longer
traditionally going out and figh
fighting the fires himself um so I think
that we do have some um
some examples that we can go by there
yeah precedent thank you um so I wanted
to float this idea out there because I
do think that there needs to be some way
for for people who have actual field
experience to be able to take these
positions um so that we're getting
Educators who have field experience and
aren't just um you know armchair
philosophers to a certain extent um
because these are the people who are
going to be training the people who are
in the field and the people in the field
are the ones who going to be protecting
our citizens um so that was my thought
I'll open it up for any comments from
the subcommittee or from the room as
well if I
might I think your points are well taken
uh especially the idea that somebody who
already has 20 years in and has that
that 20 years acral of benefits and so
forth and so on to sacrifice all that uh
for the purp
in the interest of becoming a a trainer
or educator is a that's a big sacrifice
so I I think your your language here is
um I'm amenable to
that excellent J any comments anybody
from the room I know it was mostly
negative so please feel free to come up
concerns yes please oh yes people may
want to watch from the outside and they
can't hear you without it I wasn't sure
this type of meeting was also streamed
um I'm Shannon Reed I'm here
representing the community college
system and we had testified in
opposition to this bill at the hearing
um this is the first time seeing or
hearing of the amendment so I haven't
really had a chance to review it with
others in my organization but I think
that you know we would still be
concerned about a couple of things one
is creating two separate classifications
within our faculty Workforce within nhrs
um and and two is again that this could
open a a wider door to faculty and other
disciplines like um all of our criminal
justice programs and most of many of our
instructors are people who who come from
municipal or state police forces or some
other um law enforcement entity um I'm
pretty sure but I will need to confirm
this
that field experience is probably a
requirement of this of this job so it's
not a it's not it's not a situation
where um because we currently don't have
someone maintaining group two we
therefore would end up with instructors
who don't have field experience I think
that that for this program in particular
is is likely a requirement if not
something that's um something that we
would 100% look for in hiring an
instructor so those those remain our
concerns that we we don't we don't want
to create this kind of separate Avenue
to nhrs classification within our
faculty Workforce thank you um and I'm
glad that you're here because you were
the very person that I was hoping was
going to show up because you're the one
person who's outside of just the you
know group two retirement um um kind of
Paradigm um if you could speak more
specifically if you wouldn't mind to the
concerns of having the two groups is it
administrative is it um fairness is it
what are your concerns I think it's as I
reviewed this with rhr folks internally
I think the concern is fairness and
Equity Within our within our faculty um
our faculty across the community college
system are one bargaining unit um
they're we we try as hard as we can to
maintain Equity within that group um in
terms of pay and compensation it's all
kind of consistent and we would like to
maintain that within that um employee
group um in your opinion
um how many other faculty
members might be affected by this might
look at it and say oh wait if they can
do that then how about us because you
mentioned criminal justice and and
things of that nature I'm just trying to
get a feel for the right I think there'd
be two Avenues one is kind of program
specific and folks coming into teaching
in in criminal justice or in a Homeland
Security we have we have those um
programs as well and and second would
simply be someone who's who whose
background and professional career has
been in one of those fields who comes
into teach in any other profession which
is certainly possible we have folks who
might have a background in Criminal
justice and human services who come to
teach in a Human Service profession but
but had been members of group two so I
think there are a couple areas where you
could see some of that
um leakage isn't quite the right word
but you could see some of that that door
opening to additional folks Beyond just
the fire okay uh one last question from
me if you don't mind um what would be
your concern about the benefits
spreading to those other
individuals well cost would be be one I
mean the cost when it's one person or
two is fairly minimal as we outlined in
our fiscal note to this bill um the more
we the more of those folks we we are
covering you know in terms of their um
the benefits I think it's about two and
a half times the cost for benefits if
you're group two as opposed to group one
so at some point that does that does add
up in a college budget which are pretty
tight um I'm sorry your question was our
concerns about other people I think
again just would come back to that um
the concept of equity within a an
employee group right and that's what I
was saying if the equity if we say we
were not philosophically opposed to it
spreading to those other individuals and
them also being able to to take that
same benefit the primary concern at that
point wouldn't be Equity of be cost yes
okay and again this is just um this is
just I'm kind of thinking out loud here
I I would ideally like to and the timing
might not permit that but I would
ideally like to have vetted this
particular idea more internally with
some of my colleagues but um you know
based on my conversations with them so
far I think what I'm saying is is fairly
um fairly reflective of what they would
also think sure yeah um and I mean this
will still have to go before the full
committee anyway so you would even if we
passed this amendment out of the
subcommittee today you would still have
time probably to get some feedback to us
before we were at the full committee
stage unfortunately you know how
legislation goes it's got to keep
marching so of course
but um any other questions for yeah
Representative
no if nobody else wants to weigh in at
this point art are
you just
comment yeah just want I'll have you
come up in just a sec yeah uh I I think
the other aspect is the reverse of what
we were talking about before that
somebody if they've got 20 years in all
that acrude benefit and so forth to
sacrifice that to to go into the other
thing but the reality is how many people
are there out there that are going to
are going to be 20y year veterans who
would be would fall into this category
um and therefore and also who would want
to teach because that's what we're
talking about that's that's one of the
Prime criteria uh for you know allowing
them to be into the group is that they
have all the background
so they're not teaching or something
they learn in a book but they don't have
any practical experience so just
thought well thank you very much I
appreciate you thank you and I guess I
would just say by closing if I if I may
that I think this amendment certainly
makes sense when you're looking at an
individual's kind
of pathway but our our concerns are more
kind of institutionally based yeah no
you
come join
us thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
Arthur bodri I represent the New
Hampshire State permanent firefighters
retirement Association I'm not going to
speak in favor or against this but
um as I stated in my original testimony
that group two was set up because of
life expectancy and the rigor of the job
um educators are in group one because
the the life expectancy is longer and
the rigor is not as as much as being a
firefighter
um what you did I think is is better
than 10 years but when I look at group
one they're in group one right now
that's why they have a um a split
benefit clause in the retirement system
so this individual could work 20 years
in there as group to collecting
depending on when they joined it could
be 2% or two and a half percent and then
go into group one and they would collect
they would start U collecting 1.67% a
year but they'd also be eligible for
Social Security so I would look at
somebody that has 20 years of service
depending on their age if they're in
their
40s it might be beneficial for them to
stay in group one and collect the 1.67%
and be eligible for full Social Security
then going into group two and not being
eligible for so Social Security so it it
is something that the individuals are
going to have to look at when it comes
to that that point but 20 years is a lot
more palatable than 10 years because
like I said group two should be for
high-risk jobs and and jobs that your
life expectancy is is is less than a
normal
population thank you um just a point of
clarification because I it's hard to
remember everything the windfall act how
would that how would that affect in this
situation though I mean yes they're they
qualify for Social Security but at some
point doesn't that I think they the
group two time will still put them under
the windfall act um but probably not as
great because they're going to have more
years of service working in Social
Security and I don't I don't know the
formula but social security has a
formula of how much how many years
you've worked in you know as a police
officer or a firefighter and how many
years you've worked you know as a social
security recipient so they have a
formula I'm not sure but I this
individual would still be under the
windfall act uh I believe going forward
okay
any other
questions thank you thank you very much
time so I mean we've got a few things to
take into consideration obviously uh
things that we're trying to balance and
and from my perspective the primary
thing that I'm trying to kind of wrap my
mind around is the purpose of the
program purpose of the program from
everything that I've been able to glean
is to prepare firefighters for work in
the
field um in order to do that well I just
I I don't see how we do that without
somebody who has field experience and
we're having a hard time getting people
with field experience to come over
because they've got to change over their
benefits package and why not just
stay in working in a way that allows
them to acrew that group to benefit um
so we we lost instructors according to
testimony anyway we lost instructors
last year over that very reason because
they would have to change over to group
one from group two um so I would just uh
from my own perspective as I'm kind of
processing this the way that I've been
you know kind of thinking about it um is
we are when it comes to other
instructors we're not it's not we're not
setting a precedent as a wide open door
they'd have to have 20 years of field
experience before we would even consider
allowing them to stay in group two this
isn't for new hires this isn't for
somebody with 12 years experience
they've had to have 20 years experience
to your point representative Smith they
have to want to be faculty member and
teach at that point which isn't for
everybody who goes into this profession
um for sure
um and I don't know I mean I I'd have to
hear testimony on it but I'm just
curious to know whether or not it
wouldn't be beneficial to have some of
the people in those other professions
with 20 years of experience be able to
stay in group two and come over and
instruct I I don't want to say no to
this one just because we're afraid
somebody else might also qualify if we
feel like those other people qualifying
might be a reasonable and good thing and
uh I say that completely recognizing um
the school's position of expense
and administrative complication um so
I'm not completely ignoring that um just
trying to weigh the two and figure out
comments
I think you've expressed the situation
well it's a balancing there's no
question about it you're giving up
something uh to uh if you don't have the
20 years experience and the 20 years the
20 years are cruel that's a key aspect
something that you're giving up a lot of
benefit on the other hand Mr bod's point
that uh you know
that uh um well it's slipped my mind
this is that very moment
but but your point is also very well
taken uh and so it is a balancing and
again it's not mandatory that's saying
when you get to if you're still in the
service at at that point now you get
shifted they can
choose not everybody wants to be a
teacher some people are eager to
demonstrate their skill and they they
always want to show other people what
they can do and so forth and so on but
not everybody wants to get up in front
of the
please thank you just just one one point
I would like to make is that this this
bill you're you're speaking about it as
if it's a bill that would um help the
community college system but we're not
asking for this bill the college system
is not seeking this bill we we believe
we can fill this position without this
provision so um you know in so far as
you're looking at ways to kind of
bolster our ability to provide
appropriate instruction we we don't
believe that A change is necessary to
enable us to do that yes thank
you all right
um I'm going to keep pondering it for
the next 20 minutes anyway we'll come
back to
it let's go we got a few other bills we
got to hit
so um
1211 um relative to part-time employment
of the retirement system um so we hear
this bill every year I feel like um from
testimony and conversations that I've
had I feel like we're in the same spot
we always are which is there's there's
no need uh for this bill people who are
working part-time aren't coming close to
their maximum allowance as it is so
increasing the maximum number of hours
that they can work um is I don't think
it's going to do anything uh to help the
situation and it does create
a whole lot of complication uh into the
system so uh I personally am not in
favor of this bill but I'll entertain
any comments from anybody on the
subcommittee or any thoughts that
it I agree with your point all right if
that's the case on 1211 I'm going to
move that we recommend itl to the full
committee on HB 1211 do have a second on
that
Peter
any further
comment all right all all in favor it's
easiest that way all right so 30 on itl
all right we'll make that recommendation
to the full committee
then
um
1421 um relative to investment
consulting services in the New Hampshire
retirement system uh my impression from
uh rep Mr Carlin's
um explanation of the situation was that
uh there was some misunderstanding of
how we handle this um the independent
investment firms aren't the ones
actually making the investment choices
the board is they're just paying for
consultation uh and information so I
don't think that the spell would do what
the sponsor wanted it to do um that's my
committee
okay yeah representative peon would you
like to join us this your
it
uh it simply because the
um what I want to have happen and what I
want the investment committee to do this
bill will not make that happen right
it's not going to do it what we still
have some issues with what they're doing
or not doing is really the problem what
they're not doing um but I think that
we're going to have to figure
out a little bit different way of making
the pressure be applied um keeping in
mind that we have a
the legislature has a separation from
the retirement system in the sense that
we're not permitted to micromanage them
but we can
certainly remind them that the term
fiduciary responsibility is not a
buzzword it actually does mean something
so but in this case yes this bill is is
uh is not going to do it it's not going
to get it there yeah yeah so thank you
for your testimony appreciate it
uh that being the case I will move that
we recommend itl on 1421 to the full
committee do I have a
J any further
comments no oh okay all in favor all
right
three all right um so
1307 is a bill that is looking for a
one-time uh Cola of $500 to be paid to
retired members of the retirement system
receiving an allowance or beneficiary of
such member for survivorship uh pension
benefit who are eligible with the
following criteria um so as a general
rule on this bill uh my position is I'm
totally fine with it uh I feel like this
when the cola went through last year
these people should have been included
in that Cola they were left out I like
that's pretty much just an oversight uh
the only question and I don't have an
official amendment I would have to go
get one so we wouldn't be able to vote
on it today if this was the case excuse
me if you can describe you could
describe the amendment clearly and the
subcommittee knows exactly what they're
voting on you can do it and then get the
amendment and bring it to the Z session
perfect thank you madam
chair um so it would be to raise the
threshold to $50,000 and would you like
thank you Mr chairman I don't have to
say my name again do I you no it's just
a sub commmittee meeting um the $50,000
as I testified on this bill uh group two
the the median uh or the actually the
average uh earnings for a Group Two Fire
is about
$45,000 um so uh it every every time
they have a stiping I wouldn't call this
a cola because a cola in my opinion is
put on your base and compounded this is
a stien um so the group two has been
left out we've uh we've put in two bills
in the last two years for for colas and
they ended up turning them into stiens
and reducing the the number to 30,000 to
40,000 which pretty much wipes out a
good number of group two people um so by
putting this to 50 uh $50,000 I believe
um um mty had mentioned that it could be
anywhere from 70 to 80 additional uh
members would be eligible for this stien
if you put it to the 50,000 and that was
what we re requested and I know the
sponsor was was supportive of that
also um yeah at such a small number of
people I I personally don't have any
problem with that anybody else everybody
feel okay with that thank you very much
appr um so I would like to put in an
amendment to to raise it to the
$50,000 threshold
um and I would make a motion to
recommend to the committee OTP as
amended with the $50,000 threshold do I
second guys I got people fighting over
it this is
great so who's my
official well Jason put your hand yeah
okay all right I'll in favor all right
three Z all right we'll make that
recommendation to the committee see how
they feel about about it all right um to
the to the big one HB
that
just for the record Mr chairman I may
have misheard I thought you said 1467
and in point of fact it is
1647 so just Ju Just to correct the
record yeah yeah you heard the same my
dislexia kicked in again I apologize for
those who are the vast television
audience tuning
in all right so uh when we met last uh
we were looking over the language of the
bill and realized that there were a few
things missing so this um Amendment uh
well actually this amendment changes the
bill to reduce the overall cost um by
limiting some of the people who would
qualify for the increased 2.5%
multiplier um so in two different
sections we've added the language um but
only for group two members in service
who have attained age regardless of the
number years of credible service or who
work their full age and service
requirements and retire under service
retirement if a member retires prior to
reaching the full age and service
requirements then their uh annuity
multiplier Remains the Same as their
first 10 years of credible service um so
this was both looked at as a cost saving
measure on this bill and also as a
potential retention um because if you
don't stay to your full retirement um
obligations uh you're going to lose so a
fairly significant part of your benefit
um so it might encourage people to stay
longer um while also cutting cost to the
bill uh so that that gets thrown in
there in the two sections uh that have
to do with um the new 2.5% multiplier uh
eligibility for that multiplier so that
would be on page one lines 12 through 16
and on page two lines 6 through
11 uh the other thing that we changed in
the bill comes on line
32 um because of the the change that we
made uh we also said that members who
retire upon ordinary disability um or
qualify for accidental death benefits as
outlined in RSA
108a um shall not be subject to the full
age and service requirements listed
under the changes that we just made so
we would be limiting people's benefits
to the 2% unless they meet their full
age requirements or they're at least 60
years old
unless um they end up on ordinary
disability or die in the line of duty
and then they get the 2.5% multiplier
regardless whether they work 12 years or
14 years or 16 years or whatever they
they would still get the 2.5
multiplier understood what's that
understood yeah
yeah um thought thoughts thoughts from
the
subcommittee
no anybody want to speak to it from yes
Mr
real thank you good morning for the
record Brian real uh president of the
professional firefighters of New
Hampshire I'm going to be very brief um
we worked extremely hard in the
retirement commission uh on this very
issue uh this is an amendment that we
drafted up up together um as a
collaborative to try and narrow the
focus here uh so we can land the dart on
the bullseye when this thing heads to
the Senate and uh lower the cost uh
enough to get into that range that's
palatable for them so um I would ask the
subcomittee to support this thank you
much seeing no other comments um I will
move OTP or we recommend otpa uh to the
full committee um with Amendment
326h attached to it do I have a second
on
favor
okay
um so that brings us back to the only
1299 so I guess for me the main point of
contention at the moment is um the
college system is saying they feel like
they can fill the position uh the people
in charge of instructing say they're not
getting somebody to fill the position
um and to me that's kind of the the Crux
of The Proposal that I brought forward
and whether or not we should do it um
whether or not that position is going to
be filled by somebody who has a
significant amount of field
experience um with without this so um
Madam chair would you like
to to hear from
you yes I I would be very concerned
about this because there are only one or
two positions that qualify and we hate
to tweak the retirement system for one
or two people it we we don't want to
pass bills for one or two
people if it was a broad class of
individuals who would be covered by this
I might might support it but not for one
or two people in a specific program
that's that's just too narrow and too
personal and too M too much like doing
something for an individual which
is poor legislative practice if we had a
a better way to define it so that it
would covered a bunch of people like for
example we say say that if you're in a
um an elected position you can retain in
group two um or a commissioner level
position that's um but not for one or
two
instructors is so I'm I'm I'm would be
against anything to uh move this forward
yeah no I appreciate that and the
thought has crossed my mind too I think
my only concern with that is it's only
for two people but I I don't know that
the the reach of the bill
is is simply the retirement system um it
is educating people for the field um so
the educator will affect hundreds of
people those hundreds of people will
protect millions of people um so that
was my only my only kind of
counterbalancing to that because as a
general rule I agree that you know we
don't want to legislate for just one or
two people uh but because of because it
has such wide ranging effects in my
opinion I'm just not sure that it ends
up only affecting a couple of people it
does from the Retirement System point of
view I agree with that but um it's
concerned on the educational side of it
that's what the Bill's about the
retirement
system
thoughts to the degree that we bring it
forth from the subcommittee we give the
full committee an opportunity weigh in
on Carol's point which is a valid one we
and but the year counter that one gets
two gets and so forth the multiplier
effect is a
reality
so to the degree that we bring it
forward and let the full committee weigh
in on
it see how they
feel all right well since we need to get
this out of here today so that we can
get it to the full committee here's what
I'm going to do I'm going to make the
motion
otpa and if we agree to that I'll just
let the chair mop the floor with me in
the regular full committee meeting um
and I'll I'll I'll take that
humility I'll be right there with you on
M Patrol so will you second every all
right so
otpa and I don't even know how I'll vote
for it in the end but um I don't know
either but I I I think it's appropriate
to have the full committee weigh in um
those in favor
all right we'll go send a 30 and then
we'll it it it'll be a um a reserved
otpa um and we'll see how it goes from
there all right thank you everybody I'm
going to close the subcommittee hearing
and uh we got regular Committee in just
that
for
good morning I'm opening the public
hearing on House Bill 1548 and call
Representative
leus
for the record I'm representative Tony
leus Hillsboro 38 representing the towns
of Hudson and
Lichfield so this bill is related to the
the work of the joint committee on
employee
classification and I'll give for those
who don't aren't aware I'll give a a
brief overview of what it does so you
know there
are like in any any most businesses of
any size and or the military whatever
you've got salary ranges and so there's
one tied to your position okay if people
are familiar with that and the
legislature New Hampshire's um you know
has is in charge of what get spent and
has authority over what positions are
each one of these uh salary ranges but
issues come up where there need to be
either new positions or adjustments are
requested throughout you know the year
so you
don't um you know there legislature
can't deal with it in a timely manner so
there statute that gives this committee
the authority to do
temporary
assignments or and then um every couple
years they're supposed to supposed to be
a bill put in that is everything the
committee decided to do over the last
two years and then it comes to the uh
legislature to confirm it and if you
know there's people in the legislature
who think the committee didn't do the
right thing then you know it can be
amended um I think usually it ends up
just being approved but you know that's
that's extra oversight there and the
legislature has the authority so what
this bill
is is it incorporates all of the changes
is that the committee did over the last
couple of years and um and those
two-letter codes are the
salary codes and the bill doesn't
actually have um the monetary amounts
but if you are interested you can look
at look I didn't print copies for
everybody but I've got one here you can
look up um
RSA uh 94
1-A and it actually lists um what are
the salary ranges for each one of those
um those positions and if you look in
there you'll actually see two sets and
that's because when the we did the
budget last year there was uh one set
that occurred you know started in uh
beginning of
July and then there's a it's a two-year
budget so there's an a further
adjustment next July and the uh you know
if you remember there were raises given
in general to all of uh state employees
and and that was uh split over the two
years and that resulted in um you know
all of these salary ranges being raised
by whatever the percentage was and uh
and that's why you would
find um two in there and that's that's
what this is and the process is
typically you know the department wants
to uh assign some salary range to a new
employee or they want to change an
existing one there is an outside
consulting firm that that the state
contracts with and so the department
will write a uh job description pretty
detailed and who reports to them and
what you know everything about their
responsibility and the consultant looks
at you know other um how that relates to
other positions in the state and
elsewhere and they come up with a
recommendation for the um you know the
classification or the salary range and
which might be the Department's going to
ask for one the consultant's going to
come back with one which might be what
the department asked or or you know
we've certainly seen it where it's
different and then the committee will
hear from um somebody from the
department and then have a you know have
a discussion a vote and decide what to
do and more often than not especially if
the department and the consultant agree
we typically go along but there have
been cases where uh where we didn't and
especially where there's a differ you
know consultant says one that department
wants another we'll have a discussion
and you know the committee proposes
whatever it decides whatever it's going
to decide and um that's anyway that's
what's in the bill is um this thing
updated based on any changes over the
last two years so be glad to take
questions are there any questions
representative assment thank you madam
chair um yeah just uh representative
Lucas at the bottom um the salaries as
they listed do those include benefits or
are benefits above and beyond those
numbers uh my understanding is that's
the uh the salary the salary okay right
and then benefits that would be uh in
addition okay thank you and that that
last part there that actually has
numbers in it um those are special
exceptions that have been done so there
are some positions that special
positions that um are diff difficult to
recruit for there's few potential
candidates and there are you know
specific exemptions kind of outside of
what's normal for those and and that the
the committee deals with that as
groda thank you um representative leus I
think in the past Edna has seen a bill
similar to this because we have this
done every two years so I think that
this is something that we look at on a
regular basis and have approved in the
past and have have uh voted OTP in the
past correct
correct I remember um you know while I
was on the committee dealing with the
same issue from the other side of the
table
so okay thank you representative gold
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question I just wanted to
clarify I notice in the positions to be
removed this state um epidermiology
which is line nine on page one and then
line 26 on page two
interesting the he's the state
epidemiologist is being taken out of the
normal classification of salary ranges
and given a I believe significantly
higher salary because of scarcity right
and that's one of those exceptions I
mentioned but yeah they can't be in both
so
that would confuse the bureaucracy any
other questions representative Brown uh
thank you madam chair
U thank you Tony for taking my question
representative leus um so all of these
changes the number of these people have
already gotten their pay raise change is
that over the past two years would that
be accurate that's accurate because we
have the committee has the authority to
temporarily do it I suppose if we you
know the legislature didn't like one of
them and changed it then uh you know it
would go to whatever the legislature
wanted it to be yeah just understanding
thank you any other questions thank you
very much representative leus
representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair and
morning colleagues uh so as a a
long-term member of this J joint
committee on employee classification I
thought I would do a little tutorial
here very briefly and just that the way
the system works is that the jce is the
executive committee on this particular
uh area of state government um but the
the way it works is the issue is brought
to the attention of The JCC by the
usually the commissioner of Das okay we
have a staffer that's Bradley uh
previously it was Pam smling but Bradley
has taken over uh the the function uh
it's brought in we we hear from the
commissioner or assistant commissioner
uh in you know in in our little hearing
room down in
104 um and we we have that a executive
Authority but the the process is that
the statute then has to be changed to
reflect all these changes that we
authorize that's the function of Edna
committee it gets brought to us uh we
then make
our uh it's it's it's kind of a
technical committee on our part but it's
also a technical committee on Edna's
part but our our function is to put the
thing into the statute then it moves
along to the finance committee um and
they then put it into the budget and so
that the JCC is made up of two members
from the house from Edna that's
representative lein and myself in this
particular instance and then one member
from the finance committee that's
represent representative Tracy Emerich
some of you on the Republican side know
him well I know him well because he used
to sit next to me in the house and he
served with me on now on JCC as well and
then there are three members of the
Senate it will also um come from similar
committees so in any case then it goes
to the finance committee where
representative emmer is our our our our
angel of Mercy there and putting it into
the budget because it's a financial
aspect as well so that's what it's all
about um and if you have any questions
but so it's a we are ministerial in this
function we being J CC but also Edna and
finance all ministerial but we have our
individual functions so I'll answer any
questions you might have thank you
representative
Schmidt I don't see any thank you thank
you does anyone else wish to testify on
House Bill
1548 seeing none I'm going to close the
public
hearing and open an executive session
representative leus do you have a motion
yes I'd like to move ought to pass on
okay you wish to speak or you have have
you I I think everything I would say I
covered a moment ago
Prof
okay all right does anyone else wish to
speak questions
comments all right seeing none the
motion is ought to pass on House Bill
1548 and the clerk can call the
role
representative Simon yes representative
leakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative Dolan representative Gard
yes Clark votes yes representative Boyd
yes representative Brown yes
representative groa yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative Shu yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative gold yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair yes
17 y z nay okay the motion passes 17 to
zero any objection to
consent the it's
indeterminable
um I'll request to put it on consent and
if the clerk or the speaker thinks
there's too much money in in it they'll
calendar I certainly don't expect it to
floor all
right out of executive
session and I'm opening the hearing on
House Bill 1411 and call the prime
com thank you madam chair thank you
members of the committee um I come
before you today uh to offer this bill
that it's pretty simple I'm sure that
simple is never that simple according to
representative leus um but it's saying
that the state their contractors and
subcontractors must accept cash as a
form of payment at all transaction
points the reason I bring this forth is
because I
have constituents and I work with people
um that don't even have checking
accounts
and they rely on cash to pay most of
their
bills it's really a hardship for them to
go and get a money order which cost them
more money or a lot of times if they pay
with a debit card um they actually have
to pay a transaction fee um and it
really is a disservice to those on the
lower income scale and it actually is
harmful because it costs them more than
the regular citizen that could pay by
check or through their checking
account um and I'm open for any
questions thank you representative P
representative
Gart just curious an example of somebody
to doesn't accept
cash
um well right now I know in the private
sector there are businesses uh that
don't accept cash now any any longer um
my son just ran into that um but I know
that on the Spalding Turnpike you can no
tolls okay represent man py thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question is that can we regulate as
legislators whether it's government or
private entity to accept cash
irrespective of who I mean their policy
uh thank you for the question
representative this has nothing to do
with Private Industry this is only
regarding the state uh in their
contractors and subcontractors that are
directly related to work for the state
other
agencies I have a question represent
comt I can understand saying that the
DMV or the or the Dr must accept cash
but how do you deal with online
purchases because you can't really slip
a a a $20 bill into your
computer um I didn't really think about
the online portion I was just thinking
at a transaction point and I guess I was
thinking a physical transaction Point
Okay so
thank you for the question Madam
chair any representative Dolan and then
goalie thank you madam chair um thank
you representative for taking my
question U I know in the town that I
live in londondary the town will not
accept cash at the town dump the drop
off center anymore and that was
because um security of people hand
handling cash uh and so forth are there
any provisions in this bill that would
allow the an exception in cases like
that um thank you for the question and I
haven't put anything in there however um
I had learned
yesterday that with the cards that we
carry around the chips that anyone can
scan them from 18 in away so um you're
already in jeopardy
and kind of like cash is probably a
little bit safer at this moment in time
uh depending because no one can scan
that thank you representative
goalie thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question I want to go
back
to the example you brought up this
balding
turnpike would we have to
put individuals back into the toll boost
to take cash if this passed and redo
that whole section of roadway
over uh thank you representative goalie
for that question and uh I remember a
time when you didn't have to have
individuals necessarily but there was a
spot where you could deposit cash into
the
tolls okay represent Bailey and then
maner
py okay represent man py um thank you
madam chair again it is the toll is one
place but it's also adds to the whole uh
slew of uh who's collecting that and so
you have to put a Personnel will won't
that add cost to the state highway
department uh thank you for the question
representative um I am not sure about
the cost to the state but what I do know
is by not accepting cash we are harming
those that rely on it and they're the
people that I am here to
represent thank you representative shuid
and then groda thank you madam chair um
I'm particularly concerned about um
including contractors and subcontractors
who work for the state however uh that
may not be their sole business uh they
have private Enterprise aside from from
when they're doing jobs for the state um
this would probably require them to
change their whole um business operation
if they only accept credit or cards as a
normal business is that not true uh
thank you representative shuid this is
only for payments that is administered
if they're doing work for a commissioner
or collected by a department it has
nothing to do with any of their other
business I understand what you're saying
um but I can you know I see what's
happening in the Private
Industry and I see that we're going that
way in the government and
I work in manufacturing and I see people
struggling and when they have to incur a
fee or they have to go and get a money
order and pay additional amounts of
money where they're already struggling
cash is their best option for them to
pay um they don't have bank accounts
they don't have checking accounts I'm
that's the
reality repres
Vera thank you representative K I do
understand that the situation that
you're trying to solve however I'm
wondering if this description is Broad
too broad because because we have no
limit so if somebody has I I'm going to
use an example that somebody has a bill
for
$220,000 and they hand over $20,000 in
cash to somebody that's not very safe
either so it would you be amable to some
sort of cash limit if it's truly for
people who don't have checking accounts
who are of meager
means can we put some sort of limit on
here so that we don't open up
ourselves to problems in another area
representative thank you for the
question um yes I mean this bill is now
in the committee's hands and um so thank
you for the question okay okay
representative goalie just one more when
we're talking
about um including contractors and
whatnot hired through a department to do
their business and
one of the instances I'm thinking of is
fishing game
contracts with somebody for their
licensing and their services set up
fees I don't know how that contractor
would like the chair explained
questioned how they would get the cash
from an individual for an online
purchase and I'm just having that
contractor in there is setting up some
of the Departments that are already in a
contract not a short-term contract you
know some could be four or five year
contracts with
these how we would go about doing that
the way this bill is worded uh thank you
representative goalie and like I had
said before I wasn't really thinking of
online transactions so maybe there could
be an exclusion for anything that's
online but I'm talking physical
transaction points was what was my
intent thank you other questions
representative Brown uh thank you madam
chair I I don't know if you had an
opportunity to look at the fiscal
note and if you have you might be the
wrong person to ask because fcll wrote
this do you do you understand what that
last paragraph means lastly while there
might be an increase in Revenue due to
the mandated acceptance of cash it may
be partially offset by the absence of
fees or fines imposed on complete cash
payments
uh so thank you representative Brown for
that question and yes I did read that um
the thing is is you're already being
posed uh
fees uh if you pay your property taxes
or your car online through a uh credit
card so I don't understand um right now
I don't think there's any fees or fines
for paying cash but I put that in just
in case because we are seeing that um
you know like I said these people have a
hard time just with the
uh so followup followup so my apologies
for maybe being dense everyone but so
what we're saying is they may be
increase in state revenues because the
state will not be paying fees for
electronic transactions correct thank
you thanks all right representative
Schmidt thank you Madam
chair so it was already referenced uh
but the the reality is in those areas
where we have turnpikes and where we
have U you know now the easy paths I I I
live right on I live in Dober and I pass
to the Spalding turnpikes on a constant
basis um there there are no toos anymore
all three cities uh that that have they
part of of the sping Turnpike it's just
the automatic you go through uh and so
people who live in those areas are going
to be going through those things or not
every day uh and so having to pay you
know in cash that that that's just not
going to work so we're going to have to
look at
that other questions may I respond yes
please thank you madam chair and and
thank you representative for bringing up
that point however
I'm not sure if you understand that easy
pass um actually hurts the same people
I'm trying to help here because you're
required to keep at least $20 on an Easy
Pass Easy Pass doesn't pay interest on
your
money you get no benefits and then when
these people do go through the toll if
they can't afford to have an Easy Pass
they charge an additional fee of $150 to
have that pay paper uh mail to them so
people I don't disagree with the
represent I just said recognize also
that that it's not going to be would be
unsafe for people who are everybody else
is going through those those tolls
taking devices at 55 or miles an hour
and having somebody veering off to pay
their their toll in cash that's just not
gonna that's not safe it's not going to
work so I'm just saying we're going to
have to see how we handle that thank
you representative Brown uh thank you
madam chair so to follow up on that do
you know what when when you get the
letter that says you've gone through the
Easy Pass you owe x amount of dollars is
there a place where you can walk to or
cash
uh thank you for the question there are
Easy Pass places uh I believe one is on
off the hooks at uh exit um where they
have there but I can tell you that I
have had more complaints about people
where their Easy Pass H or transpond has
not been working or that they're getting
bills that aren't even related to a
own you're welcome okay other
representative gold thank thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question um as a homesteader who's lived
very meally I've frequently encountered
the exact circumstance you're talking
about here so I just wanted to make sure
that you would be ad meable to um a
committee working on some amendment that
would put some safeguards in place but
uh I think this is a really important
bill that there are more and more people
that are low income that are living
modestly that do not have the funds to
um to pay the fines to begin with or
whatever the fee is or anything I I had
an Easy Pass when you get below that
$20 limit I changed cards and I didn't
give them my new number they just take
your money and shut your easy pass off
so it is a system designed to harm the
least able to pay in our um in our
current situation so uh thank you and
would you be willing to to accept some
of these amendments thank you
representative for the question and yes
like I said this is bill is now in the
committee's hands so okay other uh
questions thank you very much thank you
madam chair members is there anyone else
1411 seeing none I will close the public
hearing
okay so this will be going to
subcommittee representative bras to look
at some of these issues that have been
brought up and we have until 10:45 for
hearing
no phot
somebody you can I had to do that
recharge no you can't
to2
right
do you have
a I'm just getting rid of a bunch of
drunk
the not
Mak
are there
who are they advising they're advising
the executive director and sta so so
they're
Tech
yeah something like Board of
[Music]
depending director work the Govern so
that's
some of the people are pleased about it
other
tell
you did you get
name
they
anyway
she
expain
you
dep
up
n
picture
[Music]
to
that
yeah hell how are you fantastic I'm
much
pleasure
that
wow this is interesting because have you
supporting
want
no
that's
ridiculous
it being 10:45 I would like to open the
public hearing on hb1
1271 and call the uh esteemed and
Bill thank you thank you Mr
chair good morning committee I'm Carol
Maguire representing marac District 27
which is the towns of Allenstown
Dunbarton Epsom and hookit and House
Bill
1271 essentially converts a number of
the professional licensing boards into
advisory
boards these are all boards that have a
small number of licensees
so
that those are the boards that have
trouble finding people to serve on the
boards they have trouble attaining a
quorum even if they do have a quorum
they meet infrequently so they can't
respond in any timely manner to any
issues and if there are issues with uh
complaint or that needs to be
investigated it's a small state we all
know each other
you would end up with a significant
portion of the board having to recuse
themselves in any significant
investigation
so for these reasons these boards are
more appropriate for the advisory
model instead of being responsible for
actually generating the rules they would
review them for technical accuracy and
compliance with the statute and with the
professional guidelines that they
know they would serve as advisors to the
executive director and the oplc to make
sure that
the um the the profession is properly
managed
and it it's simpler and easier for these
small boards with a small number of
professionals to work as an Advisory
Board rather than a full regul atory
board and that's why I agreed to to
submit this
legislation and I will mention that
section n on the board of registration
of medical technicians is already
covered in House Bill 1410 so it should
probably be eliminated from this
bill I will answer whatever questions I
have but I believe the executive
director is here for more details thank
you very much for your testimony any
questions yes representative leas
representative black as I excuse me
you're co-p sorry sorry good
point representative man did you have a
question I'm
debating thank you uh Mr chair thank you
for taking my question is this in line
with what uh the committee did last year
kind of moving the process of Licensing
toc's responsibility and the board as a
uh if
it relies on the oplc having the
responsibility for licensing but it is
totally independent of that I mean once
that has been accomplished whether it's
an Advisory board or a full board is a
different
decision any other questions seeing none
thank you very
much uh Jody Bell from the New Hampshire
Association
good morning Mr chair and house
executive department administration
committee me Members thank you thank you
for this opportunity to provide some
information with as this committee goes
forward making decisions regarding HB
1271 may remember I was here last week
rep regarding HB 1676 FN my name is jod
Bell I'm a licensed acupuncturist here
in New Hampshire I serve on the board of
acupuncture licensing since 2020 but I'm
here today as a representative for our
state professional association the New
Hampshire acupuncture and Asian medicine
Association we called nahama I wish to
present our the letter to the committee
demonstrating our association stand you
should all have a copy of that letter
near or around you so in the interest of
time I won't read every single word of
that letter but I'd like to call your
that so primarily hb1 1271 does not
maintain that The Advisory Board as an
active regulatory body with complete
jurisdiction over its profession so the
New Hampshire acupuncture asan medicine
Association must oppose HB
1271 in addition acupuncture is the only
diagnostic healthc care profession
proposed for change in
hp71 once again the members of the
general court wish to group us with
occupations that don't require a level
of Education or training or a level of
liability to practice do not look at our
number of licenses when determining this
action look at the possible harm to the
public health when mistakes are made in
implementing a new system acupuncture
requires a 3,000 hour master's degree
which is also people can do an advanced
practice to a doctorate level which
includes no less than 900 hours of
clinical training three National
standardized board exams one of which is
biomedicine and a separate National
standardized clean needle technique
certification assuring Public Safety
members of the general court continue to
draft bills to set acupuncture up apart
from the other diagnostic Health
Professions in the state even the
attempt in doing so in this bill shows a
lack of understanding of our profession
education and license what seems to be a
subtle change of merely exchanging the
word executive and director for the word
board in the RSA 328g is not subtle it
strips away a vital supervisory role and
Authority the change allows for a
consultation but does not require a
consensus or agreement between the
executive director and the advisory the
executive director a single person not
the body of professions has the ultimate
rule hb1
1271 moves professional boards to
advisory and the executive director has
the sole supervision taking over a
growing number of professions and Prof
and professionals the possibility of
costly mistake Rises how can this be in
the interest of the
public we also wish to point out that if
this passes the sole responsibility of
the profession of acupuncture would be
ruled by a body excuse me has repeatedly
shown that it does not understand the
profession the bill would give the
executive director the ability to
consult The Advisory before a rule is
added or change still it only requires
it as an option not a mandate of
Consulting The Advisory when holding the
license e to the rules of the RSA 328
acupuncture is a diagnostic healthc care
profession practiced independently
similar to Medical Doctors chiropractors
doctors of naturopathic medicine and
should be treated as such therefore
since hb1 1271 does not maintain that
The Advisory Board as an active
regulatory body with complete
jurisdiction over its profession and hb1
1271 does not keep acupuncture and
integral Health Care profession alongsid
other independent diagnostic practices
and hb1 1271 does not put Public Safety
First nama respectfully request this
body to amend H
b1271 by excluding acupuncture
entirely also um with regard
to uh representative Maguire's comments
uh trouble finding people to serve uh
for our board that has not been an issue
also finding a quorum the only time
that's been an issue is when we've had
emergency meetings right before a
holiday
and then the part about having to recuse
ourselves because we know who's coming
under Fire that's not been an issue for
us either so um that's one reason those
are several reasons why we feel
acupuncture should not be part of
1271 and I
also we have consulted our national
board and uh we have letters of
testimony from them which I only made 10
copies so I need to submit that to you
to you all for your consideration so
they really reiterate what we have put
in our letter but just having it come
from the national board that has
oversight on 46 other states would be
significant I believe for your
decision-making process I'm open to any
questions great thank you for your
testimony are there any questions
representative man depy thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um how would this imp impact your
professional practice in the
state or would it
not having the acupuncture licensing
board go to an advisory status we feel
that it will we'll lose the
maintaining vigilance over our
profession and then the fact that an
Advisory Board is an option then when
they do want to consult us it's it's
going to be like being on call and how
many people can stop their practices I
mean anyone who's been here myself
included we rearrange everything to
accommodate what the legislature and the
board wants to do to us so we're sort
of it would be an unfortunate strategy
for us because it would catch us off
guard and create
undo disruptions to Patient
Care
any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony all right so these um extra
copies I have I can yeah you can pass
them around we at least one for the file
Kerwin
I'm pretty sure you just said man Vicki
Irwin yes okay very good hi thank you
for your time thank you for uh allowing
me to speak today my name is Vicki Irwin
I'm a licensed acupuncturist with a
private practice in Nashville New
Hampshire um while I am here as only an
individual I have previously served for
six years on the State Association for
acupunctur and I am currently on the
licensing board uh but I am here to
testify against this bill um of course
I'm a little bit biased towards the
acupuncture specific pieces of the bill
but I did read it in its entirety um and
I do have a few concerns the executive
director is simply a single person with
only a few exceptions um this bill did
not say executive director or their AE
or oplc as an
organization if the intent is to speed
up licensing Pro and the process of
applications I do wonder what happens
when Lindsay is out what if she's on a
medical leave moves on to another job or
retires
it would seem a nearly insurmountable
task to find another single person who's
willing to take on the responsibility
the entire responsibility of nine
separate wildly unrelated boards as well
as manage an organization that handles
many many more I'm also concerned that
there's no clear indication of when the
advisory boards must be consulted there
appears to be this appears to be left to
the discretion of a single person who
likely knows very little about many of
these professions the lack of oversight
and checks and balances is concerning to
me as someone who has served on a New
Hampshire licensing boorn I made it my
business to learn the ropes I read the
statutes I read the rules I've tried to
learn the order of operations when a
change needs to happen even with
quarterly plus meetings I find it a
difficult concept and I can only imagine
the confusion that an Advisory Board
that's only called now and then would
face we do understand that uh the
licensing process needs to speed up and
we have as an acupuncture licensing
board have understood that in the past
we have attempted to form a subcommittee
to review licenses that were received
between our meetings and to be ratified
at the next meeting but every time there
was a staff turn over the subcommittee
idea was lost and had to be
reintroduced we've also put together a
clear and easy to understand Matrix that
oplc could use to approve very
straightforward license applications but
again with staff turnover that document
was lost the same seems to be true for
work we did in helping to determine
states that qualify for
reciprocity despite this and despite the
absence of actual rules defining
reciprocity in place yet applications
are being approved without our
review
um while I do think that some things
need to change and be streamlined and
sped up in their process I do think that
this particular bill is shortsighted and
should not pass as written and with that
I thank you for your time and I'd be
happy to answer any questions thank you
for your testimony any questions from
the committee
yes representative
Smith your microphone
please I didn't catch her name when you
gave it in the beginning can you repeat
it again Vicki irin Vicky irin okay
thank you yes ma'am um Mr chair if I
might ask Miss Irvin to send us her
testimony that you were reading from
that would be helpful you can send it to
our committee uh
Gordon welcome back it's good to see you
nice to see you
all thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Ned Gordon and I'm
a resident of Bristol and I here
represent my myself today but I also
represent the guardian that lightam
board Guardian the lium
board uh was established about 25 years
ago uh prior to its establishment it uh
we had Guardian at Liams who uh who
perform a very important function in the
State uh they are appointed by the court
basically to represent the interests of
children they have a huge influence on
families and the decisions that the
court makes with regard to uh parenting
time uh and other issues for example if
you have a dad who says J mom has a
boyfriend and they're involved in
domestic violence and I don't think
Johnny should live there and you have um
uh uh mom who says Dad is selling drugs
out of the house I don't think Johnny
should live there a judge can't go out
and uh go out and investigate the
household to figure out what's going
going on somebody has to be appointed to
do that and in this particular case a
guardian at Liam is appointed by the
court to do that go out do an
investigation and make a recommendation
as to what is in the child's best
interest and that's important function
it's a hugely important function for the
courts prior to 25 years ago the court
was appointing guardian of items who
were
completely untrained could be
unqualified there were no standards for
Guardians at lium and there was no
discipline for Guardian at lims who
engaged in
misconduct the guardian at Lim board was
established standards were put in place
training has been provided there are
minimum qualifications to become a
guardian at lium and continuing
qualifications education for Guardian at
lims over time that's all been done by
the guardian at Li
board so now we have a bill before us
that says we was want to make the
guardian the lium board and Advisory
Board it has seven members currently
they're all in one way or another
involved in the guardian the lium
process there uh with the exception of
two Representatives one a senator and
one a House member who participate on
the
board I read the bill I saw in the bill
basically the purpose was to reduce
supervision I wonder uh if anybody did
any study to find out if there was a
need to reduce Workforce barriers I
don't believe the committee has ever
received a report from anyone saying
that there are Workforce unreasonable
Workforce barriers other than the
minimum requirements that are required
to become a guardian that
lium and to provide State supervision I
think the guardian of the lien board has
done a good job of that and uh just at
our last meeting we had a meeting last
Friday at the guardian lighting board we
meet it each month uh we were given a
sheet of uh fairly
recently uh in the your legislation
which was passed in the last session it
was agreed that the guardian the
lightting board would now uh review the
do the initial review of complaints and
do an
investigation and we thought that was a
great idea because they have the
resources to do that on last Friday we
got a thing showing that currently there
are 20 complaints that say they just
been intake just since
intake which means they haven't been
acted on going back to last February
almost a year
ago and this is this is who we want we
want oplc now to take over
managing the guarding the lighten
board and when we ask well why why is
that happening and and the person that
comes to our meeting says well that's
the enforcement side I can't I don't
have an answer for you so I just don't
think that the guardian the lightting
board is going to be prepared to provide
the training I don't think they're going
to be able to understand the standards
and if you look at what they said is
we're going to change those seven
members who are generally involved in
Guardian that liem industry and know
what standards should be applied what
training might be necessary and how
people should act we're going to replace
them with just three members now one
member being appointed by
oplc one member being appointed by the
Supreme Court and remember the guardian
liting board was taken away from the
courts so that it would be separate from
the courts and one representative from
Casa and Casa provides is basically is a
guardian n liem which we hire to be a
guardian that liem and then they hire
individuals to serve in abuse neglect
cases but not all the abuse neglect
cases because they don't have the
resources to provide them for the whole
state so there are lots of our Guardian
at Lems that are doing abuse neglect
cases long and a short is I just think
uh making the guardian the light and
board uh an Advisory Board is ill
advised I I looked at the sponsors I've
never seen him one of the sponsors of
this bill come to a a guardian em board
meeting to know what we do why we do it
h and why it should be done
differently so that's my testimony today
I hope that you'll delete the guardian
at light and provision from this bill it
uh it makes from my perspective it makes
no
sense thank you for your testimony uh
yes representative Goa thank you this
one of the the prime sponsor of the bill
said that this um
addresses a where there are a small
number of licenses so can you tell us
how many people um are Guardian at Liams
are Guardian at Lums and how many of
them are licensed I mean I would imagine
it's not a small number no we have we
have a number of people who I I can't I
don't have a number at hand so I can't
tell you but I'd certainly be willing to
find that out for you but I'm not sure
that that's really the I don't think the
number of Guardian items is really what
the key issue is it's the responsibility
of guarding that items which is really
what the issue is and when I look at the
complaints that H you know have been
there for sitting there for a year and
haven't been acted on by
oplc some of them being multiple guard
some of them being multiple complaints
against one Guardian at light them say
this this isn't right
um follow up followup I don't ask the
question for justification I just ask
the question because that's how it was
presented to us and I don't agree that
the number for example of cardian items
is small so that's I would just like you
to confirm that for me thank you we'll
get a number for you thank you
representative Manti thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question um my
question is on reverse side
it's not how many Guardian Liam or CA
members are but how many cases do you
represent so that
dictates what the load is correct right
there there are and again I I wouldn't
have a number for you a number of cases
but uh F first of all they're extremely
important cases uh and I'm I'm sure in
the year it's hundreds if not if not in
the thousands of cases
Statewide representative gold thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I'm thinking that part of the
discrepancy in terms of the numbers um
that were reported and what the actual
boots on the ground experiences has to
do with cassa being licensed but they
provide a vast array of guardian items
into the system do you think that's a
piece of that right yeah and follow up
follow
up so as a professional in the field for
many years thank you for what you've
done on the board and big thanks to the
guardian of Lems who protect the
children but back when cassa first got
involved in Vol volunteers took over the
role that was traditionally done by
attorneys I have some pretty serious
concerns I've always had pretty serious
concerns about
volunteers and about the training and
the understanding they have of the
system versus an attorney who's really
representing that child's best
interest and I use my experience in
child welfare and going into the courts
when you go into a child abuse and
neglect case there are so many interests
flying around you the best advice I ever
got and what I practiced was keep your
eye on the child
and that's the guardian at Liam's role
and it's been a lesson I've learned
that's car worked well for me in these
hearings so the child at this point is
what will best serve children in the
Long Haul and I guess I'd like to ask
you as an Advisory Board as opposed to a
licensing
board what exactly would you see the
change in your role would you not still
be there and advising director Courtney
and the
staff I don't frankly I don't know what
an Advisory
Board would do the I guess the Advisory
Board is only going to
[Music]
be answering questions if oplc has some
concerns is if it says well we we're
going to do some Ru making we want to
have some input or something like that
but
I frankly if all you're going to do is
have an Advisory Board you might as well
not have any board at all from my
perspective and with regard to your
comment about attorneys doing being
Guardian at Liams or non attorneys the
one thing that is most important with a
guardian that lium is that they need to
have some common sense and Common Sense
isn't something you can teach it's not
about being a lawyer or not being a
lawyer it's
about um knowing how families work and
children representative goalie thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question
yeah because I too was a little
concerned about the way the language was
written in the bill when you brought up
the sentence it says uh this is to
reduce Workforce barriers and provide
State supervision responsibility and
chapter I'm I'm just perplexed as to
how going from a board to an Advisory
Board reduces that role because I my
understanding was oplc already has was
given the authority to Grant licenses
upon approval as well as a met
qualifications
and I don't know if you can tell me how
changing you to an Advisory Board is
going to make that
even more proficient than what's already
going on for the statement to be in the
bill uh well given the history of oplc
so far I have no confidence at all that
it would make an improvement
up and the other concern I had and
you've been around long
enough when you're putting together an
Advisory
Board and you have the person in charge
now making the two picks of they want
versus the
governor wouldn't that be some sort of a
conflict going
forward I I I fully agree if you have an
Advisory board for oplc and you have
oplc appointing The Advisory Board it
me any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank you
everybody appreciate
it Elizabeth
pep
sorry thank you chairman Simon and
thanks to all of you for allowing me to
speak to you today about why I support
this bill I am a licensed acupuncturist
Manchester could you just state your
name for the record please since I got
it wrong um Elizabeth r r P so um I'm
here to speak about why the license
acupuncture Licensing Board needs to be
transitioned into an Advisory Board I
have three main points that I need to
make one is that the acupuncture board
is bad at basic
Administration the second is the board
upholds an exclusive law and finally the
board is inconsistent in enforcing their
burdensome
rules so um they have five members they
have a hard time meeting Quorum maybe
that's just for emergency meetings but
the board was asked to expand and they
would not cting personal differences and
I got that information from the meeting
minutes um when the pandemic started the
board met remotely and I had
questions and those questions I didn't
get answers and I and they weren't
posting their meeting minutes and I
asked where were their meeting minutes
and again I didn't get an answer or
meeting
minutes and um at some point the board
formed a subcommittee on ear acupuncture
I specialize in ear acupuncture and I am
a supervisor for acupuncture
detoxification Specialists who practice
ear acupuncture I would have liked to
have had the opportunity to weigh in on
those secret
meetings my second point is that the
board upholds an exclusive law so um
your committee has received over a dozen
letters in support of this bill and many
of them are from licensed acupuncturists
who want reciprocity from practitioners
from out other
states and the board currently does not
allow reciprocity last year the board
reviewed laws from other states and
determined that no state meets or
exceeds New Hampshire standards and one
of the biggest factors is a Balor
requirement so that's having a
bachelor's degree in addition to a
master's level degree from an accredited
Acupuncture school and that Master Level
degree takes three three and a half to
four years to
complete um that requirement is unfair
and it is unreasonable Most states do
not have this requirement we are I
thought I were I thought we were the
only one but I believe New Jersey has
that requirement as well um and the
board has the power to change this
that's just not something they seem to
be interested in um and to demonstrate
how ridiculous and irrelevant that
requirement is I I have a bachelor's
degree and my bachelor's degree
is in Liberal Arts so nothing in my
bachelor's degree has to do with
Healthcare or Health Sciences um luckily
I had it when I wanted to relocate to
New Hampshire but not everyone has that
degree um and finally my last point is
about how the board is inconsistent in
on um my colleague Laura kie is not here
here today to tell her story um she's
she completed her last round of
chemotherapy last week please keep her
in your
thoughts and so I'm going to tell her
story about how she was styed by
legislative rules that the licensing
board wrote Laura is a trainer with the
national acupuncture detoxification
Association NADA and she wrote the NADA
manual which is the standard that New
Hampshire has set for training
acupuncture detoxification Specialists
New Hampshire does allow for other ACU
detox trainings to be approved by the
board and so Laura submitted her manual
the same manual that she trains with
under NADA and the board would not
approve
it however the board did approve a
manual from another trainer by the name
of Dave worel and I reached out to him
to know how he managed to fit all the
requirements of his training into a
single weekend and he I have his email
response with me today um he said that
he doesn't spend much time on need in
technique or clean needle
technique and that is what the training
is supposed to be about how to safely
needle the ear needling technique and
clean needle technique are listed in the
rules as the third and fourth items in
board approved curriculum
training and for some reason the board
decided to wave the four-month waiting
period for him so acupuncture licensing
board members promoted his training and
hosted his training and that 4mon
waiting period is in the rules that the
board wrote and that's a shall not a may
have a four-month waiting period before
the first training so these are glaring
inconsistencies on how the board treated
Laura kie versus day worel and I don't
know if this is bias I don't know if
this is favoritism I don't know if this
is
retribution but yeah anyway these are my
points does anyone have any questions
thank you for your testimony any
questions yes representative goota so I
looked on the acupuncture Board website
and they're very transparent as to when
they meet and they have meeting minutes
for their meetings so I really you know
I'm concerned about your you may have an
issue when it comes
to um your questions about the treatment
of
individuals but I don't see based on
this information I haven't read these
many minutes but I don't see um how if
your your first point is legitimate or
can you can you speak more about that
because they are meeting and they are um
they have minutes so they have to have a
quorum so I'm just wondering how that
fits into your narrative yeah I'm
speaking of between 2020 when the
pandemic started in March of 2020 pretty
much through I want to say
2020 last year
even they met in 2022 so yeah meeting in
2022 so remotely and I would go and look
I was looking for meeting minutes mostly
because I wanted answers to my questions
and they weren't getting posted and
after a certain point the meeting
minutes are get removed from the website
so they only go back what like another
year so that's not an issue ISS with the
board it's an issue with the website
isn't it I'm looking for minutes and
that's where I go to find them and if
they weren't there they weren't there I
don't
know anything yes representative man
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um pandemic was an anomaly right we
don't have Pandemic every this is the
first one in my lifetime so to base
just on your
experience during pandemic and the
changes to the rules or the
responsibility for oplc and the board
changed last year so has it been long
enough to kind of
say this is not working let's change the
whole thing and I'm just having a hard
time coming to terms with that from you
your angle
perspective I don't think I understand
your
question are you saying has it been long
enough since the pandemic to see whether
or not the problems been
remediated yeah the problems during
pandemic was one time kind of thing so
to take what happened during pandemic in
extrapolate that's the practice I think
that's
expanding beyond that emergency okay so
okay so let me see if how I can answer
this so I think it was last year in the
meeting minutes the board was asked to
expand members so they could meet Quorum
and I read they didn't want to and they
cited personality differences that
doesn't sound like a really good reason
to not expand the board um let's see
what else um there was I read about the
subcommittee m on ear acupuncture and
then wondered okay so when are these
meetings happening and if they're having
subcommittee meetings that does have to
get public notice and if it doesn't get
public notice that is a violation of the
right to no
law and if they're not responding to
email email inquiries within 5 days
again also a violation of the right to
no law and so so these are some recent
things yes they happened also in the
continued uh yes represent
so were these concerns brought up to the
oplc yes they were and how did they
address them I let's see I emailed oplc
I want to say in
2021 and my my main question of reaching
out during the pandemic was to know how
I was supposed to address supervision
for acupuncture detoxification
Specialists because acupuncturists were
told we couldn't practice for some time
during the pandemic we weren't
considered um essential workers but that
didn't include the acupuncture
detoxification Specialists and there
wasn't any mention so I needed to know
how to proceed and I had I did talk to
somebody at oplc who didn't know what I
was talking
about and so and then I had to clarify
like I'm a supervisor I supervise these
these people some of them are essential
workers using ear
acupuncture
um I don't remember this was 2021 and
then I asked about meeting minutes and
she said I don't know where the meeting
minutes are did you ask the board and I
showed her a screenshot of my email to
the board asking for their meeting
minutes follow up so I just want you to
understand that you're asking you're
supporting The Advisory Board yet oplc
was not able to answer your questions
regarding your
specialty so you do understand that
you're
supporting an organization that had not
been able to assist you in the past can
you confirm that I think that members of
oplc could do their job if we had a
chance to educate them about what adss
are and what they
do representative
Brown uh thank you Mr chair uh excuse me
thank you for taking my question so
going back to previous testimony and
question from representative
goalie uh aside from some of these
administrations administrative
conversations
M do you feel that this this law would
help to eliminate Workforce barriers for
people coming here to New Hampshire to
enter this field and that it's a
two-piece question because it's a
two-piece sentence and that it provides
State supervision over these regulatory
bodies which I guess follows up on
representative grod's comment but
basically do you think it's going to
help eliminate Workforce barriers I
think so I'm open to further discussion
but I think it would it would I mean at
the moment we have a board that doesn't
want to that looked at all the
acupuncture laws of all the other states
and said oh all these states require
don't require a bachelor's degree but we
do let's keep it the same for no
particular reason whereas if we had The
Advisory Board model we could say all
right let's match some of the other
states and let's not just arbitrarily
out
okay representative gr thank you for
some reason I just had this moment of
remembrance okay so my first term as a
legislature the Edna committee did look
at standards for the uh acupuncture
board and I specifically remember that
this test was something that everybody
in wanted and there was no opposition in
fact I know that Miss was part of
my subcommittee okay so I want to
understand why all of a sudden the
change in attitude about the test the
national test the oh no this isn't about
the national test okay so what is it I'm
sorry I Mis I misunderstand you're yeah
you're talking about certification and
all that was all straightened out five
years ago or four years ago so why all
of a sudden are we all talking about
this again so the national test is
something that acupuncturists take when
they graduate from AC puncture school
and generally everyone needs that when
applying for a license I don't think
that it's so you need a if so pretty
much every state says pretty much every
state law will say acupunctur should at
least have two years of
postsecondary education prior to
Acupuncture school um so so there are
plenty of acupuncturists who might like
well no we had some acupuncturists who
testified for this bill they are
licensed acupuncturists they either are
from another state and just want
reciprocity they have passed the exams
they are have a license and good
standing in another state some of them
only have maybe the two years of college
required to be trained in acupuncture
and serve in the state that they
currently live in I don't know what the
test has to do with
it um followup thank you so um I get you
had mentioned something about a
bachelor's degree you had mentioned
something about the test you had
mentioned something I didn't mention the
test okay so
um with oplc taking over licensing now
that burden of reciprocity should be
so thank you thank you so much for your
testimony
please my concern is
you your concern is with the direction
the board is going currently and not
being open to some of these discussions
is how do you know this Advisory Board
isn't going to be made up of some of the
individuals that are currently on the
board as it sits and you're still where
you're at so this doesn't solve your
problem completely does it I would hope
thank you for that question I would hope
that we would have term limits and the
board actually abides by those term
limits and that's not the case at the
moment thank you so much for your
time um Elizabeth
Griffin
griffy
good
morning I'm I'm gonna read an email that
I sent to many of you I recognize some
names and uh it's just my
experience this is to whom it may
concern my name is Beth griffy excuse me
a second could you speak a little closer
to the microphone sorry thank you I'm
verdict
challenged to whom it may concern my
name is Beth griffy ey and I've been a
licensed acupuncturist since June of
2022 I'm requesting that you support hb1
1271 to restructure the board of
acupuncture licensing and hb7 1272
regarding licensing
reciprocity I don't know boards I don't
know advisers I do know
people prior to acupuncture I was a
general surgeon for 12 years in Boston
and Quincy Massachusetts I retired from
medicine to preserve my mental and
physical health in 2018 I was a widow
looking for a new career I enrolled in
Acupuncture school I graduated from the
program at the Massachusetts College of
Pharmacy and Health
Sciences which I will shorten to mcphs
in September of
2021 getting my acupuncture license in
New Hampshire was not a simple and
streamlined process mcphs provided
transcripts to
oplc which included transcripts from
Georgetown medical school mcphs had
taken many of my credits from Georgetown
for duplicate courses however the
licensing board would not Grant my
license without proof that I had
obtained a bachelor's degree prior to
attending medical school it took weeks
to get a copy of my college transcripts
I was an undergraduate student my email
says 30 years ago I'm ashamed to say it
was 42 years ago I graduated with a ba
in
Spanish I do I don't understand why the
board doesn't know that every medical
school in the United States requires a
four-year Balor
degree many of my Acupuncture school
classmates are like me We go to
Acupuncture school after several years
of other professional life experiences a
master's program in acupuncture and
integrative medicine is rigorous we need
to pass three national board boards not
one three national boards to be licensed
and those boards are RIS why is that not
enough to get an acupuncture license in
the state of New Hampshire requiring a
master of acupuncture should be enough
to allow lure in the state and I thank
uh the woman who spoke previously and
and told you how many hours we dedicate
to our
profession um when my husband and I
moved to New Hampshire in 2008 there was
already a shortage of primary care
providers in the state my husband with
cancer was assigned a PCP nurse
practitioner after an emergency room
visit I had to wait for my husband's
passing in order to take his place and
become a patient of hers in that
Internal Medicine practice this was in
2014 right now our medical system is
taxed by sheer numbers of patients
experiencing short and long-term effects
of covid illness I wonder if any of you
have been to your local emergency
department recently
last August I waited 45 minutes in the
ER with a terminally ill friend lucky
for us she looked sick and had medical
records to prove how sick she was and so
we only waited 45 minutes before we were
moved to a triage room for treatment the
remainder of the patients in the
overflowing waiting room had been
waiting for at least 6 hours this was a
Monday afternoon this is why I'm writing
this email today we need more healthcare
workers providing acute and chronic
treatment to to P to people like those
waiting in the emergency department that
day in August and acupuncturists do this
every day we need more practitioners to
take the pressure off of our Western
Medical counterparts does the
acupuncture licensing board think we
have enough
acupuncturist I think it's incumbent
Upon Our licensing
boards sorry to make it easier to bring
healthcare workers to our state please
make the licensing process for
acupuncture easier and allow reciprocity
of acupuncture licenses across all other
states people need access to health care
in whatever form we have to offer
whether it be Western Medical providers
or Allied Health Providers I thank you
for your attention
today thank you for your testimony uh
will you take questions
yes represent you do um representative
goalie thank you Mr
chair GNA ask you the same question I
asked the previous speaker
how making this board advisory which
could still be the same
individuals address your concerns it
could it could not I don't know as I
said at the at the beginning I I don't
know boards I don't know
um I I I don't know enough to say that I
know the answer to that question but I
can tell you since I've been a licensed
acupunctur for a year and a half I
suddenly realized there's a lot more to
just me doing my job it's me speaking up
about my experience and maybe trying to
join the board maybe that's something I
should do whether it's a board or an
advisory committee and I know people I
people and one last followup sure
representative
going understanding the importance of
the
profession wouldn't you as a
practitioner
want the board to have a little more say
than just making a recommendation to an
individual has who has no experience in
your field and that person decides
whether or not they want to listen to
your recommendation because you're only
advisory and you're not a true board
wouldn't it be more better to keep a
board on its own than having a say
that doesn't say in statute it has to be
listened
to I think it'd be wonderful if all of
the if the if the acupuncturist in in
New Hampshire had a good representation
on some committee board or advisory on
on an advisory um
sense all I can say is we trust in
people we trust the people that come
here to practice we trust the people
that run our our country our
state I'm trusting in the board at the
same time that I'm questioning how well
are we doing and how how much Common
Sense are we using and is there any way
we can help provide relief to the
Western Medical system which is almost
broken maybe you can remember covid this
this was a terrible time why can't we
just try and get treatment the more
acupunctur we have the more treatment we
provide and yes we we we expect that
people who are coming here are going to
be moral they're going to abide by the
rules they're going going to be trained
we know they're well trained we know
they have clean needle technique
certification they pass three boards We
Trust in their
performance so we have to trust that
whoever is advising us already knows the
with represent good any other questions
from the committee yes representative
gold thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I want to make
sure I'm understanding what I'm hearing
you say is that the status quo is broken
it isn't working well or it's flawed and
that it's your hope a change will
improve things is that yes am I hearing
that correct thank
you I mean I hope I hope for everything
to change for the better couldn't get
much
worse we hope for the same thing thank
you thank you so much for your testimony
Smith
hi uh my name is Lauren Smith I'm a
licensed acupuncturist I live here in
Conquer New Hampshire uh and I'm just
going to say I am in support of this
bill great thank you very much for your
Gabby is Elizabeth Gabby still here New
Council
that's all right is it Elizabeth
welcome can everybody hear
me okay so my name is Elizabeth Gabby
I'm a New Hampshire certified midwife
and I'm here on behalf of the New
Hampshire Midwifery Council we are one
of the n boards listed in Bill
1271 and I would like we strongly oppose
this bill and we would like the New
Hampshire midwy Council just taken out
of this bill completely we are a council
we have six
members an
obstetrician a pediatrician three
midwives and a public member in this
bill an Advisory Board brings us to two
midwives and one physician so we would
have to pick do we take an obstetrician
do we take a pediatrician there is no
overlap in their
expertise so as the board we pride
ourselves on um being there for the
public health and safety of people doing
home birth Community birth birth center
in New
Hampshire and um this Council has a lot
of expertise coming into it this this
bill scratches that not to mention I
read the 47 pages of this bill and our
you my part was on page 26 to page 29
but I kept on seeing the executive
director the power goes to the executive
director the executive director will
consult with advisory
boards but um ultimately the executive
director has the say
um I will add that we have been working
with
oplc in the last few
years 1999 was the first time the
Midwifery law went into effect in um New
Hampshire there have been nine
repeals on our um I guess that's title
30 occupations and professions Midwifery
nine
repeals eight out of those nine repeals
have happened
in the last two to three years when we
have been under
State um what is the
word State
supervision I think the um to reduce
Workforce barriers and provide State
supervision over regulatory bodies this
is in 1271 so we have been working with
oplc and they have provided very nice
administrative services for us but as
we've been having a this relationship
more and more repeals have been
happening to our Midwifery law and this
next step is a huge one to basically cut
our our mid burey Council not only does
it take away our autonomy it's a very
unique profession but it also Cuts our
um Council down to three and compromises
the expertise going into that so I'll
take questions if there are any thank
you so much for your testimony are there
any questions from the committee yes
representative
Gro what type of repeals are the nine
repeals that you're referring to you
know that was the last thing I was gonna
I do not know except that I will say I I
have the old copy in my notebook and I
was going to go change those but like
let's say section 326 D9 repealed by
2021 effective 20 July 2021 section 326
d10 10 entire paragraphs just taken out
um and that was so I'm I'm sorry that I
don't have that information I really was
I asked myself the same question and I
didn't have time to look that follow
that's okay can you send it to us I'm
sorry could you send it to us yeah that
would we don't have to decide today we
can get that information thank you I
just need to ask somebody who I send it
to how to get it to you I'll get you
that information okay thank you
representative Manti thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question when
you talk about midy it's nurse midv
Doula midv all the midv included or just
the medical okay that's a good question
um the New Hampshire midwy Council does
not include nurse midwives so these are
we call ourselves Community midwives
because we do home birth and birth
center birth so we don't do births in
the
hospital follow up thank you one
followup to
that so you are supervised by Midwife
not or your board has doctors
obstetrician and pediatrician so but on
a supervisory to get your license it is
a midwife that provides the so the um
as historically this Council has had all
of the regulatory
autonomy and that's certification
discipline making rules and regulations
um of late and I believe this is one of
the repeals um the oplc is has taken
discipline away from the mid rfy Council
and um we still are making rules and
regulations under Bill 1271 the
executive Council the executive director
has the the say over our rules and
regulations with a consultation of an
Advisory Board of three of three people
who don't span the expertise so it's
just the Midwifery Council has to come
out of this bill and I'll follow up with
repeals seeing no other questions thank
you so much for your testimony thank
reboard
good morning and allot for allowing me
to speak I am Mark caring I'm a
pediatrician who is also on the uh
Midwifery board I've been on the m wiffy
board for the last 10 years um so I'm
the physician representative for
Pediatrics and uh I currently um am a
nursery rounder at conquered hospital as
well so I take care of newborns in my
professional life and being a member of
the mid rery board is somewhat out of
the spectrum for most pediatricians
because I'm supporting home
birthing um but because I feel that
people in New Hampshire need to have a
choice that they can make I support this
but I oppose this bill that's being put
forward um I think the Midwifery board
has done an incredible job in in
supervising the midwif fre people in the
state of New Hampshire and I think this
bill will take that power completely
away and I think it's going to give it
to an organization that I really feel
doesn't have the medical expertise to
really take it over and that's my
biggest concern because right now we
have an obstetrician who knows about
Women's Care you have a pediatrician who
takes care of newborns you have midwives
that are in the community taking care of
women and we help to supervise that and
help with that and I just don't think
the oplc has the understanding to do
that I mean it's much like I don't see
the Board of Medicine I don't see the
board of dentistry I don't see the uh
Board of Nursing being taken over by the
oplc and I feel our committee is in that
sort of
Stratus that we take care of patients
and there's a lot of medical expertise
that you need to have that they just
don't have and so I think also when we
talk about what they're proposing of
their being only a thre member board it
shows a true lack of under
misunderstanding by the oplc of exactly
what we do and so that's the reason I
oppose the
bill great uh do you take questions
absolutely representative manui thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question how is this community mid viery
has being able to provide much needed
care in rural New Hampshire where the
access to uh Hospital might be an hour
away or two hours away well it all
depends so you know certainly in New
Hampshire the biggest thing we're
running into is the fact that more and
more hospitals are are reducing their
maternity care so you just can't birth a
baby in some areas of New Hampshire
because hospitals can no longer support
the medical staff to to birth so that
does give the
opportunity that there can be
Community birthing
care that could be available it would be
with a with a midwife who tend to be in
those sort of rural
areas
any other questions yes representative
Brown uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question uh following
up on some of the other uh testimony and
represent goalie's question um do you
see that this if passed would eliminate
Workforce barriers for midwives wanting
to work in New
Hampshire it I I'm not sure actually but
it there there's always been sort of an
an issue between sort of the medical o
epical care and midwives in a sense and
so it all depends on who they elect or
who gets placed on the as that advisory
physician if you actually had an
OBGYN that was opposed to Midwifery you
could have a complete change in the
whole setting of mid wiffy in the state
of New
Hampshire uh thank you that's fair thank
you yes representative
Gro thank you so perhaps because this
bill says that it's supposed to
eliminate Workforce barriers and provide
St
supervision I think what we're trying to
do is really get to the nut of the
matter and I think what changes the
changes to advisory boards I think we
really affects the potential quality of
care that
our residents our New Hampshire Gran
Staters would receive is that can you
comment on that because we're we're all
we're focused on the efficiency yet
there's nothing about quality of care
here and my concern is that this
Direction takes some of these boards
into
potential um what's the word unforeseen
circumstances regarding quality of care
so could you comment on that please
where I think this is shortsighted is
because when you do look at and as I
said before we're a medical board I
don't see the Board of Medicine I don't
see the board of dentistry I don't see
the Board of Nursing being put into this
role but yet we are when I feel that our
board does the medical care it looks
over it it well we don't have the
license you're in a sense anymore we get
the we get the clearance once it goes to
op but the other part is is that when
you look at the sort of medical
supervision that we give to the midwives
that is really what our function is and
raising the standard to a certain bar
and I think that you know certainly with
an Advisory Board again the what
information comes in is going to be
first screened and then asked to the
person if that person doesn't have that
medical expertise to even know what
they're
seeing that's I I think is just just
going to be
dismal thank you uh representative Shu
thank you Mr chair um I've kind of
addressed this issue previously and I
recall hearing that um midwives are a
great deal of Health Care for Women
particularly in rural areas the North
country of New Hampshire where perhaps a
medical professional such as your heal
yourself
is not readily available would you see
that that's still the
case yeah I I think that's an issue
throughout New Hampshire is that you
know it's it's so interesting as healthc
care has become more for profit um and
you know it's no longer being subsidized
it's no longer I mean and you see that
because you just can't support a
hospital you're closing different areas
Obstetricians require you know at least
three Obstetricians in one area so that
you can cover call and do everything and
have a life and you can find that
hospitals just can't afford them anymore
so that's what's New Hampshire's running
into anyway is the fact that you just
can't you you're seeing us the the the
birthing centers being put in larger
areas where they can afford to have more
Physicians and you can actually have a
professional life and a personal
life
yes representative gold thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question I I have a few questions trying
to understand I could have asked anybody
I'm asking you who's testified but um my
first question is are you paid as a
board member nope it's all okay follow
um if the Advisory Board in the bill was
written in such a way that it would
maintain the same
members would you oppose have the same
opposition would that lessen your
opposition to it I still would I still
would I I again I I I go back to that I
just don't feel feel the oplc has the
medical
expertise to review these cases and I
understand that I don't mean to cut you
off right no um so the question I have
is if you're volunteer would there be
anything and and you may not have the
whole answer to this but would there be
anything precluding you all from
continuing to meet regularly and provide
a lot of the work that you're doing and
be available if oplc had any technical
questions which they're already doing
the licensing correct correct but not
they're not doing the medical case
reviews and and that's what we we review
so if someone has a complaint we review
it if in fact our
board has a form that if anyone is
transferred to the hospital mother or
infant that is brought before the board
and reviewed
so we we just don't work on patient
complaints we also are supervising and
doing an overview of Midwifery practice
in the state of New
Hampshire okay thank you yeah and I
guess in I just don't think the oplc can
take that on one last followup sure so
it's your understanding that through
this bill that um that review role that
the board's currently doing would no
longer be done by the advisory committee
I I don't know exactly what the Advisory
Board other than some someone saying I
have a case we want you to look at it
okay thank you that will help me to
follow up with questions later on thank
you thank you for your testimony thank
you yes and the executive director will
be giving testimony so I'm sure she can
clarify the intent there um do
Juvia hi
office that's correct uh good morning
still for five more minutes just for the
record D jurus from Governor cun's
office uh just here to make myself
available for any questions for the
committee any
questions represent
goie thank you Mr chair and um ask you
the same question I've asked others as
to the statement about reducing barriers
and how going from a board to advisory
is doing that because I
thought by us giving oplc the ability to
move licensing along as long as the
person met qualifications was already
doing that process and I'm not sure how
making boards
advisory expands upon that if you could
explain why that statement's in here and
how this reduces barriers yeah happy to
thank you for the question and um I I
think you make a fair point um I think
that was the kind of the general purpose
statement for a number of the priorities
for the reg regul regulatory reform
which this bill was included in taking a
look more broadly at the licensing um
the boards across the board and
Workforce in general um I think a more
accurate uh description of the intent
for this specific
legislation um I think part of it was
definitely looking at the the increase
in liability because of the lower number
of lenses and and director Courtney will
speak more specifically to this but um
kind of the coff metric we used was
under 200 licens genes was recommending
and then under a certain number of
complaints recommended to go to advisory
um and as this committee is really
familiar with the um the board of dental
examiners out of North Carolina Supreme
Court case where board members can be
held personally liable for antitrust
violations against other professionals
um I think this this U group is also
aware that the the state of Vermont uh
all of their boards including their
Board of Medicine their Board of Nursing
are advisory specifically because of
that liability concern um so it's it's
not a a value statement of the
profession or the importance or even
health and safety in that regard because
the licensing protections are still in
place um but the mechanism of that
advisory role removes the liability from
the individuals on the board those
volunteers who are also professionals
with livelihoods and places that solely
on the state who would take the
enforcement action so I would say that's
the that would be the
primary push behind this specific
legislation and the workforce barriers
is more um that's a a broader picture
that that purpose statement is kind of
included in all of the legislation that
you've seen about this regulatory reform
so I hope that helps clear it up I think
your point is well
taken uh yes followup
representative and
I understand the court case that came
forward question but I also thought that
by giving the authority of the executive
director to review applicants and pro
licensing was a way of solving that
problem and not the board's doing the
licensing and approving licensing
themselves am I wrong
in as to a reason why we went that way I
I think you are correct that was a big
in terms of the workforce barriers and
expedite in the process that's the
reason that we went that direction uh
when I say we really you right it was
your subcommittee that did the work that
determined that this was needed um and
and then pass the bills in the last
legislative session so I would agree
with you that was a big piece of it on
that efficiencies the liability I think
is still there because they are
ultimately making that determination the
investigation is still happening with
well is now happening with the office
but I I do still think there's that
decision with the board so I don't think
that liabilities totally removed for
licensing board as ex exists and any
other specifics I will I will defer to
director Courtney yeah yes
representative
groa maybe this question is better for
representative Gro representative I mean
uh oh my god um you're giving her a
promotion executive director Courtney
but um when you talk about licensing
less than 200 lenses and the number of
complaints aren't those um
how did you I mean is was there a
mechanism to determine whether or not
the complaints were a result
of of uh bored inefficiencies or bored
inexperience or you know I mean just
have the number of complaints it could
be complaints against licensing which
you know we took care of in the last so
I I'd like to have more definition of
that and I um also would like to comment
that the fact that you know you put this
broad thing and then you P you know as
far as removing barriers and then put
all these boards in here under you know
something where your intentions are
quite different I think changes the
whole focus of
this of this
group can you comment on that yeah I'd
be happy to I think I addressed a lot of
that in my response to representative
goalie but I will also
say as a former member of the House and
as someone who spent a lot of time with
legislation I think purpose statements
can get uh challenging they can kind of
Muddy the statute um so for me
personally I'm not I'm not sure that
they're necessarily helpful be because
of exactly what you're mentioning um so
I think like I said I think it was kind
of a broad piece that was attached to
each of those um and I do I do
understand that the your point is well
taken about the text on the page does
not tell the whole story I think that is
often the case I think we all read
legislation and say what what prompted
that what possibly could have prompted
hearings representative man py thank you
Mr CH thank you for taking my question
um in terms of a broad sweep just taking
under 200 lenses less complaints or no
complaints whatever um that's one
arbitrary measure that was taken to kind
of list all the boards when you talk
about other states which are advised
board are the volunteer advisory boards
or are they paid advisory boards or a
professional Advisory board has that
been
compared thank you for the question I do
not know the answer to that I'd be happy
to look into that for you um director
courner may also know um for that case
as well um as you know though it is all
volunteers in New Hampshire whether it's
professionals or public
members I would also say um the cut off
of 200 was a deliber choice but it the
idea was to not discriminate based on
what profession or how important anyone
individual thought that was but to say
here's objective an objective uh not
yeah a not subjective way to say below
this number will convert to advisory um
just because the ratio of board members
to
lenses gets higher the smaller number of
lenses and the larger number of board
members so it it was meant to be a more
objective measure rather than just
saying well you know such and such
profession is yeah they're fine they're
doing okay there's only a few of them we
can just make them advisory that was
that really was not the calculus so just
for clarification on that point you're
saying the 200 cuto off isn't so much
about the two the number of the 200 it's
the the ratio between the board members
and the lenses and how how tight that
ratio is that that's how the 200 number
was was decided was to say that the the
risk of antitrust violations or
liability would increase as that
percentage is larger right to board
members to
licenses so if you have um you know five
board members and 50
lenses then you're you're taking 10 10%
of the profession is advising the whole
piece so there's greater opportunity for
that potential and not saying anything
about motives of members at all um but
just that potential liability exists
there thank you representative Brown did
questions you're under the gun we can
like so based on on your answer to
representative
if we can fix a liability problem that
all the boards can stay the way they are
doing with reservations I will say yes
if we can fix the liability problem I'm
not sure what that mechanism would look
like given of the that it's a US Supreme
Court decision but in theory yes thank
you
thank you very much for your
time last but not least executive
director
Courtney and if you would be so kind
during your testimony to clarify the
difference between the board and
great thank you Mr chair members of the
committee Lindsay Courtney executive
director office of professional LA
Insurance
certification and with me is our general
councel Douglas
osterhout um so I I think there's a a a
lot of
misunderstanding about what an Advisory
Board is what the purpose is um and I
just I just want to give a brief
overview I know that some of you
probably already know this um but we do
have seven advisory boards already in
existence in New Hampshire and they work
very well and they're in they cover very
different fields
um but essentially uh it's a different
regulatory model that provides State
supervision and in the last 10 years a
lot of States including Vermont have
started to move in the direction of um
providing active State supervision over
what what were their independent
regulatory boards and it really stems
from the 2015 Supreme Court case North
Carolina um Dental examiners and
basically in that case North Carolina
Dental Board issued a bunch of cease and
disce to individuals um who were not
dentists saying you need to stop
advertising for teeth whing because that
is the practice of dentistry and the
federal government stepped in and said
um essentially this is an
anti-competitive act um you're trying to
limit
competition the state took the position
that they were Li they were immune um
because they were acting um as the North
Carolina regulatory board they were
acting as the state so they were immune
from liability under the Sherman Act the
Supreme Court said no uh and the reason
for that was this board like most of our
boards in New Hampshire are comprised
primarily a majority of active Market
participants and what this means is they
work in the field they are
lenes and what the Supreme Court said is
you know essentially without passing
judgment it is very hard almost
impossible POS for people to wear two
hats um it is it's very hard for them to
um not uh regulate when they have this
bias which is that they're business
owners and they're also Professionals in
the field and so unless the state is
going to provide what they call Active
State
supervision uh the state is not immune
from liability and so as a result of
that um which was kind of a um it was a
very important case in the field of of
Occupational regulation because of that
a lot of states started moving in the
direction of providing State supervision
now there are a couple of ways to do
this advisory model is one which is
essentially you utilize the expertise of
the board members but you give State
oversight and somebody who's not an
active participant that'll that'll
Shield you from liability that is one
model and we have that in our state the
other model is to just completely
eliminate the board and just put it all
in the hands of a state body um or a
state actor uh we have that in New
Hampshire as well with opic dispensing I
personally don't like that model because
it leaves the agency without the
authority to have that consultation
method with the experts and I have um uh
actually supported um the creation of
boards a board in the past um and then
the third is really just to make the
boards a majority of public members
because if the majority of the board is
not comprised of active Market
participants then that
the the concern raised by the Supreme
Court in that case is not relevant from
our perspective that one is difficult we
wouldn't really be able to implement
that here given that we already have uh
a huge problem filling public member
seats so that's the gist of why a lot of
states have moved in this direction
again it's not um it's not a value
judgment about which boards are more
important it's really to Shield the
state from liability and will say and
I'm not going to get into
examples but we have those issues in New
Hampshire we absolutely have those
issues in New Hampshire um where
regulations are put into place um that
maybe theoretically on its face are for
public safety reasons but um if you are
privy to the conversations behind the
scenes it's really to starve out
competition um and so uh while we have
not had any lawsuits in New Hampshire
yet that I'm aware of um there is there
is a risk of liability so um just want
to put that on the table in terms of
practice how does it work in New
Hampshire so we have seven advisory
boards and then we have the registration
which is alic dispensing and they cover
all types of fields Medical Imaging
massage body art reflexology Respiratory
Care which is in the health field
recreational ther therapy and court
reporters totally different and what it
does is I think it's the perfect
marriage between the two you've got
experts in the field of administration
internal controls um the ability to
actually uh govern um and then you've
got experts in the field and you have to
collaborate and we do and that's why I
don't really like these pieces of
legislation because it pits the boards
against the office but I would say that
we have a very collaborative
relationship with these advisory boards
um and we're able to have very
productive conversations and and get the
regulations um
done so um I've circulated some
statistics uh for the various boards
that are um proposing this bill to go to
advisory um and you'll see the number of
meetings they had in FY 23 the number of
lienes the number of
complaints um I would say that I would
agree that the transfer of Licensing
Authority has really helped because
we're no longer required to go to a
board meeting and so we're no longer
waiting for boards to make a decision so
Corum really isn't impacting that area
um anymore um but if there are no rules
in place there is nothing that we can do
and I would draw your attention to
installation standards in particular
they've had one meeting their rules are
expired we're out of compliance with the
federal government and there's literally
nothing that the state can do because um
because they're not meeting and that
particular board the majority of the
appointments are not done by the
governor so we're really just held
hostage by by um the lack of ability to
to secure a quum now if it were an
Advisory Board essentially um the lack
of a quorum would not necessarily be a
problem um if we would prefer to convene
a meeting obviously um and and go
through that process but even if there
was one person available to have a phone
call so we could get the expertise
needed we could at least move forward
with an initial proposal and try to come
into compliance with the federal
government right now we have no ability
to do that um so so that's a concern the
thing I wanted to point out is massage
and reflexology are already advisory
boards what's proposed in this bill is
actually merging them and I had a really
good conversation with the massage board
about this I said look what why why were
these separated out because if you look
at other states um they have reflexology
Asian Bodywork and structural
integration with the massage board and
they said it actually happened many
years years ago and it had to do over um
changing of national exams and they
actually opposed it at the time and they
were supportive of merging um the board
uh the boards together so I did want to
make I did want to make that comment um
there were a couple of comments made and
I think I just want to take the
opportunity to kind of correct uh the
record the first the first being um that
uh as you know um statutes when they
give an agent Authority they don't give
it to the department they don't give it
to the office they give it to the
commissioner and that's because the
commissioner the director is responsible
under statute for all execution of those
responsibilities that doesn't mean that
that person does everything that is
required in that statute I mean that
would not be possible so when we look at
the statutory framework it's not that I
personally am going to be looking at
every application that's not true I will
say practically I am involved in every
rulemaking for every Advisory Board
under the office I personally review
them I personally respond to comments um
and I'm not saying that's necessary but
I personally do that um but but it's not
one person taking on that task so I just
I I know you know that but I just wanted
to say that for the record the other um
issue that came up concerned Guardian
guardian ad items and I agree these are
incredibly important roles and and
that's one of the challenges with the
current structure which is that they've
they've only had three meetings in FY 23
and when we talk about the complaints
that were received the statute that
authorized oplc to investigate didn't go
into effect until very recently and my
understanding is previously what was
happening is that there was a member of
the board and another member of the
board that I guess would come into the
office and review the complaints but
unless the board was actually meeting
there was nothing that could get done on
the complaints so I take issue with the
the um uh the representation that the
office hasn't acted when it had the
ability to do so because that that is
not the
case um I
think I I think that um you know
regardless of what the committee you
know decides to do with these boards I
just want to reiterate mainly for the
people in this room that the the goal of
the office is to ensure compliance with
the law to ensure that we're not um
promoting or facilitating
anti-competitive
regulations um to be efficient and then
to work
collaboratively um with those who are
experts um because I don't know midwif
Frey for example um but I do know uh the
statutory framework and I do know the
laws that relates to 91a and 541a and
the practice acts and I think working
together we can come up with some
regulations for the benefit of our
constituents with that I'd be happy to
answer any questions
thank you very much executive director
any questions yes representative goalie
then Brown thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question so my question
is since we have and I'll go back to I
had asked this
previously since we have given more
authority to your
office in dispensing of
Licensing and the in as well as the
invest investigate you know what I'm
talking
investigatory
requirements wouldn't that
be in a way
enough to cover what was in that Supreme
Court case as to giving to you that
Authority so it's it it will cover most
it won't cover the regulation piece and
I'll give you an example of of how this
has worked in New Hampshire um I think
to the state's benefit so a couple of
years ago the legislature passed a
statute that said um for microblading
which is basically tattooing of the
eyebrows and other parts of your face um
we're going to allow cosmetologists to
engage in this cosmetic procedure and
not just body artists and um they have
to the board or the office has to have
rules in place in order to allow that to
happen the person's going to have to get
a license and y y yada so at the time
the body artart board which is an
Advisory Board was very supportive of
this and the legislature passed the
statute well come to find out the other
body artists in the industry were not so
happy about that because there are a lot
of cosmetologists who were who and this
is this is a growing industry who are
really interested in microblading and
cosmetic um uh practices so they were
concerned they were going to lose
business and so the body art board said
no no no no just kidding we don't want
to do those rules well because the
office had rulemaking Authority I
basically said to them look we got to do
it the legislature said we have to do it
I'm going to do it but I really like
your advice and your expertise so I
don't mess this up and we were able to
get it done but if they had been an
independent regulatory body there would
be no rules I guarantee it today which
could create a risk to the state if
somebody wanted to bring in enforcement
example representative Brown uh thank
you Mr chair and thank you director for
taking my question
um and thank you for clarifying for the
board that you don't do all of the work
in these
laws um but to kind of follow up on that
there was a number of comments made that
as as this work gets passed down through
your through your employees there isn't
the expertise to make the decisions
needed so can you can you speak to that
so you think the decision points are
really at the ru making well I should
say they're at the R making um level and
then also in disciplinary hearings and
so I'll talk about rle making first
obviously that has to go through public
hearing so um so there's always going to
be opportunity to receive input from
professionals and we have a statutory
obligation to notify them but the way it
works uh practically for us is we do Ru
making um we draft a set of rules
usually based on what was previously in
place we convene a meeting um we come to
a ensus and agreement with the board and
then we file the IP that's how it
practically works so we get their input
on on that now sometimes uh we don't get
the input and we just move forward and
then I'll give you another example
regarding body art um body art uh had
wanted for years to do facility
licensing we thought we needed a
statutory change come to find out I took
a separate look second look at the
statute I'm like I don't think we need a
statutory change so we decided to move
forward with ruem now the board very
much wanted establishment ler so we put
together a set of rules based on another
state and we sent it to the board we
asked them to review we asked them to
review we asked them to review and they
didn't get back so we just moved forward
with the IP um and then we had held the
public hearing well the public they were
not very excited about this um and we
got some really good feedback that I
didn't get from the boards and we
withdrew The Proposal um so there there
are many instances to receive that
feedback our hope is that in the board
can provide that feedback prior to
filing um you know filing an IP the
other instance is with disciplinary
proceedings so many of our boards we
contract with Consultants to provide
investigative support um I would say
there's a little bit more flexibility
with the advisory boards because
typically the complaint will come in um
to enforcement it'll get investigated
and then it'll proceed and it goes to
our uh hearings office officer who then
will consult with the board um if
necessary but sometimes enforcement
needs an expert and
because the agency can act without a
quorum of the board we can utilize that
person as part of the investigation
instead of as part of the adjudicatory
hearing you know we get a lot of massage
complaints that have to do with you know
sex assault that don't necessarily uh
require expertise and we can act on them
quickly
but then there are others that um that
we absolutely need their expertise and
so it's it's a very collaborative
relationship and that's what I would
like to emphasize um and and how they
provide that consultation to the highest
level of their um capability thank you
may follow up you may thank you U it it
is related I believe so based on that
you you sort of answered this to some
degree I
think
based on some testimony and what I'm
kind of hearing between the lines from
others how do you feel about the comment
that if this passes The Advisory boards
don't have anything to do that they they
have no place and that they become uh
pointless I I strongly disagree with
that and there and we try we strive to
treat our advisory boards in the same
manner as um our independent regulatory
bodies um you know they get paid a per
DM just like everybody else they get
invited to the board chair meetings we
spend time with them there's a little
bit greater
flexibility um because the agency can
the agency can act um which which is
good when um particularly you have few
lienes and there have been instances
where we've had boards had to completely
recuse themselves from a disciplinary
matter and the case just doesn't go
anywhere because nobody is able to step
in and act on their behalf um um so I
would say that um if there is an active
Advisory Board which most of them are uh
they they fully participate um as you'll
see massage regularly
meets um well they've increased the
number of meetings because we've been
talking about different pieces of
legislation and how to handle the
establishment issue in particularly
human trafficking which is a separate
issue um but uh but they they regularly
meet um
so we and so does MRT they meet
monthly thank you representative Le us
as much as I would love your input
you're on the bill just had an exchange
email exchange with the clerk on this
point okay and the response from him is
prime sponsor should present their bill
and not return to the table co-sponsors
May either testify or ask questions but
not both and I have not testified I love
that clarification I'd love for you to
join in okay thank you uh I thought I'd
remember it that way but I could have
been wrong so Mike this gets back to to
what extent we did already has um
eliminated the liability issue and this
gets to the question I understand that
the investigation part has moved to
oplc entirely I think um but on the ad
judicary I you know making the Judgment
making the final decision if it's an
Advisory Board I understand that's with
oplc but if it's a regular board isn't
that still with the board and doesn't
that potentially leave the board and the
state open to liability and to clarify
that the liability to on the board is
individual to the people on the board is
that correct it it can be um and yes
that they yes it under independent
regulatory bodies have sole Authority
for adjudication the office only
provides um a hearings examiner that has
certain procedural Authority but the
substance is lies with the board okay
thank you
clarification on that while it's on the
table in that scenario is the state also
liable or is it just the members of the
board well I think um no the state could
always be liable I mean any lawyer can
make of a claim
um so and having defended the state in a
lot of uh wacky cases you can always you
can always make an argument um so
certainly that's always an issue and
when oplc acts that's an issue right but
then there are immunities involved MH
goalie so I'm glad you clarified your
attachment because um Miss jurus had
said that the these boards were on this
bill because there were less than 200
lies had to do with the number of
complaints and the ratio between the
number of board members and the number
of lenses none of which is on your
attachment other than the
complaints so is it possible to get this
kind the information on which these
boards were determined because it says I
do did I Mis misunderstand that these or
that these boards were chosen because
that there were less than 200 licenses
and that had to do with and also the
ratio of the board members to The lenses
and also the number of complaints not to
put any bias on the profession so this
the criteria for which these boards were
chosen
can you share that with the committee
because it's not on this attachment so I
understood her testimony to be that um
it that it was a flat 200 being the
objective standard and when you consider
200 in relation to the number of board
members whatever that is it's usually
five or seven um the ratio is so small
so I don't think there was an
independent calculation based on how
many board members are on acupuncture
versus how many
are on you know G's versus installation
standards it was 200 now the one thing I
wanted to draw your attention was
medical technicians and we talked about
that um th that obviously doesn't have
the 200 lcy threshold the challenge with
medical technicians is that it's not an
actual profession nobody identifies as a
medical technician it's just somebody
who's otherwise unlicensed who may come
into contact with a controlled drug
that's not a profession and by virtue of
that we cannot recruit board members so
they've had zero meetings for years
we've received complaints we can't act
on them so regardless of what the
legislature decides to do I would say
it's largely dysfunctional and something
needs to happen so that's why that one
is on this list even though it doesn't
meet the the criteria that Miss jerius
um previously
stated follow up so when you meet when
you say installation standards you're
talking about number five which is the
manufactured housing installation
standards right yes actually the name of
the license though is a it's it's an
install it's an installer so yes correct
that's all thank you representative
goalie thank you Mr
chair first I want to go well we're back
on what representative groa asked and
your response to the medical technicians
and I thought I heard you say you had
numerous complaints this sheet says one
complaint in 2023 would you reiterate
yes this is FY 23 so we have have we
have other complaints that were received
outside the FY 23 time frame they
haven't met in years so we received some
in fy22 we've received some in fy2 24 we
received one in FY
23 that the way it stated it sounded
like you had numerous complaints in a
year but I see only one here but M can
you stated that you rely on the medical
or expertise on the boards correct can
you explain why we heard concerns from
both the Midwifery board and the
guardian Liam board as to members being
removed from the board that they feel
are important in experience and
expertise um that should remain on the
board as to why they were removed if
you're going to rely on the expertise of
these individuals are you talking about
specific people or positions positions I
think we heard one was an OB position
and um pediatrician pediatrician and
there was uh also I think a position or
two mentioned by uh Mr Gordon uh at the
guard guardium at Liam that they were
were curious about why they were removed
yeah I can't speak to that specific
policy decision I will say that all of
our current advisory boards are only
three um so it could just be that that
is the model I will say several years
ago I don't know if you recall but there
was another bill introduced to propose
to move Midwifery to
advisory um and that bill I believe was
ited but we worked with the council in
between and we came up with some
legislation that they were agreeable to
um to move to advisory it's a little bit
different from this language I think it
included five people and included two
positions that they were interested in
and I'd be happy to circulate that
language um that they had agreed to
previously um G's I can't speak to that
particular issue again we haven't had a
my primary concern with G's is that they
continue to have Quorum issues in large
part because the legislative members
don't attend um but they've only had
three meetings in a year so that's
challenge any other questions from the
committee yes representative man thank
you Mr Mr chair question to me is just
listening to your
testimony the shift of
responsibility for several boards is
going from distributed amongst different
regulatory boards to
oplc that is too much Powers shift in
terms of Regulation and uh oversight
don't you think think that is that shift
is huge mega
shift um well I would disagree with that
I would say that um you know
fundamentally right and this may be
somewhat
controversial uh no profession is has
entitlement to regulate their own
profession it's it's the states the
state has chosen this model and it's a
very popular model but the reason why
lure exists is to protect the public and
so when we talk about your right to
practice a particular profession the
state has imposed a barrier saying you
can't do this profession unless you have
a license because the state deems it
necessary to regulate that and restrict
entry and the state has many options for
determining how to regulate it
historically the board the state has
decided to put that Authority with
independent regulatory bodies but that
doesn't need that doesn't need to be the
case and other states have different
models and I would say it's up to the
state the legislature as to how it
chooses to regulate because the
legislator you are delegating that
body any further questions I most of
mine got touched on I just had one left
on my list um you had mentioned trouble
meeting compliance with Federal
Regulations can you give us some idea of
if you're not meeting those regulations
what the
consequences generally I know it's Broad
but you know what they could be I guess
it's not going to impact us it's going
to impact the individuals who purchase
manufactured homes in terms of what
standards they must comply with for
installation and as you probably can
appreciate the federal standards impose
costs um it I know it's shocking um so
we don't want that to be the case so
it's really it's it's it really could
impact the constituents and it's less
about the regulations because if we
don't have regulations in place that are
effective then the federal standards
apply which are more burning some okay
and and actually just clarification on
the composition of the advisory boards
if we move forward with this particular
model um does the department um have
concerns with potentially opening The
Advisory board up to more members than
are currently there or there anything
like any pitfalls that we would have to
be concerned about in So doing we don't
have concerns about that I mean we want
to make it um you know 20 people is
difficult to work with but you know
it if if there's a need to make it 5
seven I we prefer odd numbers for Quorum
purposes but we we don't have a problem
with that okay thank you so much for
your testimony thank you for your
time does anybody else wish to testify
1271 uh seeing none uh this is going to
go to subcommittee uh Tony's and Tony do
you want to work with Jackie and split
on this
or okay and uh I will close the public
hearing and we will recess for lunch and
1:15
for
good afternoon welcome to Edna I'm
opening the hearing on House Bill 1408
leus thanks to the chair and committee
um for the record I'm representative
Tony leus uh at District Hillsboro 38
representing the towns of Hudson and
Lichfield so this is another one of the
bills that was uh put in at at the
request of the governor and some of them
you know I've had more involvement with
and and uh uh you know and maybe done
some redrafts this one is basically uh
straight as it came and I don't have a
lot to say about it it merges some
boards and make some other changes um
you know just following in general terms
uh what we did last year but I'm going
to i' prefer letting other people speak
as to the purpose of this bill and then
Barry
you
have good afternoon Madam chair
honorable members of the committee uh my
name is Jake Barry I'm the vice
president of policy and new Futures as
many of you know new Futures as a
nonpartisan nonprofit Health policy and
advocacy organization we've been working
for more than 20 5 years to help address
substance use and behavioral health
issues in our state um I feel a little
bit funny testifying before somebody has
had the opportunity to sort of outline
the bill but I do want to um stress new
Futures concerns about this bill
specifically the provision proposing to
merge the board of mental health
practice with the board of psychologists
and especially the the late act board uh
we certainly understand and appreciate
the intent of the bill for years we've
worked to increase uh or overcome to
help our state overcome barriers to care
including increasing efficiencies uh in
licensing and eliminating bureaucratic
hurdles within our licensing boards um
certainly we understand there's much
work left to do on that front to get our
licensing process where we need it to be
uh but frankly we feel that um we don't
believe that combining these critical
boards is the way to do it um as you
know each of these boards serves an
independent and specific field within
our behavioral health treatment system
each one has its own specialty training
its own education and Professional
Standards uh we a we have a state have
worked very hard to establish grow and
Define these professions so they're able
to meet the unique needs of the people
they serve uh to merge these boards
without deep review evaluation and
consultation with the professionals they
serve could deeply harm and undermine
our treatment system we've worked so
hard to build uh it would sacrifice the
autonomy of these professions and create
confusion across the network which could
contribute to licensing delays and
further Workforce shortages uh again
this could undermine our treatment
system and limit our ability to overcome
our ongoing addiction and mental health
crisis and to prevent the next one uh
with that uh I thank you for your time
and I'm happy to take
questions are there any questions
representative maputi thank you madam
chair thank you Mr Barry for taking my
question sure um you said 25 years ago
was uh when new Futures started in
advocating um from your perspective was
these two boards separate or were
created separately
that some of the psychology and the
Mental Health Board psychologist and the
Mental Health Board I'm certain thank
you for the question representative I'm
certain there are others in the room who
can recount the history uh better than I
can but certainly uh you know I think
that with the establishment specifically
of the the the lak board the board of
other Alcohol and Other Drug counselors
uh you know that was really a critical
part of the effort to establish again
this field as sort of freestanding is
separate from you know is it's a
separate field it's a separate science
it's a separate medicine and in some
ways from uh mental health there there's
obviously some areas of overlap and we
have really worked hard to increase uh
sort of collaboration within those areas
of overlap but they are freestanding
fields and we and we feel strongly that
such representative Schmidt thank you
madam chair so um
Jake the this committee was the
operative committee and the hearing on
the bill to separate
psychologist out of the board of mental
health practice about 10 years ago I
think sure maybe not quite 10
years has that uh separation worked in
the best interest of the psychologists
and the people in New Hampshire and your
opinion um again thank you
representative for the question again I
think that there are other folks
practicing in the field uh who are in
the room today who could speak more
directly to it I think that um you know
it has helped having these separate
boards has helped to sort of maintain
the nuances between these practices for
sure and again help to support uh uh the
existence of the as separate
freestanding Fields but I I would I
would argue again knowing that our focus
at new new Futures is primarily on the
the substance use side of things again
these are are are separate Fields there
separate fields of medicine again we we
think that um they need to be treated as
you thank
you thank you very much any other
good afternoon my name
is uh you can call me
Reggie sorry my French accent okay
that's okay thank you um esteemed
members um I was hoping to go towards
the end because there's going to be
quite a few things that people are going
to say before me I am currently a member
of the leak board have been a member
since um February of last
year uh my concerns in terms of this
particular bill is as Mr Barry had said
before me is that although there are
many
similarities uh regarding the profession
of mental health um each one has its own
particular aspects to it that are unique
to the profession um I cannot speak to
school psychologist but I am duly
licensed I am licensed as an mlc but
also as a clinical mental health
counselor so I report basically my
licenses are under the jurisdiction of
two boards oh and one more acupuncture I
do the not a protocol for persons with
addiction acupuncture for detoxification
purposes in any case um my concern is
that
uh persons I'm always thinking about the
public saf safety I remind myself of
that every time I go to a board meeting
uh if ever you'd like to attend second
Thursday of the month uh at oplc 9:00
a.m. for the public meeting you're
always welcome um the lak profession I
was just sharing with a representative
from the board of mental health who's
with us today I find that it is
basically mental health counseling with
a specialization in substance use and
addiction you know I think of it in term
terms of and I do this with my clients I
like to give analogies the dealing with
medical because most people get that um
for instance if I'm a doctor I'm a
general practitioner of
PCP and I have a patient who has
problems with their kidneys I'm not an
expert in kidneys I'm going to refer
them to a nephologist who has a medical
degree but had specialized training
for
nefrology
right making the analogy real life uh in
terms of with uh the professions I'm in
I've had several referrals from Mental
Health Counselors
who find they're not qualified to deal
with persons with
addictions and they refer them to a
person who is licensed to deal with such
persons
um and that's perfectly fine however the
training needed to become a licensed ALC
alcohol drug counselor N&M leak is very
specific in addition to the mental
health so in in that sense um yes rules
would be different and the experts
needed would be different with the
proposed composition of em merged board
the newly merged board would be reduced
to one mlac who by the way also needs to
be
knowledgeable about the Certified
Recovery service
worker that is something very different
from an mlc or lak
position it's your you could call it a
licensed peer recovery support
worker I will be fully transparent with
you I don't know much about Certified
Recovery service support
workers that's why we have a
representative on the board yes I of
course I do know something but when
there's something very intricate I turn
to that current member which statute
requires there be a crsw member present
to be to be able to answer such
questions and I feel very confident when
I do turn to
her with the newly merged boards there
would not be such a person
then with the newly formed board
proposed board any questions regarding
an mlac aak or
crsw all other members would have no
knowledge of that they would need more
knowledge of and all of that would rest
a decision maybe probably on one
person there wouldn't be much
deliberation no fault of the
psychologists or the mental health
boards that's not their area of
specialty and I think also today as we
know New Hampshire is in the top five of
overdoses I work in an organization
where they also offer sober housing in
Nashwood I'm a resident of
Hollis they had an noose death last week
in the house two weeks ago excuse me
opioid some of you may have been
affected by alcoholism substance use
either personally your family member or
friend maybe some of you unfortunately
with the state being so
deaths leex mlx
csws go through specialized training to
deal with such things I attended one
just two weeks ago through the New
Hampshire alcohol and drug abuse
Counselors Association
how to
deal with the ones left
behind after an opiate overdose
death people that might come see me for
therapy
right so I know I'm just scratching the
surface and I allotted five minutes
because I thought that perhaps there'd
be many people before me who would uh
speak and I could just say I'm here to
support what they say I didn't think I
would be the first or second
person so I do thank you for your time I
thank you each for the work that you're
doing because I'm sure you don't get
paid much for being here today just like
me so thank you and uh I'm open to
questions representative G thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question in your analogy you talked
about the kidney doctor that the general
practitioner might send somebody to is
does the kidney doctor have a kidney
license no but I would believe and again
I'm not a medical person that would they
would probably have to be board
certified by the neologist you know for
instance um a
dermatologist right so if they're going
to be a primary care physician they
could be board certified and those
usually last 10 years by the internal
board uh Board of internal medicine and
then they would have to pass an exam
take specialized studies for Dermatology
or nephology and if you want to continue
that in analogy and then be board
certified now that's something that
insurance companies require and um thank
you and so likewise we could do the same
with the I'm yeah my education and
background was in mental health field so
we could do the same in the mental
health field correct we could have
different certifications but not have to
have a board for every
specialty right there aren't boards for
every Specialties um however this one in
particular given what's going on in our
country and in particular New Hampshire
um this is uh you know addiction is
something that affects mental health as
you well
know and unfortunately it takes someone
who needs to be trained to determine if
a person has not has stopped using
whatever drug there is and they're
depressed or anxious or very paranoid
after stop Shing for 2 three months we
need to keep in mind that that's
probably upon further assessment of
course due to their cessation of drug
use now and this is nothing to against a
mental health counselor if they haven't
been open to their mental health
counselor and uh unfortunately I've seen
instances where people stop using
methamphetamine and they develop
schizophrenic types of symptoms hearing
voices audio and visual hallucinations
which they never experienced before or
they see a mental health counselor don't
tell them about their substance use or
may but that person may not know enough
and misdiagnose
them so we have to really be careful we
have to really be careful and as I said
I keep in in first and foremost in my
mind Public Safety Public Safety um I
signed up if you want to call it that I
applied and was humbly accepted to serve
on the board
and uh when I you know I don't tell too
many people that I do because you know I
don't want them to treat me differently
or whatever the case might be but I
always make sure that I use the word
serve I serve the board I serve on the
board I serve the people of New
Hampshire I want what's best for them in
terms of substance use in terms of
substance use so thank you for the
question thank you any other questions
oh sorry didn't mean to take a job I
don't see any thank you
thank you for your testimony thank
or good afternoon chair McGuire and
honorable committee members thank you
for your time today and considering
these remarks my name is laara gruner or
and I'm a licensed clinical mental
health counselor in the state of New
Hampshire I'm here today on on behalf of
the board of mental health practice
where I am a board member we hold public
meetings the third Friday of every month
which you are always welcome to join the
board of mental health is opposed to hb1
1408 due to concerns about the
consolidation of the current Board of
mental health the board of psychologists
and the board of Licensing for Alcohol
and Other Drug use which broadly
represents the range of mental health
licenses and professions in New
Hampshire what this bill proposes is to
consolidate 13 license types under one
shrunken down board with a mammoth
Practice Act with the current proposal
this would eliminate three boards and
consolidate them to one with seven
members these seven members alone would
be responsible for licensing 13
different license types this would be a
Monumental task even with a more
proportionate number of board members
the elimination of specific licenses to
rep to represent on the board would
deprive these professions of their voice
each lure type has its own ethical code
rules laws and standards of care to
consider this extends from um complaints
to rulemaking having entire professions
underrepresented when the board
promulgates rules is irresponsible we
continue to work with the oplc to
increase the speed and efficiency of
lure within our state and have made
great progress through the use of online
applications simpler ways of tracking
continuing education credits and
streamlining internal systems to
decrease any unnecessary barriers to
those seeking lure our hope is that you
would reconsider changes to the current
board structure to ensure continued
ethical and appropriate oversight to the
care of New Hampshire citizens I thank
you again for your time and welcome any
questions that you may have thank you
are there
questions excellent job thank you very
Oliver good afternoon chair Maguire and
members of the Edna committee thank you
for hearing my testimony and opposition
to hb1 1408 the seeks to consolidate the
licensing board of psychologists with
Board of mental health practice I am Dr
Celia Oliver I'm a psychologist and I'm
representing the New Hampshire
Psychological Association nhpa is a
nonprofit professional membership
organization that is a state chapter of
the national APA we have a total of 32
27 members in New
Hampshire many of my colleagues very
much wanted to stand with me today
because this is such an critical issue
for all of us however this is an
exceptionally busy time of year for
psychologist since mental health issues
especially anxiety and depression
increased dramatically after the
holidays and they were not able to clear
their schedules to be here I have
recently retired and closed my clinical
practice which allows me me to be here
before you today however I remain active
in a number of professional roles
including nhpa leadership I'm the chair
of the nhpa Ethics Committee and one of
the nhpa liazon to the board of
psychologists who attend the public
portion of their monthly meetings let me
assure you that getting a large group of
psychologists to agree on anything is
almost impossible it's like H and cats
on opposing this consolidation of
Licensing boards though guess what we're
completely united we were able to gather
over a 100 signatures in less than two
days plus the signatures of all 17
members of the nhpa board of directors
all of these signatures are attached to
the written testimony that I've
submitted to you
today we also actually fully support
efficiency and productive changes for
example last year we supported HB 650 5
that streamlined the licensing and
renewal procedures additionally through
our lion roles to the board of
psychology we have continued to
volunteer our time to work with both the
oplc and the board of psychologists to
facilitate the smooth implementation of
these
changes HB 1408 before you today though
is a completely different story this is
not a hypothetical situation for us we
have already lived this experience those
of us who have been licensed for more
than 10 years in New Hampshire were
originally regulated through the board
of mental health practice when I moved
here 26 years ago from Ohio I was
surprised that it was Consolidated
licensing board overseeing so many
distinct mental health practices at that
time only one other state in the United
States had an Omnibus licensing board
for
psychologists oh well I thought to
myself that's just the way it's done
here but then the next thing I knew my
professional liability insurance
premiums doubled from what I was paying
to practice in
Ohio I'm the same psychologist well
trained ethical and with a good
professional reputation all I did was
move from Ohio to New Hampshire I was
soon informed that New Hampshire was one
of the most dangerous states to practice
psychology because the odds of having a
licensing board complaint filed against
you were very high no matter how it
could do work I was like what so what do
competent professionals do in this
situation well it turned out that many
psychologists simply avoided practicing
in in New Hampshire others moved their
practices to Vermont Maine um
Massachusetts rede Island Connecticut
but not New Hampshire those who remained
in New Hampshire limited the number of
complex cases they accepted this meant
that New Hampshire had severe shortage
of psychologists long before covid and
many New Hampshire residents with the
greatest need for Psychological Services
were unable to access access
treatment with a lot of hard work the
New Hampshire Board of psychologists was
established on July 1st
2013 and as you noted it's been about 10
years and it has been working well and
it continues to improve we do not want
to go backwards we oppose consolidating
the licensing boards it's all already
been demonstrated that a Consolidated
licensing board decreases efficiency
decreases consistency and impairs Public
Safety as you've already heard HB 1408
proposes to create a board of only six
professional me members and only one of
those will be a psychologist I won't add
any more numbers to your minds
there there is a saying less is more and
absolutely that can be true for example
reducing clutter can make more more
space and it gives you sense being able
to breathe more freely and less
testimony for me today I think all of us
could agree would be a relief for all of
us myself included however in other
situations having less simply means
deprivation and hardship consolidating
the licensing boards creates added
hardship for both the psychologist
practicing in New Hampshire and the
citizens of New Hampshire trying to
access those services
and it doesn't even save money by
Statute our licensing fees must cover
the operating costs of the board of
psychologists so in conclusion we are
most sincerely and urgently asking you
to allow us to continue doing the work
that we love and not put this
unnecessary hardship on the Hampshire
psychologists nor on the patients and
the communities we serve thank you so
very
much questions oh sorry no I want to
quickly I do I'm here for questions yes
represent man py has one thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
um you said you've been practicing in
New Hampshire for over 10 years Yes
actually for Yes actually for 25 years I
just closed my practice I think about
two years ago follow question question
so within that 25e frame have you seen
your patient load inrease and the number
your Outreach
to the difference between your ability
to serve more patients under the current
structure of the
board for psychologist versus before
that the understand your question so
essentially did I notice when I switched
when 10 years ago the board of
psychologist was implemented during
those 10 years did I notice that there
that I was able to practice better and
serve more patients absolutely and
especially I I have a lot of experience
I'm considered to be good at what I do
and so I felt more free to take on the
complicated cases and the need for
mental health services in New Hampshire
continues to grow between as my
colleague pointed out the um substance
abuse crisis and covid has dramatically
increased depression anxiety so it's a
huge relief to have the board of
psychologists at my back and to feel
that I could really do what I'm trained
to do with less fear of losing my
livelihood did that answer your question
thank you very
much representative gold thank you madam
chair I just wondered I was curious when
the um boards split did you notice a
decrease in your insurance
fees sadly no the insurance fees didn't
go down but the good news is they
stopped going
up so that was a huge relief also thank
you thank you for your testimony thank
you
see I passed I hello thank you so much
Madam chairwoman and this committee it's
a pleasure and it's an honor to be able
to come and talk with you about our
concerns as Citizens and small business
providers um I've handed out a testimony
uh it's in front of you it has my name
at the top Deborah
Warner I'm going to read the big print
version so
um you you know me I've been before this
committee before um over the past 15
years I was part of the um Board of
mental health practice when it combin
was combined and um I was a member of
that board and then more recently I was
a member of the board of psychologists I
am now a regular citizen I'm speaking on
my own behalf so um psychology's
original board started about 60 years
ago or more and then it was doing very
well and it was doing so well that when
they wanted to bring in um licensing
level at for the other professions they
um asked the board of psychologists to
take them in and expand in that and it
was recomposed and you got the board of
mental health practice
in the next 15 years the board of mental
health practice was crippled in design
with inadequate professional
representation and it struggled to
regulate the professions I was there I
saw that I know that it's true um it was
so incapable in fact that lawsuits
flourished in the Supreme Court
overturning the board's faulty
decisions costing the state and the
lenes many resources now we heard today
in an earlier um bill that there's a
determination of the liability and it
was a discussion about the Supreme Court
and whether or not they're favorable
toward the composition of boards but
that was rather a little bit
hypothetical since we haven't had such a
case in New Hampshire I know we need to
be cautious of course but these were
real cases there were five that were
overturned in the Supreme Court it was
not a good thing and it was because the
board was
underrepresented it was so destructive
as you heard from Dr Oliver New
Hampshire quickly became known in those
simple 15 years as the most dangerous
state in which to practice
psychology so professionals avoided New
Hampshire and this is not the fault of
the professions on the board but the
design of the board itself with such
minimal representation that it could not
appropriately judge the competence of
the diverse
professions it was like having a
professional ball game with a football
halfback a Soccer forward a hockey
goalie and it was an impossible task
even for top
players bringing drug and alcohol
counselors into this um composite board
would be into the same trap would simply
multiply the inevitable
ruination um for the professions it's
extremely and drastically ill advised
the psychology board has taken on the
school psychologist in the past several
years and it was certainly a leap to
have to St span those two professions
because the the um federal regulations
that they were dealing with were
somewhat opposite Hippa and furpa are
rather opposite to each other and it
really turns your decision-making upside
down when you're trying to deal with
cases and Professional Standards in that
regard it is extremely and drastically
ill advised advised
um the data from the proposed experiment
of this bill is evident and proven we
already know what happens so under the
old Board of mental health practice
insurance rates were uprated in fact
they have come down in fact I I did
change to
a most of the profession had had shifted
as well by then our shers even supplied
testimony to the committee that it was a
dangerous state to practice in this
committee wisely restored the psychology
board that had already been in place for
50 years it codified reforms for both
boards since then the psychology board
has functioned well I can attest to that
having been on that the BMP has also
grown meanwhile and it functions well
and it has thrived
the professions deserve well-functioning
boards that have
today there is no cost savings as you're
aware the board fees are
125% of the operating costs to run the
board we will not save any money it it
doesn't work that way I think that the
point of having these boards and this
regulation is to make sure that the
public gets the best care possible and
that the boards are able to adjudicate
and see cases of um discipline in a
proper manner that will make sure that
there's a quality of care out
there this also this proposed joining
merger of these boards is destructive to
the New Hampshire advantage that here we
have a great state we have wonderful
freedom and we also have the ability to
have professionals and small business
people work well independent
we need to expand and not shrink our
pool of
providers I ask you to remove sections
of the bill that pertain to this merger
that's sections 5 through
25 besides the DraStic and destructive
proposed board design a number of
portions in this bill are missing
important pieces that are currently in
statute and if you look at my bulleted
points you can see which ones those are
under purpose missing in the purpose of
the statute is aspects of quality care
and protecting the public those are
missing in the purpose of
Licensing in uh section
a21 um 330a 21 the license is missing
examination by the board which would
include jurus Prudence exam that was
recently developed and other
interviewing of candidates who are
borderline in their um
qualifications due to certain glitches
in the system currently it's possible to
interview such people people and see
whether or not they substantially meet
the qualifications and should be granted
a license that's omitted from this
criminal records check fails to include
the Board review of candidates who are
flagged qualitative review is needed for
fairness sometimes somebody can get
flagged for something that should not
interfere with their ability to get a
license and that should be reviewed by
the board Who would
know HP 1408 in entirely admits 29 if
329 B16 the telip pass automatic rapid
license that can be obtained instantly
in order to do tath tele medicine in New
Hampshire uh it is was recently
developed and this committee did pass
that several years ago it removes um 329
B17 criminal consequences of practicing
without a license 1408 has mere
administrative fines instead of Class A
misdemeanor or felony consequences it
also removes the capacity for the board
to request the AG to commence action it
removes 329 b19 citizens right to have
civil claims for damages suffered by
reason of violations by an
impostor for the sake of those who need
the services of these 18 professions
affected by this bill professions who
are currently well regulated ated by the
boards for the sake of keeping the New
Hampshire Advantage for a great place
for all of our citizens to work heal
live and Thrive please remove sections 5
you thank you
Wagner
so just to confirm we've moved on to HB
1408 yes sir we opened the hearing at
1:15 very
good so good afternoon and thank you for
hearing me my name is Adam Wagner the
found founder and partner of Market
Square Architects and the current chair
of the New Hampshire Board of Architects
I have been a licensed architect since
2006 and licensed here in New Hampshire
since
2008 in July of 2019 I was appointed to
the board of Architects and recently
took over the role as the chair ever
after having previously served as the
vice chair the composition of the board
of Architects consists of four licensed
professionals and one public member
currently the four licensed architect
positions are filled and the one public
member position is
vacant we meet by monthly for about an
hour including both our public and
private
sessions the primary responsibility of
the board is to adjudicate the rules of
professional conduct of the profession
and I'm here today to speak in
opposition to the proposed legislation
to merge the board of Architects with
the board of Landscape
Architects we have a tremendous amount
of respect for the landscape architect
profession and fully support their lure
requirements and representation of their
profession but the profession of
architect and landscape architect are
not as similar as the titles May
indicate before coming today I read the
board descriptions of both boards on the
oplc website both list that the boards
are responsible to develop and maintain
the ethical professional and educational
requirements for licensed
professionals the distinct difference
however is that the board of Architects
description goes on to State the
following to safeguard the state citizen
from construction or building hazards
such as fire structural failure and
unsanitary
conditions this standard of care is
significant in the role that Architects
are responsible for providing to New
Hampshire citizens which Landscape
Architects are
not we strongly feel that if an
architect is questioned for not
upholding the standards of the
profession then they should be judged by
a panel of their peers for any
profession that deals with Public Safety
this should be the
expectation our current board
composition of five members including
four licensed Architects assures that
even with a minimum Quorum the majority
of those determining a ruling will be
licensed
Architects this is a fair representation
for a profession that is highly
regulated and critical to ensure Public
Safety should the boards be joined as
this bill proposes there would be two
architects two landscape Architects and
one public
member as the landscape architect
members are not fully versed in the
Professional Care that Architects need
to provide they would essentially be
public members for matters pertaining to
architects now depending on who was able
to to attend a given meeting a merged
board could reach a quorum and make a
decision on the practice of a licensed
architect without an architect
present that is a dangerous situation
and does not serve the people of New
Hampshire furthermore there are
currently
1,913 licensed architects in the state
of New Hampshire by comparison there are
135 licensed Landscape Architects that
is a ratio of 14 to1 which is not an
equitable
representation uh of the of the proposed
makeup of a merged
board given the aforementioned standards
that Architects are required to provide
in support of public health and safety
we are opposed to this merger and
request that the board of Architects be
left to regul regulate this critical
profession as currently provided thank
you thank you are there any
questions not seeing any thank you very
Ley thank you madam shair
members of the committee my name is
Gordon Ley and I am a landscape
architect I live in Amherst uh and I
serve as the chairman of the board of
Landscape
Architects uh while our preferred
outcome would be no change to uh to the
current situation and to remain as an
independent board as a board we're
neither for nor against the combination
of these
boards um as long as both professions
are adequately
represented uh it is the desire of if it
is the desire of the legislature to
combine our boards we commit to working
with anyone who has concerns about the
details of the arrangements to achieve
an equitable and workable
result uh and with that I would
entertain any questions you might have
thank you very much thank you very much
for your testimony are there questions
representative Brown uh thank you madam
chair so following up on and thanks for
taking my question following up on the
previous
testimony the statement seemed fairly
legitimate whether it's your profession
or others there could be a circumstance
if these boards are combined where no
one in a hearing has the expertise in
the issue at hand for the person being
brought to the board do you see do you
agree that that could happen I agree
that that could happen okay yes thank
you and and also just to that would be
bad
I I think that we can rely on the
Judgment of the professionals on the
board not to let themselves get into
that kind of bad situation right so I I
at least I hope we'd be able
to any other
questions seeing none thank you very
NS
good afternoon chairwoman Maguire and
committee members thank you for taking
the time and letting giving me the
opportunity to speak on behalf of the
New Hampshire chapter of the American
Society of Landscape Architects my name
is Randy nolles and I am the current New
Hampshire chapter trustee our chapter is
currently neutral on House Bill 1408 our
profession is not opposed to emerging
and combining boards we agree that if
regulated under multi multidisciplinary
board landscape architecture should be
regulated along with an Allied design
profession making architecture a
judicious
Choice as a l as Landscape Architects
regularly work with other design
professionals it's common to see
Landscape Architects regulated with
Architects and Engineers addition
additionally these technically based
professions share the foundation of
Education experience and examination as
the standard for
licensure um jointly regulating
Landscape Architects and Architects is
fairly common Nationwide in fact 24
States nearly have jointly regulate
Architects and Landscape Architects
under one
board we we our chapter recognizes
there's a national Trend focusing on
licensing efficiency combining boards
and sorry restructuring licensing
departments regulating professions with
similar licensing structures and
commonalities in practice is therefore
or common when done correctly a
multi-disciplinary board can be an
efficient licensing entity benefiting
lenses and the citizens of New Hampshire
while continuing to protect the public
and environments throughout the state
again thank you for your time thank you
are there
questions represent
BR thank you have you um reviewed the
recommended changes to the
board on in this Bill yes at the five
member board with with two architects
and two Landscape Architects and one
public member yes um yeah we would be
fine with that we're actually neutral on
the bill but we would oppose any any
makeup that would limit us to one member
on up any board
makeup thank you and we do understand um
the architect's um concerns regarding um
representation of The Architects
themselves thank you
Michael
McKeon thank you madam chair and Edna
committee members U Michael McKuen I'm a
partner at Dennis Meers The Architects
uh who serve served architecture um in
the state for 43 years um I've practiced
for 20 plus years in the state of New
Hampshire um proud uh resident of New
Hampshire I'm currently the vice chair
of the oplc board of Architects
representing the board um and also chair
of the American Institute of new ham uh
American Institute of Architects New
Hampshire chapter legislative advocacy
committee I'm also a director on the a
AIA New Hampshire Board of Architects
and are representing that board as well
thank you greatly for hearing my
testimony in opposition to House Bill
1408 um as you've heard it looks to
merge the licensure board of Architects
with the lure Board of Landscape
Architects it also looks to combine
experience eligibility and rul making
processes of both boards into a single
board um while we have as as Adam had
mentioned tremendous respect for the
board of Landscape Architects and their
current lure requirements um we feel
that the combination of these two boards
would be a detriment to the practice of
architecture lure in the
state um I remember back in in schooling
I had a I had a mentor who was a PhD in
architecture and he said there are three
professions in our country where um you
can actually kill people uh lawyers
doctors and Architects um and it brought
to light what the responsibility of
Architecture is in the state um it's the
health life safety and Welfare of of the
public in in any setting within a
building or or space that an architect
has
designed um because of this large
responsibility there are strict very
strict educational experience and El
eligibility requirements for lure in the
practice of architecture within the
state educational requirements are are
of Landscape Architects are much less
and cover limit limited areas of
expertise in comparison to the general
practice of architecture in the
state um which um the practice of
architecture within the state covers the
construction of entire buildings spaces
um outdoor areas and uh Landscape
Architects are limited generally to um
uh site and civil related um areas
Architects are also charged with
oversight of land landscape architect
structural mechanical electrical and
Plum plumbing and Fire Protection
designs within um the practice of our
profession as Architects we're the
keeper of all these trades and each of
the trades has educational experience
limited to their trade only I.E a
landscape architect does not manage the
design of a plumbing engineer per se but
uh an architect is charged with that
responsibility similarly AR ARS have the
critical obligation to have oversight
over all facets of construction as well
landcape Architects are not involved in
the construction of a building past
landscape and site
design which is um an an
astute Factor Architects are also
charged with an in-depth extensive
knowledge of the uh entire building code
again as a life safety
issue travel distances occupancy load
exits uh all how to get people out of a
building if there's an issue a fire um
or a problem with the building uh
unfortunately Landscape Architects do
not have this knowledge or experience in
these areas of the
building design or the building
code our as Adam mentioned our office uh
adjudicates disciplinary actions when
necessary on those not abiding by the
laws that keep the public safe within
our profession and the The Lure of
architecture Landscape Architects are
not qualified to speak on the details
surrounding these matters due to the
previously mentioned lack of core code
knowledge generally speaking merging of
various boards may offer benefits to
each board in the state of New Hampshire
depending on the board um but
unfortunately not in this
case our board is composed as Adam
mentioned four um tenure
plus tenured Architects with an open
public me member and there is an
opportunity to not have architectural
representation in the current proposed
dangerous also throughout the state
Architects commonly hire Landscape
Architects as a sub trade on projects
which o opens a huge door to conflict of
interest within the proposed merger of
these
bills as Adam mentioned there's roughly
1900 um practicing Architects within the
state and only 135 practicing Landscape
Architects so you could understand that
many of us as Architects have hired The
Limited pool of very talented Landscape
Architects within the
state for those that we've hired to
adjudicate disciplinary action
um open-ended legal
issue as you can see that there's a good
deal to consider with this bill in our
board request that it is dismissed for
the previous reasons it has the
potential to dilute the requirements to
the practice of architecture within the
state which could harm the Public's
right to life safety and
Welfare it's a liability that the state
representation should not and need not
take on when people say is concerned our
boards work very very well and we'd like
the opportunity to continue to do
so thank you thank
you
Simon thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question um during your
testimony you intimated that you have a
concern that um Landscape Architects do
not have the knowledge base necessary to
um understand the complexities of
architecture in general um is the
reverse also true or do you feel like
architects are qualified to speak on
into the topic of landscape architecture
we do we are required to have a
knowledge base there um it's cursory
it's certainly not the knowledge base
that they have within their profession
um I can't really say with uh
definitively if we would have the
experience I would think that we can
speak to some of the items that might
come up during those meetings but uh but
the opposite is is more the concern
Schmidt you madam chair so your last
name has many spellings could you spell
your name or it's uh Michael
WN okay other
questions thank you Yes representa Man
py Madam chair um thank you for taking
my question
do you see this kind of combined
states thank you for your question uh as
previously mentioned there are states
that do have a combined board uh
generally speaking um which addresses
the questions previously asked the board
is is much larger in order to have
Equitable representation but um we're
only aware of seven states that have a
combined board and we're not aware of
particularly a trend in this direction
because it does dilute the life safety
aspects of the profession of
architecture thank
you and as an engineer I think your
professor omitted at least one
profession yeah I'm sure thank you madam
Das from the forest land owners
Davis
last good afternoon Madam chairman and
members of this esteem committee my name
is an Davis I'm a forest land
owner uh and my husband and I were the
New Hampshire tree farmers of the year
in
2022 uh we work with
Foresters in every step of the
management of our 500 Acre Wood
lot uh I am also a member of the board
of
Foresters and in that role um I have
worked since May May of
2015 uh helping to review the
applications of Foresters I am currently
one of two Forest land owners who work
on that uh
board there are four
Foresters and I believe that as a land
owner I bring a perspective to the board
from a consumer standpoint and it's a
very important one and provides consumer
protection because of that I oppose the
portion of House Bill 1408 that would
eliminate the two landowner
Representatives on this board now I'm
not looking for more volunteer work I'm
pretty involved in my home community and
uh in various and Sury other State uh
boards and commissions but I feel very
strongly that this is an important
Public
Service uh the landowner members of this
board take the time to carefully review
the applications we have the time to do
that I don't know whether the Foresters
read all the materials that come with
applications but the applications
require uh
significant uh materials including
management plans
sometimes the application Pages uh total
more than 100 and it often takes me more
than two hours to review one
application I think this is an important
Public Service uh there are people
willing to do this work uh to my
knowledge the board has never had
trouble finding landowner
Representatives we work well with the
Foresters in fact the board is a
pleasure to work with because it's
efficient um and we enjoy working with
the folks at the oplc they are also very
fine
professionals
so I urge you this committee to vote no
on this aspect of the bill if anything
the board would be better served if
there were three land owners because of
the perspective that we bring uh to the
table than thank you for your time and
allowing me to testify and thank you
also for all of you for your service to
those of us who live here in New
testimony all right is anyone else wish
to speak on House Bill 1408 yes repres
director
Courtney
thank you madam chair I'm sorry I was
tardy and getting my pink slip in um
Lindsey Courtney executive director
office of professional LIC certification
the office is not taking a bill on or a
position on this bill but I did um want
to make myself available to answer any
questions that you may have I think the
bill is prettyy clear it would propose
merger of Architects with Landscape
Architects as you may recall last year
in hb2 uh the bill proposed to eliminate
lure for Landscape Architects there was
conversation that happened at the
committee level um and at the hearings
about potential mergers and essentially
I believe that's the result or this bill
is the result of those
conversations um again we take no
petition on that in terms of uh the
merger the board of mental health
practice psychology Board of Licensing
for alcohol and drug use professionals
the only comments that I would say is I
think that the circumstances that were
described prior to
2013 was a very different scenario than
what you see now um in particular the
office didn't exist at all um the boards
had their own staff um they operated
completely
independently and I really just don't
accept uh as a General proposition that
these uh groups can't collaborate and
get along um and be successful because
I've personally witnessed uh
Professionals in various disciplines on
many different licensing boards be able
to collaborate and work together and
learn from each other um in the course
of uh pursuing um you know occupation
regulation that's um appropriate and
forward thinking so I I would just keep
that in mind that 2013 is not 20
24 um with respect to the other changes
essentially there were changes that were
proposed last year mainly intended to
make um changes to the composition of
the boards um if you recall we've had a
lot of conversation about quum issues in
particular public members and I know
that representative lakas had put
something in your bulletin so if you
know anybody um interested and serving
that would be great but um essentially
what was proposed last year and what's
currently proposed is a reduction of the
overall size with the goal of reducing
the number of public members because
that appears to be impacting cor more
frequently um with that I'd be happy to
answer any questions again I just wanted
to make myself
available thank you represent Simon and
then gold thank you madam chair um just
a quick question on the board of
Architects is the public member is that
there by Statute or is that negotiable
they're there by Statute correct by
Statute okay thank you gold Shar and
thank you for taking my question it's
maybe somewhat related my question is
regarding advisory
boards if there's a statutory layout of
who's required by Statute to be on the
board is there anything preventing
adding other members is there anything
that would stop your office or The
Advisory Board from having other people
sit with them regularly that are in the
field to assist
so yes certainly so we uh boards can
work and they often do with different
stakeholders provided it's in public
session but once you cross over into
matters that are considered confidential
obviously you have to exclude everybody
who's anybody who's not staff or not on
the public body so that would be the um
that would be the challenge we we do
have a couple of boards um and actually
um alcohol and drug use counselors they
have this in their statute I think
mental health practice does as well
um where they have authorized
subcommittees um that can perform work
and certain boards Board of Nursing has
the ability to appoint people to those
subcommittees so that is another way
that boards have um gathered expertise
from other professions um an issue came
up during testimony about people opining
or passing judgment adjudicating cases
to which there's no professional member
there and I'll give you an example um
Board of Nursing the legislature
recently added an additional APRN member
that has yet to be filled they currently
have a 13-member board with only one
APRN and they have about 3,500 aprns a
lot of their cases concern aprns they as
a matter of practice do not adjudicate
cases if the APRN member is there
because they understand that they would
like that person's expertise so I think
board's a really good at self-regulating
that issue um and I would fully
anticipate um that regardless of the
compens of the board that all of our
professionals on these boards would
continue to do
that thank you
representative thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question I'm
going to go to a section that really
hasn't been talked about yet in the bill
page
pharmacists
yes in reducing the number of
Pharmacists uh
so four practicing members
why was it chosen to make two from
pharmacists two Pharmacists and two
shall be full-time Hospital
pharmacists because the ratio of the
number of Pharmacists in the state to
the number of ratio of Pharmacists who
work for hospitals doesn't seem like
it's
5050 and why is that at 2 and two yes so
I can't speak to the um the intent there
I can say that I might make a suggestion
that you remove this part of that bill
um from remove this part from the bill
and the reason is this there were many
changes last year to the pharmacy
Statute in terms of composition at one
point I think in hb2 um hb2 included the
language that would change it to seven
members and then 409 changed it back to
five members and then there may have
been it was it was kind of a mess um
legally that we had to figure out who
was on the board um so the J as settled
I may suggest not making any changes
there but um there there was a a a
consensus among I think hospitals in
particular that there needed to be
because the practice of Pharmacy in a
hospital is different than the practice
of Pharmacy in a retail environment that
they needed greater representation uh
the
conversation regarding adding an
additional Hospital pharmacist um
centered around uh or was in the context
of the board continuing to exist at
seven members that probably doesn't
answer your question but in a nutshell
you may not want to make any changes
there because there was this um there
were these changes last year followup
just one other followup regarding that
section because when we talk about
boards usually the head of the board's
the chair of the board why is this being
a president of the board it has always
existed that way and certain boards are
called are considered commissions and
they refer to themselves as
Commissioners it's just whatever the
statute says I think uh medicine has uh
a president as
well that's the only other one that
comes to
mind
history because we've always done it
that way which is never the right answer
but that's that's why and just one of
the quick if I may while we're on this
page if you go up to line 11 sure Roman
numeral seven it says repealed the
stricken after
seven is that a
typo yeah what goes back in there
there's nothing there replacing it yeah
that would appear I mean just a glancing
at it without looking at the current
statute I would agree with you it would
appear to be a
typo because typically you would
actually strike
language I just want to see if you if I
was seeing something wrong or not no I I
there thank you for your
time does anyone else wish to testify on
House Bill
1408 all right I'll close the public
hearing this bill is going to
subcommittee and for the committee I'd
like to mention that tomorrow after
session provided it doesn't run too late
I'm going to call for an executive
session
on two four five bills two of them are
the time changes two others have have
come from subcommittee with this with
simple recommendations I think we'll
agree with um so be prepared to stick
around and where will we meet was that
where will that me meeting be here I
believe okay thank
you
so yes sir I will let I will announce
when and where
and we should open the hearing on the
next
bill
okay with that I would like to open up
the public hearing on HB 1285 and
welcome representative Maguire to
Bill thank you I'm Carol Maguire
representing marac District
27 and House
Bill
was is one of the sections that after
examination by representative groa and
myself we pulled out of House Bill 2
last year it started Ed as the
governor's recommendation to combine
these
boards we just we thought it needed
separate attention as not being included
in house bill to so here it is
back uh it merges the board of
podiatrists which is another one of the
relatively small boards into the Board
of
Medicine
and someone from the opl will be able to
details thank you very much any
testimony sorry I'm having a hard time
nhp I may have butchered it that's why I
said I
apologize can yeah it could be y m that
looks
[Music]
words I do have some uh written uh
material to sub you can hand it right
the right oh yes uh my my name is on the
uh on the document there's I think seven
or eight copies I'm not sure there's
around uh thank you uh chairwoman
Maguire and the uh
uh members of the committee of the New
Hampshire house executive departments
and administration uh for granting me an
opportunity to speak on House Bill 1285
which proposes to merge the currently
separate State Board of Podiatry with
the State Board of
Medicine my name is Dr William mccan and
I've been a practicing podiatric
physician in New Hampshire for the last
years I serve as immediate p president
of the New Hampshire podiatric Medical
Association and I'm speaking today as a
concerned resident of New Hampshire and
as a practicing podiatric physician in
the granite
state I'm in opposition to the proposal
relative to merging the board of
Podiatry into the Board of
Medicine the currently separate Board of
Medicine needs a full day every month to
manage the concerns and complaints of
the lenes under its
regulation versus the Board of Podiatry
which only requires a halfday meeting
every quarter merging the boards will
simply increase the workload of the
Board of
Medicine additionally for those who
serve on the board of Podiatry the
meeting frequency would increase from
four halfday meetings a year to 12
meetings that consume at least a full
day for a podiatric physician volunteer
an essentially unpaid role this is a
significant increase in the time
required which will be a deterrent for
future volunteers who might consider
serving caring for patients requires
significant focus and energy and such a
Time increase would be difficult to
manage at
best doctors of podiatric medicine also
called podiatric Physicians play a
critical role for caring for some of the
sickest
patients a recent American Diabetes
Association 2021 report place the
estimate of New Hampshire patients with
diabetes at
10.1% or over
113,000 people with an estimated
additional 29,000 residents who don't
realize they have diabetes or are
undiagnosed at this
time amputations and infections in the
lower extremity are two of the biggest
complications for these patients and
role a Frontline role in and caring for
these
conditions this is the case in our group
practice here in conquer and in Meredith
where we have many patients who Express
their gratitude for the significant time
and attention given to salvage their
lower Limbs and provide them with the
continued ability to walk and live a
normal life
again during a podiatric physician's
Education and Training there is a
significant and early focus on lower
extremity care including the structures
of the foot and ankle
as a result the issues that a board of
Podiatry May face are significantly
different and more specific from what a
face a separate Board of Podiatry also
ensures that podiatric Physicians are
not unduly restricted or disciplined by
a Board of Medicine with members who may
have outdated views or limited
understanding of the specialty of
Podiatry this further indicates an
elevated need for the board of pediatry
to continue to exist in its separate
autonomous form and ensure that patients
are getting the highest level of foot
and ankle care from podiatric Physicians
practicing in New
Hampshire thank you again for the
opportunity to comment on the proposed
House Bill
1285 and thank you members of the
committee for your service to the
citizens of New
Hampshire thank you very much for your
testimony will you take questions uh yes
Mr chairman excuse me doctor so is there
a difference between a podiatric
physician and a
podiatrist no it's one and the
same you're welcome represent man py
thank you Mr chair thank you for talk to
this
way I'm sorry I know you were looking
the other way um my question is as a
podiatrist um you do go to the senior
centers and also nursing homes and
Senior Living Facilities is that not
true other than the primary care
pH geriatric as well as podiatric both
go to these Senior Living
places yes that is true and that is
correct um it depends on each
podiatrist's individual practice some
podiatrists are very much office and
Hospital based and don't go to uh to uh
nursing homes or uh long-term care
facilities um although many pediatrist
do go to long-term care facilities and
nursing homes uh and have combined
practices that does that do both and
some even specifically just go to
nursing home
facilities follow up thank you my
follow-up question is as New Hampshire
is aging population
and the need for jedric as well as
podiatric uh Services needed is
increasing would that be impacted by
combining the
boards would that I'm sorry would what
the last thing was would that be would
that need increased need be impacted by
boards you know I I don't think that
would however I I probably should
research that question a little bit more
it's an excellent question and I'm not
exactly sure of the answer to that
question um and perhaps some of my
colleagues to follow could could even uh
expand on that or answer it better than
I um but uh I would certainly uh like
the opportunity to answer that question
after some more research and maybe get
some get get your information in order
to make sure that I do you can send an
you any other questions seeing none
thank you so much for your testimony
thank you very much for allowing me to
uh
bondar
little back things so pardon me um I'm
Dr Billy bondar I'm out of Rochester New
Hampshire I've practiced 31
years uh over there solo practice and
I'm here for uh Bill
1285 as an opposing
voice um interesting enough I haven't
been here for years to speak but my
cousin is a senator out in Colorado so
she told me to go for it
um no sugar coating by me I'm not going
to um do that but I just want you to
realize that Billy my given name is
willing protector so for my peers and my
patients I am certainly of that nature
I'm also a Leo but I will speak about a
little bit about my dad my dad was a um
a war to vet Battle of the Bulge North
Africa Europe served as a dental surgeon
um born and raised out of
Manchester um he was a colonel he he
took over so many different
organizations and and things out in
Michigan where I was raised um knew a
whole bunch of legislators so growing up
in and watching him with this and the VA
system I saw what a specialty in health
care is about and what you have to do to
provide your your group um an entity of
of of strong people and and getting what
is needed for those particular
professional
caregivers um I chose the other end of
the the the body part um Foot and Ankle
uh I got my degree in 89 I uh I like to
describe my work as Skin to Bone um from
the knee to the tip of the toe for
children to Elders I think my oldest was
106 um um I see podiatrist as
fixers uh we are are there to get dirty
we do not have the stethoscope around
our neck we have lab coats that are
grubby by the end of the day um and with
a back problem that bending and helping
patients with shoes and all that is just
getting ridiculous but there's young
people back here
um but I want to elaborate how a medical
doctor does not remove clothing you you
go you you know what I'm talking about
the socks and shoes aren't removed your
your shirt is not removed there are
things on your body that are not
examined and the foot and the and the
lower leg is one of those that seriously
gets
missed um so that's one factor um the
other Factor being is I as a a
professional get occasionally referrals
from other Physicians be it Dermatology
orthopedic and medical practitioners and
I
get I get I don't want to say I just get
upset is I'll say it nicely because you
can have someone with a medical
degree and supposedly they should have
got some foot
education but they send you a patient
that has been diabetic for numerous
numerous years and they have a wound on
their foot that does not heal
and they have been using you know soak
that foot do this do that no no
particulars um antibiotics of course
because that's what you do um that wound
heals but then it opens anyways foot
dock gets that patient as a foot dock
it's a big puzzle to us or to me I'll
speak for myself what is this why is it
there and you you take the time to ask
questions you listen it it's timec
consuming medical docs don't have that
opportunity with hospitals and insurance
telling you what to do and So eventually
that particular patient you know what
that was for her it was a wart a veruka
we call it a simple viral lesion that
had been abused by that particular
caregiver um
incorrectly attended um I have numerous
cases being at children I have I'm I'm
really going to go for it
here Urgent Care Center child goes to
the Urgent Care with an ingrown
toenail that particular health care
provider says I'm going to take care of
you parents are there goes to the
computer they can see the person going
in there and that's the hey social media
and whatever will give you
information this person numbed up the
child's toe it took a a long long time
because they don't do it properly you're
you just do too little
anyways what happened was they removed
the nail plate which is a typical for an
ingrown they rotated the nail plate
around and place the the end that was
exposed to the outside the end of the
toe back into the flesh they reattached
that nail plate with
suture and then said there it's all good
that's how it'll stay open for a while
so it can heal and then you can go see a
podiatrist to get the sutures
out
really uh so that that was one of my
worst cases I reported that I did and I
got an apology
from the particular person and he said I
was educated at this particular school
to do that in medical school
really so yeah toe stuff is our stuff uh
some of our podiatrists do really big
stuff there stuff uh diabetic shco foot
is something that you're maybe your
mother or your sister might have it it's
a toe a foot that swells up it's it's
red it's hot not really too painful but
hey it it's not right so Dr so and so
says I think you got an infection
antibiotics weeks go by still swollen
maybe gout the emergency room says in
the end it's shco foot where the bones
are falling apart
okay that person has to be in a walking
boot or a wheelchair for almost a year
Sometimes some of them lose their foot
we know what that is we know how to
address this issue so that those hazards
and horrible situations for that person
and the family shall be
minimized um and then I'll I'll end with
my own situation I ended up
personally um I had a friend going
through pancreatic cancer which you
probably know is very short term and you
want to be with that person and anyways
I had a lesion on the back of my right
calf um I should have gone to one of my
peers but I'm a very Polkka doted person
meaning I have a lot of moles I went to
my Derm as I had for
years and she said well watch
it I was in my head to help my friend
Jess I was flying to and fro from
Seattle and I said okay okay I catch you
in six months 6 months was 12 months I
went back she was retired the next Derm
looked at it and said oh hm well
maybe I said just take a piece I had
noticed changes it was a melanoma I lost
this much of My
Flesh I've had three of those in my
wonderful lifespan so
far not there different body parts um we
as foot docks We Roll those pant legs up
and we look for these lesions and we
find these cancers so that someone else
doesn't have to go through as much
physical despair or potential loss of
life we find that stuff and it's
amazing and very rewarding and and and I
don't believe the medical doctors even
look at your legs or your back anymore I
know that mine does not so so if if they
refer to Derm do they look at the legs
no I hear that people come to my office
saying yeah I get a Derm visit all the
time but they never look at the legs we
are the Specialists we know what we're
doing I'd like to make certain that this
board is its own Unity it it's important
for the public and it's important for
for us as a profession because we know
how to do the work and we know the
regulatory legal parameters that issues
regarding foot and ankle we've done it
for the past for for decades and we can
do it for the future the education in
the medical system for the medical docs
it's it's not there for podiatric it
should be I wish it was maybe that's my
retirement goal but um thank you for
letting me speak thank you for your
testimony any
questions seeing none thank you very
much um just looking at the number of
cards that I have in front of me on this
issue uh as you come up to testify um if
you can try to emphasize uh how you feel
like the changing of the the board's
construction would uh would affect the
practice that would that would be best
um we understand that there's obviously
differences between podiatrist and
medical profession at large so um if you
could emphasize that stuff that would be
Kelly thank you
I also have a a copy here of my
testimony uh just have one copy um but
it is primarily indicated with what I'll
be reading before you guys
today good afternoon my name is Dr
Michael Kelly and I'm a practicing
podiatric surgeon in Nash New Hampshire
at St Joseph hospital and I'm a member
of the New Hampshire podiatric Medical
Association I stand before you today to
strongly oppose house bill 1285 which
proposes a merger of the board of
Podiatry with the Board of Medicine I
firmly believe that this merger poses a
serious threat to Public Safety
increases the burden on Health Care
Professionals and disregards the unique
role that podiatric Physicians play in
our health care System the claim that
merging the boards will result in cost
savings and reduced administrative
insufficiencies is a misconception the
workload disparity between the Board of
Medicine and the board of Podiatry is
substantial while the former requires a
full day every month the latter only
necessitates a half day meeting every
quarter merging the boards when
inevitability burden the Board of
Medicine leading to increased
efficiencies rather than cost
savings the proposed increased in
meeting frequency for the board of
Podiatry members from four day four half
days meetings to 12 full day meetings is
not only a significant time commitment
but also a potential deterent for future
volunteers this change could adversely
impact the availability of qualified
individuals willing to serve in a
voluntary and unpaid
role podiatric Physicians are
indispensable Frontline Health Care
Providers addressing the unique and
complex
challenges faced by patients with
diabetes the prevalence of diabetes in
New
Hampshire emphasizes the significant
responsibility podiatrist bear in
managing complications such as
amputations and infections of the lower
extremities their specialized expertise
is a Cornerstone in preserving the
overall health and well-being of the
state's
residents merging the boards with jeiz
the Specialized Care that podiatric
Physicians provide as Physicians from
other Specialties may not fully
comprehend the unique challenges faced
in podiatric care the focus on the lower
extremity care in podiatric education
sets these professionals apart in
merging the boards without adequate
representation would harm patients and
create unnecessary conflicts the
distinct nature of podiatric care
requires a dedicated regulatory body
that understands and addresses the
unique challenges faced by these
healthare
professionals a separate Board of
Podiatry is essential to ensure that
these Specialists are not unduly
restricted or penalized by a Board of
Medicine lacking in the in-depth
knowledge of podiatric Specialties the
autonomy is crucial for preserving the
high standard of foot and ankle care
that patients in New Hampshire
deserve separation ensures a more
efficient and streamlined approach to
addressing concerns specific to Podium
atric medicine without diluting the
specialized focus on the lower extremity
undermining the quality of patient care
in the
state contrary to the assumption that
merging boards is a progressive move
over two-thirds of States including our
neighboring New England states maintain
separate and autonomous Boards of
Podiatry the structure serves the public
health interest effectively and allows
for a more focused approach in
addressing concerns related to podiatric
physicians in conclusion House Bill 1285
poses a serious threat to Public Safety
and the specialized care provided by
podiatric physicians in the state of New
Hampshire the current separate Board of
Podiatry ensures the highest level of
foot and ankle care allowing these
podiatric Physicians to address the
unique challenges faced by their
patients I urge you to reconsider this
proposal and prioritize the preservation
of of patient care by maintaining the
autonomy of the board of Podiatry thank
you for your time and your consideration
thank you for your testimony do have
questions yes representative
Schmidt you're reading from a prepared
statement are you going to hand it in
yes I am thank
you any other questions singon thank you
for your
testimony and you can just hand that
over to representative man
boy uh Dave
BISS
well good afternoon I don't have any
copies but my Post-its will be available
afterwards um I have to change
glasses uh somewhat prepared um one
thing well I'm Dave bis I'm a podiatrist
um I'm originally from Chicago I've been
here since since uh 2002 uh private
practice right now up by Airport
Road um one thing I'd like to just make
clear I don't know if everyone knows but
um podiatrists have their own degree we
go to a separate school I believe right
now there's 10 uh different pediatry
schools and who knows how many MD
schools we have similar training through
most of schooling um and then we diverge
in the third and fourth years where we
do um our clinical times different with
different emphasis of course being lower
extremity so we have um depending on the
training program uh maybe a lot maybe a
little uh
interaction with MDS on a regular basis
um and I think uh part of what that
speaks to is the familiarity between a
lot of say an MD or a do and podiatrists
we have uh I'm what you'd call I think a
a regular community pediatrist I perform
uh a lot of different services for
people uh such as in day-to-day practice
I do everything I cut toenails I trim
calluses I take care of ulcers as
mentioned we do wound care I do a lot of
different minor in office procedures and
uh hospital-based uh surgery I mold for
and have made in dispensed leg and foot
braces uh podiatrists perform uh in
office Diagnostics ultrasounds and
x-rays and we interpret them ourselves
kind of like a dentist uh we don't have
to have them
overread and um some of that
requires uh even the simple things such
as trimming callous and uh cutting Nails
requires um sort of our own set of
instruments and a way to prepare them uh
basically sterilize them keep them clean
how we how we take care of them uh what
we do on a day-to-day basis
um it's not that familiar with what a
lot of other doctors um perceive of us
basically there is um a large difference
in what we do what we can do and the
familiarity with a lot of MDS uh with
that um and so it's it's my opinion that
the practice of podiatric medicine
requires its own board um to evaluate
complaints and look after the safety
concerns of patients uh and the public
um was on the board of pediatry for five
years I guess it ended uh six years ago
um and with the complaints and things
that came through um I can just tell
that the the way that we perceive things
um and it's just it's a little bit
different we perform we're allopathic
Physicians just like um an MD is um but
the way we approach patients uh and
especially the breadth of treatments
available uh performing routine care
such as Nails minor in-office procedures
hospital-based
surgery and the Diagnostics it's just
it's it's wide ranging and it's a bit
more wide ranging than I think most
Medical Specialties
are and it's just my opinion that it
requires its own board to look after
those
things
thank you thank you for your testimony
uh will you take questions of course any
questions from the committee yes
representative
Schmid give me another try at your name
Dave bis b i
SS that means bite in German which you
probably know or
until oh that two
s's set yes that's two s's correct I
stand you're talking to a professor of
talking thank you so much for your time
appreciate you're very welcome thank
Christie um thank you uh my name is Dr
Reed Christie uh I'm a practicing
podiatric physician here in New
Hampshire and I'm speaking today as the
president of the New Hampshire podiatric
Medical
Association uh the New Hampshire
podiatric Medical Association is the
largest uh podiatric medical
organization representing podiatric
physicians in New Hampshire and we also
Advocate on behalf of all licensed
podiatrists also known as DPMS or
doctors of podiatric
medicine um thank you for the
opportunity today to provide commentary
on uh
1285 which proposes to merge the
currently separate State uh Board of
Podiatry with the Board of
Medicine uh the New Hampshire podiatric
Medical Association wishes to express
its strong and unequivocal opposition to
this proposal while we commend uh
chairwoman Maguire for her efforts to
identify opportunities and improve
administrative efficiency and lower
costs uh we do not believe that this
change will accomplish that goal the
Board of
Medicine uh regulates all allopathic and
osteopathic Physicians as well as
physician assistants under its Authority
and takes a full day of meetings every
month to manage administrative uh
processes concerns and complaints for
those
professionals to this point from 2020 to
2023 the Board of Medicine has held uh
disciplinary hearings and made decisions
on 14 individuals per year on average
average uh in contrast the board of
Podiatry meets every quarter for a half
day and has taken disciplinary action
against one podiatric physician in the
past seven
years uh adding oversight and regulation
of podiatric Physicians to the Board of
Medicine will not lessen the amount of
time needed to process and function
effectively additionally for the
essentially unpaid volunteers who serve
in these roles uh this would be a
significant increase in time required to
participate and be a deterrent to Future
members
serving furthermore the inefficiencies
may be compounded by having allopathic
and osteopathic Specialties evaluating
podiatric Physicians with which they
have no practical
familiarity uh podiatrists MDS and dos
share some of the same underlying
training education uh four years of
undergraduate education four years of
medical education and three years or at
least three years of residency however
podiatrists receive a significantly more
focused uh education on lower extremity
care with emphasis of the Foot and Ankle
a separate Board of Podiatry helps to
signal to the public that podiatric
Physicians practicing in the state of
New Hampshire are appropriately and
efficiently evaluated for licensing and
are
monitored this leads New Hampshire
podiatric Medical Association to its
secondary and arguably more important
concern patient safety and continued
access to the best foot and ankle care
available New Hampshire podiatric
Medical Association does not believe
that merging the board of Podiatry with
the Board of Medicine will serve
patients in New Hampshire the ongoing
duties of the New Hampshire Board of
Podiatry go far beyond the licensing and
ongoing registration of podiatric
Physicians it goes beyond the advocacy
of the podiatric profession it goes
beyond the scope of practice
determinations the board of Podiatry
determines podiatric physicians's
ability to practice lower extremity
medicine and surgery and determines what
actions warrant suspension or revocation
of a license to practice podiatric
medicine the separate Board of Podiatry
safeguards the public by identifying and
disciplining those podiatrists who
engage in unprofessional improper or
incompetent uh podiatric practice at the
heart of how it safeguards the public is
by directly reviewing the ongoing Contin
uh continuing medical education
compliance each and every uh licensed
podiatric physician versus selecting a
small sample of licensed Physicians to
review this is how the separate and
auton autonomous Board of Podiatry keeps
the public
safe last the New Hampshire podiatric
Medical Association stresses that New
Hampshire would be in the minority of
Professional Licensing boards structure
if it were to adopt the proposed
amendment to consolidate the boards
under the Board of Medicine
um more than two-thirds of the states
maintain a separate Board of Licensing
and regulation for podiatric Physicians
because these states recognize that it
serves Public Health interests to do so
in the New England region alone Maine
Massachusetts Rhode Island Connecticut
and New York are all separate boards
adopting this amendment and ending New
Hampshire's uh Board of Podiatry
autonomy by consolidating the boards it
would be a disservice to the patients in
New Hampshire once again on behalf of
New Hampshire podiatric Medical
Association and the state's expert foot
in ankle care uh and Physicians we thank
you for the opportunity to provide
feedback on the proposed Bill thank you
for your testimony will you take
questions sure any questions represent
manager P thank you Ma Mr chair thank
you for taking my question the question
I asked to your previous colleague who
um there's the need in as the state
population aging population increase is
there a need
in increased need for podiatrist because
that exclusive that population needs
more of that care sure there could be a
increase need for pitous um I think
that's what you're getting at yes
yep to clarify um since you're the board
president right now or chair for uh I'm
not the board of di um Dr surri is here
yes um were you asking the same question
as you had previously asked about how
would this affect the correct um I
believe if you're making the argument of
an increased need for pediatry in the
state I think it would be affected by if
if you're merging the two boards
together it potentially could take
longer to have if you're needing new
pediatrist in the state that process of
getting new podiatrist license could be
become longer if you roll these two
boards
together so any other questions saying
testimony sorry I probably won't get
this last name right I can't quite read
samre
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak about HB 1285 I am Dr Jennifer
saror and I've have been practicing in
New Hampshire for 22 years while I
currently serve on the board of Podiatry
as the chair I must state that I am not
providing the position of the board at
this time the board was unable to meet
in a timely manner to provide a formal
opinion on HB 1285 so I am here as a
citizen and a practicing podiatrist and
I am in opposition to hb1
1285 I'm sure this bill is
well-intentioned and I'm sure um it's
trying to streamline operations and
costs
But like everyone else that has
testified before me I think they um have
stated it pretty well it it has serious
consequences from potentially limiting
licenses um taking a long time to get
podiatrist licensed um maybe not holding
them as accountable as they should be
because the rules of the Podiatry board
are not known to the Board of Medicine
um I'm not even sure how those two are
going to be combined we have separate
exams that we take that are different
from medicine MDS
dos um the rules are extensive I'm sure
on the board of medicine and as well as
on the board of Podiatry so Podiatry is
definitely a specialized field you've
heard from others today on what that is
I'm not going to go into that um I think
the merging of the two boards would
result in a loss of focus on the
specific needs and issues facing the
podiatrists in the communities of New
Hampshire we Face unique challenges and
we have concerns that are distinct from
the other Medical
Specialties um and I think we really
need a dedicated board for Podiatry I
was opposed to this merger previously
um and I'm opposed to it again and um I
think you're going to see um that it's
going to be impossible to merge the two
boards and consistently have
um people being able to get their
license being held accountable for any
kind of discipline and then um just
process and I really urge you you to
really reconsider this bill and not
merge the two boards together I also
worry about restriction of trade um with
the merger of the two boards and I worry
about lawsuits coming up
um the boards don't have
immunity they can still be sued and if
you have someone disciplining without
the same license without the same
initials behind their name I just worry
that that opens up trouble so again I
hope for you to reconsider this proposal
on this bill and I appreciate you
allowing me to speak and I appreciate
everything that you do for the citizens
of New Hampshire thank you thank you any
questions seeing none thank you so much
testimony question of the community does
anybody have any questions for the
governor's
office
yeah D you're off the
hook I'll call uh director Courtney
hook thank you Mr chair members of the
committee lindsy Courtney executive
director I think the first thing that I
wanted to clarify is that this bill and
the bill that you're about to hear was
not made at the request of the office of
professional ice insur and
certification um as always we provide
technical assistance when requested but
as you know this um these were
initiatives that were contained in House
Bill 2 of last year and so we're
essentially carry over until this year
um so in any event um I really just
wanted to make myself available again to
answer questions but I would note a few
things um based on the testimony the
first is that the Board of Medicine
currently has um actually there are
three different degrees that member or
that the regulated professionals have
there's the MD the do and then of course
the physician assistant in some states
um Vermont is one of them there are
different boards that regulate whether
you have a a a do or an MD our state has
a a composite board and so I think
there's a history there of the Board of
Medicine being able to regulate multiple
different
disciplines um in an efficient orderly
fashion but also in a collaborative
fashion they're um they you know they
meet regularly they uh collaborate with
each other to make sure that they have
the requisite
expertise and when you think about who's
on the board of medicine and the
Specialties that comprise uh the
regulated Community um you've got
Orthopedics you've got OBGYNs you've got
anesthesiologists Radiologists there are
a number of Specialties that are
regulated by this one board so I I think
that regardless and again the office is
not taking a position but if the
legislature chooses to go forward with
this um composite approach I feel very
confident that there's no doubt the
Board of Medicine would be able to be
effective a couple of the um the
comments that we heard in the in the in
the stories about podiatric medicine and
the the concerns specifically about uh
Physicians or MDS Doo's treating um
ailments uh that are probably better
referred to podiatrists actually led me
to think that maybe the Board of
Medicine could benefit from having a
podiatrist on um its board and that if
under the circumstances presented by one
of the individuals testified today had
been brought to the Board of Medicine
that board wouldn't have the expertise
needed to be able to determine whether
or not that person was acting recklessly
in providing that care and that's
something that maybe the committee would
like to consider again I'm not taking a
position but it was just something that
I I noted um given the concerns that
were raised um finally there was a
comment about immunity I want to be
clear that boards do have immunity it's
under RSA 999d that's immunity under
state law for certain circumstances
essentially can't act recklessly but
then there's immunity as it relates to
antitrust under federal law and that was
the immunity issues that I was
discussing previously so um there is
immunity enjoyed by board members um but
there are parameters in order for you to
qualify but I just wanted to correct
that record I'd be Happ to answer any
questions that you may have
representative leus thank you um so some
questions that are all kind of the
similar we've had before as to potential
issues with the board so um you know is
there a concern with the board of
Podiatry with the number of people
licensed around antitrust I mean I
assume if it's a small number that's a
bigger concern so that's one so the
board of Podiatry has about a 100 lenes
and so as we we talked earlier I think
there's always a higher risk when you
have fewer licenses regulated by active
Market particip ANS there's certainly
always a a higher risk there followup
followup similarly um you know how often
are there complaints I we heard there
was one action taken but you know how
often are there complaints you don't
receive that many complaints thankfully
they did have some continuing education
issues last year um that were dealt with
with public hearings but they don't
receive that many complaints and I and I
would agree that um that certainly that
if if the s were to be merged the um the
podiatrist members on the Board of
Medicine would uh certainly have to meet
more frequently and probably longer um
because that that board Board of
Medicine has many more complaints follow
up follow up have there been any issues
with Quorum the meeting any of that sort
of usual thing we've heard before on
other boards um I can get the number to
you off the top of my head I don't think
they have a quum issue although I will
say they meet quarterly you know and
part of the challenges uh just from an
operation standpoint again I'm not
taking a position is that when boards
don't meet regularly
um from an administrative standpoint um
because they're not doing it as
frequently and there are there is a
potential need for greater resources
more training that sort of thing um it's
the same thing for boards that rarely
have any disciplinary actions so the
Board of Nursing for example as a dis
plary hearing every meeting they know
what to do they know the script they
know the dos and the don'ts they know
the legal
parameters um but if you have a a
different board let's say Board of um
reflexology they never have those cases
you know there would be a little bit
more handholding there but that that
doesn't mean that it can't be done and
we're of course happy to support the
boards whatever the makeup is based on
what the legislative intent is last
followup um this relates to how often
they they were uh they meet I mean does
the board have to meet to approve new
applications because that gets into I
mean there was some testimony that there
might be concerns that it might take
longer if they were mer merged with
medicine but if they're meeting
quarterly I would think it might
actually be more timely if they're
merged is there anything to that so I
think that t that was the case um
previously but the this body uh made
some changes with 655 in House fille 2
and in 409 last year so we are currently
reviewing applications so that's that's
no longer an issue um I would say there
are a lot of concerns regarding scope of
practice and I hear those concerns and
um I think that's something that this
body should very much consider I would
say typically the legislature and the
statutes govern scope of practice um
they don't essentially delegate it to
the boards to determine their own scope
of practice and our statutory structure
is kind of interesting in the sense that
um everything is deemed to be you know
Healthcare is deemed to be the practice
of medicine unless it's carved out and
there's an exemption and all of the
other practice acts are essentially
considered such exemptions and so the
people like uh Podiatry have to operate
within that framework um medicine is
considered the catchall so you might
argue that by merging the two there's
there's kind of Greater flexibility with
respect to that scope legally thank
grto thank you thank you um director
Courtney
um I'm concerned about the board and the
board number so right now the Board of
Medicine consists of 11 members is that
right yes followup and so you want to
merge another practice into it and
you're reducing the number by
four be clear I do not want anything I'm
not taking a position I say well someone
wrote this okay so whoever wrote this
okay what is proposed correct is a
reduction of the board yes so to me this
is where I have a
problem dead so this is I'm just telling
people that this is not acceptable if
you're if you're adding a practice to a
field you don't shrink the number you
you make room for them to have a
discussion and you don't Lop off the
other people because you want this magic
number to seven where I don't know where
the number came from and if if you if
you sense my frustration I apologize I
don't mean to give it to you but maybe
you know six hours of this or five hours
if this is enough for anyone and um I do
think that this is this is a big a big
issue in this
bill I I appreciate that and I don't
take your frustration direct at me I
what I what I would suggest is that
there are two issues there that are
presented one is as a policy matter do
you want to merge the two and if so what
should the composition look like I think
the composition was largely driven by
again the concerns regarding public
members um and being able to retain and
attract public members but I think those
are two different issues and I think you
don't even need to get to the
composition question if you decide that
you want to keep uh the status
quo thank you um
I've got one before that uh just as a
reminder to the committee members uh
that the we're asking questions during
public hearings we have an opportunity
to debate the topic with ourselves uh at
the executive meeting so um make sure
that we're keeping it in that Bane um
representative manager P thank you Mr
chair thank you director Courtney um my
concern is I don't know if you can
answer but my concern is as the demand
is increasing for this profession
instead of making it
more um how do I put it making it more
easy and streamline the process if
you're constructing and overloading and
putting it together combining it
together it defeats the purpose of
attracting new Workforce and addressing
the increase in the need for that
profession so I I don't think that the
propos changes are going to have any
impact on Workforce whatsoever I think
it's I think it's purely how the state
wants to govern um or facilitate
regulatory uh oversight of these
particular professions one thing to keep
in mind is that you know uh the
legislature made some big changes last
year in the sense that it allowed the
office to license applicants in between
meetings now the Board of Medicine had
already been doing that um I don't think
Podiatry had been doing that although I
I could stand corrected on that but and
so really the purpose of the board is to
promote and facilitate
regulation um and regulation is really
just just that it's um how do I get a
license it's ethical requirements how do
I maintain my license how do I maintain
competency and then if something happens
what does that look like so access to
care issues are certainly important and
impacted by lure but it's not at the
center of what what what is the issue
with respect to our regulations
certainly if you put too many burdens in
getting a license that could impact
access to healthcare but I don't think
that that is an issue that's that's um
changes representative
gold Mr chair and thank you for taking
my
question so this gets back to what I
asked you earlier and I'm still trying
to get my head around um the number of
people on the board and and who makes
the appointments to the board and how
much like can the statue say we're going
to be taking this to committee so I'm
trying to get from you now what we could
look at in committee so um like a range
of s to 11 or something
like can we look at a range and do you
as or does the director does opl appoint
the the people on the
board um or is it the governor's office
so most boards in these boards are uh
Governor nominated and GNC appointed uh
The Advisory boards have historically
been appointed by the director I'm not
sure why that is I think um originally
several of our advisory boards were
attached to the Department of Health and
Human Services and it was always like
that so um that's just how it is that
certainly you can make some
modifications there um I'd have to
consider that because uh board members
are public officials and in order for us
to understand what a quorum is there
needs to be a certain number and
together they comprise a public body um
so I'll give some thought to that prior
to the next uh to the subcommittee
meeting but I would say you probably
need need to set forth in statute how
many people serve on that board follow
up and so just to be clear I'm not
suggesting that it flipflop around
certainly all the time I'm suggesting if
the statute gives the appointer some
flexibility for the board to be able to
say we're finding that this number is
too little let's increase it to you know
so it's just giving Authority within a
preset margin for for policy or
procedure to set that that's the nature
of my question does that make sense yes
and I'll give that some thought and
we'll we'll look at it legally and come
come back to the subcommittee on
that any further
questions thank you for your time thank
you
director did anybody else wish to speak
1285 just uh when you're done if you
could fill out a pink card and send it
oh did you I don't have another card do
we this
one
oh
no okay I I will look for it but if you
just state your name for the committee
that'd be
on sorry I do have it it was my fault
okay thank you uh my name is Dr Natasha
bazasi I'm a practicing podiatrist out
of Portsmouth I've been in the state for
uh about 12 years now um I'm not going
to rehash everything that everyone else
has already said um but I just want to
touch on a couple things that I don't
think were mentioned um I do appreciate
your concern with one Podiatry member if
the boards were merged I do not think
that is a big enough voice um but we
have a unique degree we have three
different letters after our name that
aren't MD and do our training is unique
to us just like a dentist a chiropractor
and an optometry all of which New
Hampshire has their own
boards if you're thinking about board
merging the board of Podiatry and
Medicine why not throw every Medical
Board under it we are
unique just like those other Specialties
and we deserve to be heard and judged
licensed by our peers not someone with a
different training path than what we
have had and I don't think that's been
made overly clear um I oppose this bill
and I would I appreciate you taking the
time to hear me thank you thank you for
your testimony any questions yes
representative goto I would like to be
sure I got this in my notes so Podiatry
is different from other from the Board
of Medicine such as other boards and you
mentioned opt Optometry and what were
the other ones Chiropractic
Dentistry you're welcome thank
you no other questions thank you for
your testimony thank you did anybody
1285 seeing none will close the public
hearing on hb1 1285 and subsequently
because we're behind schedule open the
public hearing on HB 1286 and welcome
back representative McGuire to introduce
the
bill oh yes and uh 1285 is um sent to
subcommittee
leisure good afternoon again Carol
Maguire marac District
27 I'm introducing House Bill
1286 which is another item that was
pulled from House Bill
2 and it would merge the board of land
surveyors with the Board of Professional
Engineers
uh I'll say the same things that I could
say about the previous Bill the only
other valid point is that the board of
land surveyors and the of the land
surveyors and the Professional Engineers
are actually members of the same
Professional Organization that runs
their qualification tests which I was
surprised to see and they work they uh
work together frequently and
usefully thank you for your testimony
any
Joseph uh no you're good sorry I cannot
read the last name Joseph Wick wicker
thank
you
so H good afternoon um my name is Joe
wicker I'm a licensed land surveyor I
have uh been self-employed for about 35
years and I run a small uh five person
firm out of Manchester I'm currently the
chair of the board of lure for land
surveyors uh and I've been on the board
since
2015 I'm also I've been a three-year
member of the um professional surveyors
exam committee for the National Council
of examiners for engineers and surveyors
or
NCS uh I termed off that in 23 and I'm
currently a member of the surveying and
mapping Sciences task force for uh NCW
so on behalf of um our board myself and
our and the board are opposed to uh
House Bill 1286 which proposes to merge
our board and with the board of
Engineers so uh representative Maguire
had mentioned we're part of the same
National Organization which is what NCS
is so
NCS um they oversee and prepare the
national exams and um you know uh we we
we kind of work through their
organization to help us uh run our state
Ser our state exam programs but even
they treat every we're similar but we're
different so the the associations and
the issues are we're an Associated
profession but we're not Engineers
they're not surveyors and um our
concerns our items our discipline
they're all different because they have
different items so I you know this came
up last year and we heard different
reasons why the bill was popping up one
of them was uh licensing boards were an
obstacle to people wanting to work in
the State uh because of Market issues
right people on the board would try to
um obstruct people from uh from getting
a license for competition reasons so
most of us in our Fields have
significant backlogs the majority of us
are turning work away because we don't
have the staff to do that work
um so I don't really understand that
thought process uh if we had more
employees that were licensed we could
take on more work right both boards and
certainly our board tries to ensure that
applicants and the uh people in the
profession adhere to the approved rules
our rules have existed for many years I
don't think there have been any
significant changes in the last 15 or 20
years so I really don't understand this
sudden uh push to to merge boards um and
and sort of change what we have right
the board members all of us who serve
were volunteers many of us have have
mentored multiple people on their path
to lure help to set up their careers
just like was done to us and we're
trying to pay it forward I've also heard
that the boards are too slow and that uh
without the without the boards that
things could be handled by uh staff and
could be done more efficiently and
faster which would be uh better for the
public so in our case we meet four to
six times a year but we're we're very
aware of our our time deadline so if we
have a case that needs a 30-day response
or whatever our next meeting would get
scheduled such that we comply with that
response um you
know last year I believe there there was
a bill passed that puts the Authority
for licensing and discipline into oplc
hands and you know we're we're working
through that but there is a value to the
boards the boards are the ones that have
the experience and can oversee an
applicants uh application packet and
make sure that the what it qualifies for
surveying we have no education
requirement right education was deemed
as an obstacle to licensure so therefore
we have a path of experience it has to
be Progressive experience for six years
and you have to be able to maintain and
show that you move forward somebody that
doesn't know the profession isn't going
to be able to look at a resume and say
12 years here at this position is
considered responsible charge versus not
right if you're in a larger State such
as California they actually have
Professional Engineers and licensed
surveyors on their as the administrators
of their boards we don't unfortunately
or fortunately however you want to look
at it we don't have the population to
justify that but that's one of the
reasons why I believe the subject matter
experts have an important role and I
believe this bill would weaken that role
we also had heard last year that um
there were complaints about the boards
and the boards were unreasonable I've
been a member of our board for
approximately eight and a half years I
think in that time I'm aware of one
complaint it was an email to A A
legislator that said uh from an
applicant who had failed the state exam
twice who felt that the state exam was
intentionally too difficult um but what
it fails to mention is our pass rate is
probably been stable for six or seven
years at least and there have been a
many other applicants that have taken
the exam and pass so it certainly wasn't
a one-off and that other than that
that's the only complaint I'm aware of
another item I think we heard was The
Proposal is consistent with the majority
of the other
jurisdictions um in through NCW or in
Nationwide so I believe uh the
representative for NCW will be Prov uh
providing written testimony and it'll
give a breakdown of the various boards
so 39% of their boards I think there's
69 boards total are joint boards 36% are
separate Boards out of that 36% there's
17 and a half that are separate
engineers and 18 and a half separate
surveys and approx
25% uh include boards that are
constituted of surveyors Engineers
Architects and others right so there's
not one thread that's all that covers
everything but in addition you know what
what I think that those numbers don't
show is once constituted generally they
don't change so usually if you're stood
up as a joint board you stay as a joint
board if you're stood up as a individual
board you stay as an individual board
there's not a lot of back and forth I
think the last one I can recall that um
I think Texas about two three years ago
eliminated all their boards and then
stood up a joint board a year later and
depending on who you speak to the
results of that are mixed good bad it
all depends on perspective but I haven't
heard an overwhelming response say that
that's the perfect thing to do from a
national level as we sit New Hampshire
has two Vats out of a possible 69 if the
boards emerg that impact gets reduced to
one out of 68
so what I would say is respectfully that
I don't see any benefit to merg in these
these boards The public's not going to
see any difference they're going to have
to go through the same process so
nothing changes for them for the
volunteer board members we're going to
have more meetings and longer meetings
in our case you know we meet four to six
times a year the engineers would meet
monthly so we're probably going to go to
a monthly schedule you're going to take
what was done in two meetings put it
into one meeting so the number of hours
of that meeting are going to go longer
right we're all volunteers you're all
we're going to do is is make it harder
to get good volunteers to become a board
member which I don't think should be the
goal of legislation right and then you
know the other thing is in our case we
because we offer a state specific survey
exam twice a year our members go through
and grade the exam so we have four
people grading the exams that would be
reduced depending on how the new board
or the merge board would be constituted
but you'd have less right one of the
proposals last year was two Engineers
two public uh two Engineers two
surveyors one public so now you're going
to have two surveyors grading all the
exams because the engineers aren't going
to necessarily be able to do that and in
addition you're going to have those same
two two members are going to now have to
make the decision about an applicant's
experience or discipline or whatever and
the way uh should there be a discipline
investigation one of the things we
normally do is one member recuses
themselves and then the other members
kind of go through it and look at the
results of the investigation and help
weigh in on that so if we only have two
members one member recuses himself we're
you have one member basically making the
decision I think having the larger
talent pool is going to be better for uh
both the applicants and the public the
decision would be better you know there
could be some minor savings
on from the staff point of view because
they're going to have to cover a few
less meetings but like I mentioned
previously the meetings are going to be
longer so I don't know if there's any
significant change in that right most of
the renewals and things we do anymore
are done online I don't think that gets
changed at all you know and even if even
if there was a small increase by
maintaining what we currently have so I
I have a hard time saying it's an
increase but I guess we could argue it's
it's not a savings right you know I know
for our you know for our profession the
certificate of authorization which is
the fee we pay annually to for the
privilege of practicing in the state you
know increased and I think those you
know that that increased fee would
certainly
cover the cost of maintaining this uh
the services that we currently have
um you know I have not heard from anyone
in our professions that says that they
think this is a good idea so I think
this is a you know it was a a proposal
that probably was well intended but I
don't know if there was a lot of
discussion with the people in the
profession to do it you know if the
intent of this is to improve the
business climate in the state and reduce
the obstacle to lure I don't think this
is the answer you know New Hampshire has
a 400 person legislature because people
would have the ability to know their
representative and talk to them it's the
same thing with the board if I go to a
meeting or conference we're constantly
pulled aside and if if it's not a
confidential issue somebody will say
why'd you do this why how and things
like that merging these boards is going
to reduce that
opportunity um you know and we do you
know we shag calls from the public we
I've had in the last four or five months
we've had calls
regarding uh an inability renew a
license under retired status lack of
response from being CED the mandatory CE
broker program cost to get a certificate
um printed that used to be provided for
free right the boards aren't really
going to have input or can solve those
problems but at least we can we can
speak to the members in a way that
they're going to understand and say hey
this is what's going on you have to do
this this and that and I do believe
there's a value to that um you know I do
think that you know prior to this last
year or so we had um our board
administrators were had longtime tenure
in the board they had good institutional
knowledge and that's getting harder to
to have I mean currently I think we're
on our third or fourth administrator in
last six uh last six or eight months so
now we're talking the institutional
knowledge is coming from the board
members as opposed to staff um and so my
closing words be fairly simple you know
if it's not broke I don't think you
should fix it and I'm not really sure
that this is broke so thank you for your
time
thank you very much for your testimony
any
[Laughter]
questions thank well done thank you so
dolberg thank you sir uh my name is Mike
dolberg I am the vice chairman of the
board of Lancer Bears I've been on the
board since November of
2018 I have been a lan surveyor in New
Hampshire since
1982 licensed uh since 1988 I am also
licensed in Mass Main Vermont and I'm a
certified flp plane surveyor nationally
recognized by The National Society
professional
surveyors to butress Mr Wicker's
testimony um I was the board
representative speak I'm sorry sir um I
was the board's representative to the
exam uh subcommittee where we um spent
countless hours um going through our
database um in um verifying each and
every question that we have uh with a
source um one to protect the board two
to make sure the questions were Fair uh
three uh so that um if someone feels
they are grieved and they want to sue
the state of the board they don't have
much to uh to sue um reasons to sue
um we've also taken our statutory um
guidance where the exam has been
revamped to test for what we feel is
minimum
competency um all of the Master Level
questions that were on the exam the
gotcha questions are gone those were not
fair um
I had a few of those when I took my uh
exam back in
87 um they're again they're gone we're
trying to test for entrylevel minimum
competency and most of my fellow
surveyors that have H staff that just
received their licenses they don't let
that new um LS stamp plans for a year
because they're still green they've
passed their exam that doesn't mean
they're uh they're in that position to
uh be on their own yet um and very
important point is that if we have a
joint board with two members engineering
two members of
surveyors um we've lost that internal
database of knowledge for local state um
boundary law that's what we regulate and
that's very important if any of you have
ever built a house you want to know
where your setback lines are and where
can you put your million dollar house
and all of your life savings into you
want to hire a licensed Lancer bear you
don't want them uh just someone off the
street that's not um that's not licensed
um I would not be uh suited to sit in
Judgment of an electrical engineer a
mechanical engineer a civil engineer I'm
a licens Lance ofir and I think that
they'll speak to that um on the reverse
of that um
um if we don't have the four members on
the board of surveyors there is a
potential for harm to the general public
harm to the individual servers that may
have a complaint filed against them um
and the uh profession as a
whole
um that's it if you if you have any
questions I do my best to answer them
thank you so much for your testimony any
question questions representative Greta
thank you are land surveyors the work
that they do are they also do are they
also hired by municipalities and
planning boards and zoning boards and do
they not have to submit their their um
findings to their to those
organizations I work um we do a
significant amount of uh public utility
work uh Municipal work for highways
roadways um drainage design and the like
um
and every community that I know of hires
an engineer and a surveyor uh yearly for
their projects um and uh every every
application that goes before a planning
board for a lot line adjustment a
subdivision on site plan as a surveying
component and they all require um the
stamp of a licensed
professional which um we are a dwindling
Bunch um but that's like as M Mr worker
spoke
um we are backed up we could use another
half a dozen people yes I believe it
thank
you any other questions saying none
testimony forgive me ahead of time Mark
there close
[Laughter]
it
thank you so much uh Mark condo demat
traki um I'm representing the New
Hampshire land surveyors Association I
am the government Affairs director um
and I have the uh great privilege of
being licensed as both a land surveyor
and a professional engineer so I can uh
see from both perspectives you know how
this bill will uh will impact the
profession and you know I uh I agree
with what um both Joe and Mike said I'm
not going to spend too much time
reiterating the um testimony because we
believe in efficiency and um limiting
redundancies so that being said um from
from my perspective obviously the needs
of each
leny is different and unique um and
there are needs that Engineers require
that uh you know surveying and surveying
boards cannot provide and vice versa um
you know to to combine the two uh now
and in the fashion that it has been
proposed uh we don't believe is going to
increase any efficiencies we don't
believe it's going to limit redundancies
and and really you know as you've heard
from the two previous uh gentlemen that
testified it very well may have the
opposite effect um you know our job as
lies we are tasked with protecting the
health safety and Welfare of the public
um you know when you look at the
importance of professional engine ing
you know every day it impacts your lives
whether it's the water you drink or the
roads you drive on or the light switches
you flip Etc uh an engineer has their
hand in that and when you think about
some of the largest Investments you will
ever make in your lifetime such as your
own personal home um land surveyors have
a great impact in that so obviously
protecting the public and protecting the
Health and Welfare and safety of our
community is of the utmost importance
for us um the two professions are unique
in the sense that you know New Hampshire
is a colonial state and there are uh
unique land use laws in New Hampshire
that set us apart from engineering and
from other states and uh you know we are
not part of the US Survey System um
because of you know our Colonial ties
and Heritage
so the the other thing to keep in mind
is that as the two board members
testified um being a member of a board
is is a great honor and privilege uh you
know but it's also a lot of work I mean
it's a it's a lot of work and they do a
lot of stuff and to now reduce the
number of uh individuals that are going
to be you know overseeing and reviewing
and helping and processing and and
working in all of those different facets
of what they do um really essentially
doubling you know their workload
potentially you know it it makes it a
lot more work and a lot less desirable
to want to represent you know your
community and volunteer your time and
you know offer your services and your
expertise and your profession you know
for the greater good of our community so
uh with that being said anybody has any
questions I'd be happy to answer thank
you any
questions yes representative man py
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question uh you sit in a very unique
position of from both sides and you
touched upon the fact
that the workforce growth or need in the
communities you know the increasing
housing need and other needs so this
would impact can you elaborate a little
more how it would impact by combining
the two boards How would would it
negatively impact the public receiving
the asking for service so from from my
perspective as a consumer of you know
the the the license um I I can tell you
that there are times where I will reach
out to board members with questions with
clarifications um with concerns uh I
definitely think that this will slow
that process down which will again slow
my ability to respond to questions and
concerns from the public down which then
you know creates that Log Jam which then
only compounds as you go further out so
I I definitely think that that there
will be that effect the fact that you
know as Mr wicker stated you know he is
underst staffed um my company is
understaffed you can ask many people in
many different Industries and they will
say the same thing that that they are
underst staffed and then that wait time
only then compounds that ability to
serve uh you know you've gone to say a
restaurant and they've said I'm sorry
we're short weight staff and you'll have
to wait now for that service it's
similar um in the engineering and
surveying business where you know if you
are underst staffed and you now have to
tell somebody that they have to then
wait for that service you are now
delaying potentially large financial
investments um that may never
materialize as a result of that and you
know
by creating that potential inefficiency
you know you you're impacting real
people's lives with you know their
um representative goalie thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking the
question I just want to follow up on
that
so your
statement you're saying that merging
these two boards potentially may not
promote the efficiency that it says it
does here in the language of the
legislation
you enough further questions thank you
for your testimony thank
cochos uh thank you Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Alex kouis I'm
here in my capacity as the executive
director of AC New Hampshire which
stands for American Council of
engineering companies I'm not an
engineer and I don't claim to represent
every engineer in the state but we do
have a lot of employees in our
membership over 1500 we also have 70
member companies that employ those
individuals we are opposed to this bill
because we believe it's a solution in
search of a problem we also believe it
is premature to pass a bill like this
based on the bills that you passed last
session that have been signed into law
that haven't really even had a chance to
be fully implemented yet just to give
you some background information
according to the 2023 oplc annual report
there are almost 6,500 licensed
engineers in in the state of New
Hampshire in that same report you will
learn that the PE board had revenue of
537,500 brought before the PE board and
there were zero cases meaning there were
no
prosecutions according to the oplc
website the PE board met nine times last
year if you go back to 2022 they met
eight
times so just in summary 6,500 licenses
in the state they generate a small
Surplus with their budget revenue is
higher than expenses they had three
complaints last year
no
prosecutions they met nine
times so this would lead I think anyone
to believe that this is a pretty
well-managed board so I don't understand
here great thank you so much well I have
a couple other things but but I but I
will I would ask you to again what is
the problem we're trying to solve I I I
can't figure it out uh
I I won't go I think the gentleman who
spoke first went through a lot of the
reasons that have been floating around
this building about why this bill's here
I'm I'm going to just cut all that out I
do want to just bring bring it back to
last session and and the director of the
oplc said it you passed House Bill 655
six months ago I I think we need to let
that bill actually get implemented the
the PE board is one of the more Hands-On
boards they are as you heard they're
reviewing the applications they're
reviewing the the resums how much of
that responsibility is the oplc going to
take on I don't think we have the answer
to that yet so before we start passing
bills to consolidate boards let's figure
out what we passed six months ago and
see how that's actually working before
we start ripping things up uh you you
also had the the bill on the endorsement
substantially similar license what's
going to happen with that we we don't we
have no idea so there's a lot of angst
you know it's someone who works for a
lobbying firm that has a lot of people
who are licensed professionally there's
a lot of angst in the community about
what is going to happen this session
with with professional lenser so I I
would just ask you to keep that in mind
the other thing I want to point out
again not to say that these other
smaller boards aren't as important as as
6,500 lenses with Engineers but if you
look at geologists there's 500
geologists who were licensed in the
state you know under this bill they
would have their own separate board for
GE ologists under this bill as you heard
there'd be two pees for 6,500 licenses
you have chemical Engineers mechanical
engineers civil engineers environmental
Engineers geotechnical Engineers all
these different disciplines that that
aren't going to be
represented so again I would just ask
you to really take a hard look at this
bill and say why why are we here what is
it I I haven't heard any compelling
reason why we should take something
that's worked well for decades no one's
complaining about it why are we here I I
can't figure it out um so I would ask
you to
really kill this bill and and let's uh
let's go
home thank you very much I'll say okay
great I'm done now any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony appreciate it sorry sorry for
the levity but it's it's been a long day
hello um my name is Dave Gil I'm
actually representing the Board of
Professional Engineers here uh thank you
chairman for taking this time in
committee for listening to us the board
of Engineers is not in favor of this
bill strongly um as with House Bill 2
um that failed we are still against this
also and not to rehash everything that
the profession uh life the AR Architects
the landscaper no the land land
surveyors I know it's land something I'm
an engineer so I know it's again we're
so different you know but one thing that
was mentioned is we share the same group
The
ncees which is true they are holding our
testing they do all that work but when
we meet as a group we go to one area and
the surveyors go to a whole another area
um it is just a kind of a an umbrella
that monitors our exams keeps the scores
does some of the paperwork for us we
again our meetings are held separately
separate areas we are completely
separated the idea of the workload we
are all volunteers um having you know
we're averaging you know almost 40
applications a month and we're getting
through them all with all of us
splitting them all up now if we were to
all of a sudden lose two more Engineers
on the board now we're looking at even
more time to review these
applications uh it is a volunteer and
I'm proud to be a volunteer I'm proud to
be on the board um it's something that
I've kind of wanted to do to give back
to my community um I've always been a
volunteer in the state and volunteering
for the board is just as
important um let's see here um our board
does meet on a monthly basis we have
never had an issue with a quorum we've
always had our quorums uh when it comes
to other specialized items that might
pop up we are all notified and we work
our hardest to get back together another
quorum to deal with the issue as it
happens we have never had complaints
against us as a board U we've always
been very responsive very active um
we're not the ones holding up a lot of
the stuff again I don't want to go over
a lot of the same stuff um you know the
survey Engineers were different
different societies board um it's it's
we're just very much against this bill
um it's not serving the purpose that we
assume is as it was said in House Bill
down thank you for your testimony any
questions see thank you for your
time djus does anybody have any
again director Courtney anybody have any
questions yes we do sorry you never get
hook thank you all l z Courtney
executive director oplc and again just
want to clarify this was not put in at
the request of the office happy to take
any questions I would say that there's
been a lot of changes legislatively with
respect to six 55 409 what was House
Bill 2 if you look at the overall bills
package last year that was the
initiative from the governor's office um
it proposed some massive shifts a couple
of things obviously switching the
investigative function over to the
office in order to promote um a clear
delineation of responsibilities so you
don't have the same people doing the
investigations as the adjudications
shifts The Lure over to the oplc and I
think what's clear is that there has to
be objective standards and and we're
still working through some of the issues
with respect to boards that have
subjective standards in their licensing
process but then after that you know
essentially the question was okay the
board's um primary function is with
respect to rulemaking regulation and
adjudicating
cases um there were a lot of proposals
to merge various boards with the
understanding that boards would no
longer be meeting monthly in order to
review
applications so these bills are or this
bill is essentially just from last year
and proposes to merge land surveyors
with
Engineers um and you've heard from all
folks as to their thoughts as to as to
whether that should be the case um but
we're not taking a position I'm happy to
answer questions about how we would
operationalize that change thank you
representative leus you uh so these are
going to be similar to the prior uh bill
so and with regard to the Lance survey
board not the engineers I mean how many
lenes are there are there an trust
concerns that's first so off the top of
my head I do not know how many land
surveyors there are um you heard about
how many land um Engineers there are um
we don't currently have any concerns
regarding antitrust and I will say that
the board mergers
that I can't speak for the governor's
office but the board merges were were
not contemplated as as a remedy to
antitrust issues that's uh essentially
it was
these are boards that historically like
every board used to meet monthly to
review applications they're not going to
be doing this anymore so is there a need
to have that monthly meeting or can we
essentially consolidate those efforts
that was essentially the gist As I
understood it so it wasn't um the
mergers were not proposed to to deal
with State supervision
issues follow up um actually kind of
maybe answer the question I think we
heard certainly from the engineers I'm
may recall from the land survey is that
they're reviewing applications is that
the past process and has changed or will
changed or so my understanding with
their oh Bethany would you like
to I apologize uh Bethany katr division
director of Licensing um I was just
clarifying that with our staff so they
currently are reviewing when someone is
going to take the professional
engineering exam there was a process
there's multi-level steps to be
professional engineer but the approval
or denial process for the lure is still
held with the
office followup followup y thank you for
that um so I mean any other concerns
there's the typical ones uh uh it sounds
like there's not but you know Quorum
board meeting um anything else that
would raise concerns about in particular
I would think what I suspect is the
smaller board the no we don't have any
concerns and we're happy to support them
administratively I think what I would
just offer is this again and take taking
a position is that the goal of um a
board is not to represent the profession
and I think we've heard that a few times
today the goal is to protect the public
and um earlier you heard me explain how
there are different models in different
states one of the models is completely
public member majority that is a model
that some states use it's intended to
provide State oversight but we in New
Hampshire have a state board of
education that is is comprised entirely
of public members so so I just want to
um so I don't support the notion that we
need representation of the profession I
think we need expertise of the
profession to understand how it's
regulated but I think it's up to the
legislature to determine you know what's
the best composition in order to do that
yet not taking a position but um that I
just wanted to correct or make that
point okay thank you so representative
man no we're good representative goalie
thank you I just have to follow up on
that so has
there been any concern at all
about these boards made up of
professionals doing something not in the
Safety no I don't have any specific
no just want to make sure we're I'm
clear on that because it was not clear
whether having boys made up
professionals was truly in the Public's
best interest as to the way you had
worded it so I want to make sure we're
not we're okay with having these folks
on the boards the way they're set up yes
absolutely I'm sorry I wasn't clear all
I was saying is I heard today that
essentially merging the two wouldn't
allow us to represent our professions
and that's not the purpose of a regular
board the purpose is to protect the
public so if you change the makeup you
know put them together change however I
mean the whole goal is to protect the
competency any
else thank you very much thanks for your
time Mr chair if I may I do have one
quick question for the governor's office
up
good afternoon just for the record D
jurus representing the governor's office
thank you me and representative Brown
had has same concerns on the language on
page two line 15 and once again we go
back to statements in legislation and
says to promote efficiency and economy
eliminate redundancies and lure
requirements that just doesn't read
appropriately to me I mean the wording
of promote efficient deficiency in
economy
and it was also asked to members of the
board as to whether or not this is truly
efficient putting these two boards
together so I'm just concerned we're
putting once again language into
there I'm I did not draft the
legislation I I would defer to your
expertise on stat construction as
members of this committee and um so now
not speaking on behalf of the governor's
office uh I I would be happy to take a
purpose statement directly out if uh if
the committee so
wished yes representative Brown okay
thank you Mr chair and you made the
mistake we coming
up I'm not sure I had a
choice so for couple three hours here
I've been sitting
here
thinking as as one of the testifiers
said why why are we here why are we here
and and there's a lot of conversations
about what happened last year which I
wasn't on this committee then so I'm a
little bit naive on that but um does the
governor's office have any any specific
data
on um some of the the the issues we've
talked about lack of Quorum or or
meetings not being held frequently
enough or any of those issues that have
sort of been thrown around quite a bit
in the last days do you have does the
the government office have any data on
that that we could see so to to sort of
bolster up that position certainly so uh
right now I the only thing I would have
to share is anecdotal I'd be happy to
find some data for you I guess I guess
what I will say on on that point of why
are we here what is going on um as you
know right I mean if we're thinking
Civics 101 you all make the laws that we
have to execute in the executive branch
and um I think many of you know in last
year my my role as a director of
appointments all of the nominations for
all of these boards comes through my
desk it's a single person in the
governor's office and it's not just
licensing boards right any person that
govern names to anything comes through
this office and it's it's a lean mean
fighting machine um as we are in New
Hampshire but I I think i' I've had a
lot of experience firsthand on how to
execute the the law as it is and and our
only mechanism for doing that is to
approach you and say what do you think
could could we pass this idea around
could you even if you know we have
legislators that say I'll put it in I'm
I'm not going to work really hard but
we'll see what the committee thinks
sometimes they take it and they run with
it I think representative lakas has said
right sometimes he's dug really into
something that that he was passionate
about so we we can't change the law
right we just have to execute it and so
some of it is to look from that
perspective of just the board
Construction who is appointed where what
those members look like there there have
been challenges that we have found in
executing the law that you've given us
and and so what we have just said is
what do you think again again the
governor's only vote is a veto right he
doesn't get a vote on the floor um but
we don't we don't have a mechanism for
him to actually introduce bills we just
defer to your Authority and say hey
we're having some challenges ex like
executing this we're doing our best um
but what what do we think about that so
I I think that's that that's a big piece
of it and um as I mentioned before we I
mean our office the office of
professional licensure and certification
and any other executive department that
comes before you is I mean acknowledges
your Authority they they just do what
you you tell them to do in the law to
the best of our
ability that's a thank you that's a
Frank answer I appreciate that thank you
yes representative leas that just broke
brought up a a hopefully brief question
that is so about uh how many
appointments a year and how many
positions does the governors actually
appoint thousands thousands uh it it it
and I again uh at the risk of being
extremely Frank at uh you know 4:05 in
the afternoon uh there are a number that
we get to licensing boards are
prioritized because of their outsized
impact right an advisory um board not in
licensing specifically but in other
areas of the law might come to a lower
priority um just due to the you know the
nature to conduct business or the effect
on on constituents um but there's a lot
that that we don't get to there's
there's so much more that we could be
doing I mean it it is an expansive
number thank you I was just trying to
get a feel for the magnitude quite large
and could be much larger yes thank you
any further questions seeing none thank
you so much
once again did anybody else want to
yet how do I keep doing that I'm sorry
it's been one of those days I guess
it MERS of the comme turn that
on my name is Chris Maly I been a
professional engineer since
1999 um I'm here as a private C private
uh Citizen and professional uh with some
serious concerns on the merger of the
board as well as the uh in the bill
itself The Avenues for lure and the
requirements for the last n and a half
years I currently serve um on the PE
board I am the chair and I have been for
the last three years I've got one more
year in my
term there's a reason we have a five
member board for our professionals with
different backgrounds uh myself I am
civil with structural we have
environmental we have water Wastewater
and we have fire
and
chemical as just some of that because we
have to have a majority we have a number
of different applicants come in we are
very busy with the five with the four
pees and the one uh outside member
that's there typically they're someone
that has a legal background and the new
board member that just joined us
actually has a code enforcement
background which is very helpful as well
uh should complaints arise which they
often do um I know there was mentioned
there was only three complaints there's
a lot more than that there was three
complaints that were may have had
something to do with a lot of them are
just dismissed um or they're they're put
off to a civil matter uh and doesn't
involve the board or nor do we have
jurisdiction
I am concerned about Dr merging the
board to two uh engineers and two land
surveyors uh being involved with NCS uh
nationally as a
representative they are distinctly
different and I I heard it mentioned
earlier that to have someone from the
general public they can simply look at a
menu of qualifications and be able to
check a box without having the
experience in the field being a licensed
professional in my mind I don't think
any of you would want to drive over that
bridge of that person that was licensed
by someone that was in the administ as
an administrator just looking at a box
and they think that it meets those
requirements some of the lure the as I
mentioned earlier some of the steps for
a licensure that are in this new bill
are different from what they are
currently for what you have to have for
education for specific experience and
the discipline that you want to PR
practice and ethical standards some of
that in this is if I'm reading it
correctly which I hope I'm not uh
someone that has 16 years experience and
say they've practiced civil engineering
can go to the board and say I want to
have be licensed there's a lot of steps
that go into becoming a professional
engineer I been honored to serve and
continue to be honored to serve the
state um on the PE board is something we
all take extraordinarily serious because
we recognize that we are here as Lindsay
mentioned to protect the health welfare
and safety of those in New Hampshire
um certainly that use the roads and
everything else to do that someone so
elely touched on that Engineers are
involved with so I'm certainly opposed
to this um and I do hope that when the
time comes or if this goes forward I I I
kind of chuckle because I do think it is
an ill-advised solution looking for a
problem that really doesn't exist I've
been on the board for nine and a half
years we have never had a complaint
about being inefficient and processing
people through we take great pride in
doing that we all work very very hard to
make sure that someone is not held up
certainly for no reason at all that's
all I have thank you for hearing me
thank you very much any
questions seeing none anybody else wish
1286 Michael dolberg again for the Bo of
sures um we take our charge to protect
the general public very seriously um so
when a complaint comes into the board we
look at that um that complaint in that
light um and recently um and this is not
a slam on the opl staff on on the
licensing side but the the intricate
details of an applicant um the the
portfolios they submit and the paperwork
they submit is uh sometimes very lengthy
and
voluminous and um recently we've had two
applicants uh that were okayed by uh
staff to sit for the professional
licensing exam they did not have the
qualifications they did not have their
initial um fundamentals of surveying
exam um passed from the ncees they did
not have it
um we as as the professional surveyors
on the board we look at all that first
to see their qualifications to look at
their experience um if someone sends us
a package that they've spent the last
eight years doing construction layout uh
good for them that's the we need that
but that doesn't qualify you to make
boundary decisions um as a lance of air
and that's that's the Crux of the the
law is is is is boundaries rights of way
easements that um are critical to the
state railroads uh power companies um
you know that that that law as Mr Caro
de traki spoke to earlier the colonial
states law um is incredibly um intricate
and detailed in every single state that
touches us they're all different Vermont
um their laws are based on
um
on all the lawsuits that um that
occurred back in the 16 and 1700s and U
main everything's cified New Hampshire
is a little bit above both but mainly
just precedent um in Massachusetts a lot
of it's
um um in the statutes but the the the to
to look at someone's
qualifications from a sheer um office St
Point saying yeah well they've got six
years they can they do this um that's
that's not how we work that's not how it
works and to hand that off and and and
water that down by having only two
surveyors look at it and have staff take
that over um that does injustice to um
the state you're going to let people
through um that aren't
qualified even if they can pass the exam
some people are not qualified who
experience to to for that exam we have
specific requirements for responsible
charge and um if that is not met we know
as a board that they are not qualified
exam okay thank you very much thank you
appreciate your
testimony anybody else on HB
1286 seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing and journ for the day see
Carol